COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ODERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS WILL ALLOW. WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE OF IS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE FOR TODAY IS EIGHT
EIGHT SIX. ONE SIX NINE FOUR
AGAIN. EIGHT EIGHT SIX ONE SIX
NINE FOUR. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED AND MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME IN PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL BE WAIT
YOU'LL BE WAITING IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE
THEN READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE THAT YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL ALSO BE
MAINTAINING DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AT ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MONITORING SERVICE. OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR THE PARTICIPANTS TO
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. I
ASK THAT WE PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. TODAY WE HAVE FOURTEEN
BILLS ON THE AGENDA THEY'LL BE
HEARD AND FOLLOW ORDER EXCEPT
FOR THE CHAIRS BILLS MIGHT
WHICH WILL BE HEARD LAST. THE
ORDER MAY BE MODIFIED BECAUSE
THE VEIL ABILITY OF BILL
AUTHORS TO PRESENT AND THE NEED
TO COMPLETE THE HEARING AGENDA
IN A TIMELY MATTER. ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT WE HAVE FOUR BILLS ON
CONSENT- THOSE BILLS ARE ITEM
NUMBER NINE BY CENTER EGGMAN SB
THREE SIXTEEN ITEM RIVER TEN BY
CENTER ROCK SB THREE FIFTY
THREE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN BUT
CENTER BATES SP FOUR THIRTY
FOUR AND ITEM NUMBER TWELVE BY
CENTER PAN MYSELF SB TWO TWO
SIX. SO BEFORE WE BEGIN
PRESENTATION OF BILLS I SEE WE
SHOULD GO AHEAD ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PAN HERE CAN HEAR
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ HERE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GONZALEZ. CONSOLES
HERE GROVE. HER TADO. I CAN
HEAR HER TITLE HERE LEYVA HERE
LEYVA HERE LEON. ROTH HERE ROTH
BROUGH. WIENER YOU KNOW HERE.
THANK YOU QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED
AND I WANT TO WELCOME BOTH ARE.
THE NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
CONTINUING FROM THE PREVIOUS
SESSION'S WALLS ARE NEW MEMBERS
AS WELL I'M VERY EXCITED TO
HAVE ALL OF YOU HERE TODAY. FOR
BILL TSTIMONY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR MAY INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON BILL TESTIMONY.
EACH SIDE WE COMMITTED EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE CHAIR. SO IN HERE FOR
HEALTH COMMITTEE FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION I WILL COMMIT UP
TO TWO WITNESSES. FOR TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS OR MAXIMUM
OF FOUR MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE
FOR TESTIMONY. THEN ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY LET'S LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
THERE FILIATION WITH ANY
ORGANIZATION IF THE IMPOSITION.
ON THE MEASURE SO JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE WHICH IS
THE TESTIFIED BUT BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A DEFINITE END TIME FOR
THE HEARING. WHICH IS I BELIEVE
FIVE PM- IT IS FIVE PM I MAY
LIMIT THE TOTAL TIME FOR ALL
COMMENTS ON THE BILL TO ENSURE
THAT THE COMMITTEES ABLE TO
COMPLETE OUR HEARING AGENDA
TODAY. EVERYONE ALSO HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT TESTIMONY
ON ANY BILL BEING HEARD TODAY
ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE
SO IF YOU'RE UNABLE TO
FORTUNATELY BE ABLE TO TESTIFY.
VERBALLY YOU CAN ALSO SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR IF YOU NEED.
MORE TIME THAN YOU ARE ALLOTTED
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS ON
HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE. SO
WITH THAT- WE WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH THEIR FIRST ITEM-
ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS SB
FORTY BY CENTER HER TADO. AND
DAVE BE PRESENTING FROM YOUR
DESK- UP PLEASE PREPARE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL THANK YOU
THEIR DAUGHTER. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START OFF BY SETTING THE
COMMITTEES TECHNICAL MANAGEMENT
REFLECTED ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS. CALLING WE HAVE A
PROVIDER SHORTAGE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY WORSE. IN REGIONS
LIKE THE ONE THAT I REPRESENT.
AND SB FORTY ESTABLISHES A PRE
MED PIPELINE PROGRAM CREATING
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOUR YEAR
UNDERGRADUATE UNIVERSITIES AND
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SCHOOLS AND
LOCAL HEALTH CENTERS TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM
pREGIONS OF HEALTH CARE
OPPORTUNITY ZONES. AND DREAM
ABOUT GOING TO MEDICAL SCHOOL.
CALIFORNIA IS PREDICTED TO SEE
A SHORTAGE OF OVER FOUR
THOUSAND PRIMARY CARE
CLINICIANS BY TWENTY THIRTY.
AND REGION SUCH AS A CENTRAL
VALLEY BE INLAND EMPIRE AND THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY COMMUNITIES ARE
ALREADY EXPERIENCING THE PAINS
OF PROVIDER SHORTAGES LACK OF
NETWORK ADEQUACY AND HER ACCESS
TO TIMELY CARE. WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE NOW. IN MY
DISTRICT PATIENTS FACE LONGER
THAN AVERAGE TIME TO SEE IF A
PHYSICIAN OR EXPENSIVE TIME TO
TRAVEL TO THE NEAREST HOSPITAL.
IT WOULD HELP PRODUCE
PHYSICIANS WHO ONCETRAINED
WOULD CARE FOR SUCH COMMUNITIES
AND COME FROM A BACKGROUND THAT
WOULD HELP THEM HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WAY OF
LIFE THAT WOULD BE AN INTEGRAL
TO ENABLING THEM TO HELP STOP
OR LIMIT. THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICINE
SCHOLARS PROGRAM ENVISIONED SB
FORTY WILL HELP SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. OF YOUNG
STUDENTS WHO COME FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND
HAVE A UNIQUE UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW TO BEST SERVE. THESE
COMMUNITIES. IT IS ALSO KEEP
SOME OF THE STATE'S LOOMING.
OUR PRIMARY CARE. SHORTAGE I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES TODAY
JOINING US REMOTELY. DR NANCY
MENDOZA WHO WORKS IN DEPARTMENT
OF EMERGENCY MEDICINE AT KERN
MEDICAL. AND DIANA RAMOS EIGHT
STUDENT- COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENT WANTING TO PURSUE
MEDICAL SCHOOL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER TIDO UM WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE HERE BECAUSE
BEFORE WE CAN PROGRESS WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES SO I DID MY
INTERRUPT YOUR PRESENTATIONS
INTERTIDAL BUT LET'S. GO AHEAD
AND ADOPT THE SENATE RULES AND
WE WERE TURN TO THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AS OUR MOTION TO
ADOPT COMMITTEE RULES I SEE
MOTION FROM CENTER EGGMAN-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS JUST REMINDER TO TURN
ON YOUR MIKE WHEN YOU VOTE. PAN
HI AND I'M MELINDA'S HI.
MELENDEZ I EGGMAN HI. NONE I
YEAH THANK YOU EGGMAN AIKEN
SALAS HI GONZALEZ- I GROWTH HER
TADO HI A TOTAL AYE LEYVA ALL
LEYVA HIGHLY MON ROTH ALL RIGHT
ROTH AYE RUBIO WIENER. HI
WIENER AYE. BUT. THE VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO THE RULES HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
RETURN TO OUR PRESENTATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF. SB FORTY ITEM FILE
ITEM NUMBER ITEM NUMBER ONE- SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH-
DOCTOR MENDOZA- SO- MODERATOR
CAN WE PLEASE HAVE DOCTOR
MENDOZA ON THE PHONE LINE FOR
TESTIMONY. DOCTOR MENDOZA'S
LINE IS OPEN. I AM DOCUMENT AND
OF THIS BILL AND THEN YOUR CASE
IN THE MEDICALLY UNDER COUNTY
OCCURRING ASKING THE FOR HAND
COURT HELD OUTCOMES OF PATIENTS
LIKE PRIMARY CARE. I WOULD
ELECTED YOU ABOUT ON HOW TO
DECISION TO SEIZE THE POSITION
INCOME COUNTY I WAS REGIONAL MY-
IF NOT RIGHT OF THE- BUT MY
MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS PARENTS. I
AM TO SAY THE ON THE PART OF
HARD FARM AT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WITH ONLY A THIRD GRADE TEACHER
CONNECT I CAN'T ALWAYS
ENCOURAGED ME TO IN SCHOOL SO I
DIDN'T HOW DO AND ONE WORD.
DIDN'T HAVE ANY GUIDANCE AND
UNFORTUNATE BUT COMMON REALITY
MANY MINORITY STUDENTS FACE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IT WAS SURE
LOOKING PERSEVERANCE THAT I
CONTINUE MY STUDIES AT CSU
BAKERSFIELD AND ONCE HE'S
FEELING MEDICAL. I AM NOW YEAR
MAY READ PHYSICIAN AT COMETA
THE HOSPITAL WHERE I WAS BORN
BUT I LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
MIGHT TO BE A BIT IS A RARITY.
FOR MY FIRST HAND PUSH I CAN
TELL THAT THIS IS THE COLOR
LIKE MY ARE. WHY SHOULD ANYBODY
WELL I ATTEST TO HOW MUCH OF A
DIFFERENCE IT MAKES IN REGARDS
HELP COULD. WHEN A PATIENT HAS
TRUST AND POSITION FIRST WHEN
YOU SPEAK THE SAME WAY AS YOUR
PIECE YOU'RE READY NOT ONLY
BETTER REPORT INSTANTLY WE ALSO
CAN THE MEDICAL NECESSARY TO
MAKE AN ACCURATE. SOMETHING
THAT IS MADE THE COUNTRY SUCH I
CAN AND WITH MY PATIENTS THEY
COME TO ME THANK I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY BEING IN MY R.
WHEN YOU'RE BURST SEVERAL
ORINDA HEY HAS A BUNCH. I'M NOT
WOULD SLEAZY STROKE. ALL GARY
ADULTS EXAMINE WHICH COULD BE
AVOIDED AND THIS CALL THE
NORMAL COSTS ARE HELP SYSTEM
GLASS. THANK YOU. SORRY I
DIDN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND WITNESS STAND A RAMOS.
PLEASE HAVE DIANA RAMOS ON THE
LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE I
WOULD LIKE TO FIRST THANK THE
SENATOR MAISEL BATTLE AND HER
TEAM FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF SB FORTY.
HUNDRED MYSELF MY NAME IS
BANNER AND I AM CURRENTLY A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
STUDYING BIOLOGY I LOOK AT
HONEST COLLEGE FOR CALIFORNIA.
I AM A FIRST GENERATION COUPLE
LATINO COLLEGE STUDENTS AND IN
THE FALL I WILL BE TRANSFERRING
TO UNIVERSITY IN HOPES OF
EVENTUALLY PURSUE MEDICAL
SCHOOL. AT THE FIRST HAND IT IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE
HIGHER EDUCATION WHEN I BECAME
AWARE OF SB FORTY I WISH THE
PROGRAM WAS AVAILABLE FOR ME IT
PROVIDES A LOT OF SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES I WISH I HAD NOW. I
KNOW I WANT TO SERVE MY
COMMUNITY WHICH LIKE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN AND WITH THE
REGIONAL HUB IT WOULD ALLOW FOR
ALL HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS HOSPITALS AND
LOCAL HEALTH CLINICS TO COME
TOGETHER AND PROVIDE GUIDANCE
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF. I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
BUILDING A PIPELINE OF DOCTORS
WHO COME FROM AREAS WHERE THE
THIRD BECAUSE THE THEY SHOULD
SEE THE DOCTOR SERVING NONE
THAT COME FROM THE SAME
BACKGROUND HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE SAME EXPERIENCES AND
UNDERSTAND THE CULTURALLY IT
MAKES IT EASIER TO RECEIVE
CARE. SB FORTY IT'S REALLY THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM TO MEDICAL
SCHOOL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR SENATOR
MANY. THOUGHT WILL BATTLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. A DAY RAMOS
FOR YOUR TO. RIGHT- NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY NAME ORGANISER AND
ONLY WILL BEGIN- WITH ANY
WITNESS HERE IN A- SAYING NINE
AT THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE NOW
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANY
WITNESSES AROUND TWENTY FORTY.
TESTIFIED SUPPORT OKAY- ARE YOU
DO WISH TO TESTIFY ON THIS BILL.
OKAY NOW IT LOOKS LIKE SHE HAD
ART SO I KNOW WITNESSES ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT GONNA
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. FORTY- WE WILL BEGIN.
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. OKAY
SO- KEEP PLEASE TELL ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
AND THEN PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR THE- CUSTOMIZABLE IT. RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE TWELVE PEOPLE
WAITING TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
AND OUR FIRST. IT'S FROM LINE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIKE TWENTY SIX YEAR MY COULD
OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE YOUR MIKE AT THE OPEN.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YOUR MIKE AT
THE- HI MY NAME IS BONNIE
GROSSMAN I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FORTY SEVEN. SORRY HAVE
SIMILAR THAT WE ARE DEBATE WE
ARE TAKING TESTS MAY SUPPORT SB
FORTY. THAT'S FILE ITEM RIGHT
ALL RIGHT. I HAVE LINE ONE
THIRTY TWO SO I THOUGHT IT WAS
OKAY I WAS JUST- RIGHT PRICE
STAY ON MODERATOR US OR STAY ON
FOR THE PROPIONATE AND ANYONE
ELSE IN TESTIMONY SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY. WE HAVE THE NINE PEOPLE
WAITING- UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
NO WAY FOR ME TO TELL WHAT THEY
QUEUED UP FOR. AS FAR AS OKAY
WELL. WE CAN JUST OPEN THE
LINES AND THEN IF YOU'RE NOT
TESTIFY SB FORTY JUST SAY PASS
AND WE CAN KEEP MOVING. A LINE
FIFTY SIX- MY COULD OPEN. ONE
FIFTY SIX. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THERE ARE
BLOCKS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT WHAT LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
MATT ROBINSON WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE SAY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT. ONE LINE AT ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY. THANK YOU. THANKS
LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. THE
YOUR SERVICE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT AND SUPPORT
SB FORTY THREE. THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. LINE OF FORTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN JOHN
VALENCIA REPRESENT INDIA LATIN
EXPOSITIONS OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB FORTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. LINE FIFTY ONE YOU'RE MY
KIDDO. HELLO MARIO ESPINOSA
CLICK AND I THINK YOU TERM
MEMBERS I'M WITH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA BARBARA AN
INDIVIDUAL USER MY OWN IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY. THANK YOU
EXLINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD DOUBLE. LINE AT
ONE HUNDRED EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND.
EIGHT WHY NINETY SEVEN YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON YES MY NAME IS LEE
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE FOR BETTER
COMMUNITIES- I'M CALLING
REGARDING- ADVOCATING FOR SB
TWENTY NINE- A. B. C. OKAY
BROWN NETWORK THEY MIGHT HAVE
THE WRONG DID YOU SAY S. B.
THIS IS SB FORTY. IN SUPPORT.
OKAY. NEXT LINE TO ONE HUNDRED
NINETY THREE YOUR MIKE AT THE-
YES THANK YOU MY NAME IS LINDA
IS AREN'T I REPRESENT THE BUTTE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
I SUPPORT SB FORTY THINK HERE.
THANK YOU NECKLINE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR YOUR MIKE
ABOUT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF OUR WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT AT THE FORTY. THANK YOU
NEXT ONE. IN THE MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER PEOPLE
WISHING TO COMMENT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HE'S FROM
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL PEOPLE.
OKAY LOOKS LIKE WE JUST GOT ONE
FROM LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON SHARING
MEMBERS ARE HELPFUL WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU. AND MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER PEOPLE
WAITING TO COME ALL RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S NOW
MOVES TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO ONE LISTED
AS INFORMAL OPPOSITION- FOR
TESTIMONY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FORTY. C. NINE
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OR ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY I DON'T SEE NO
OKAY ENTERTAINMENT LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
MODERATOR WE PLEASE. OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. FORTY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN FOR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. WE HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE GIVE THEM THEIR
LINE OKAY SO AGAIN REMINDER ITS
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WHICH WOULD BE IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS POINT AGAIN WE'RE DEBATING
SB FORTY. A MODERATOR WE PLEASE
OPEN LINES FOR THE OPPOSITION.
A LINE OF ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO I'M SORRY
ACTUALLY I AM CALLING IN ORDER
TO SB FIFTY SEVEN OKAY PLEASE
HOLD ON WE ARE NOT AT THAT
POINT YET- WE'RE DEBATING SB
FORTY AND THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION. THERE ANY OTHER
LINES OPEN IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
FORTY AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER PEOPLE WISHING TO
COMMENT OKAY- SEEING KNOWN IN
THE QUEUE- QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS- I THINK IT'S ANYONE
WHO'S HAD TO TEAR UP HERE I
KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME
REFLECTION IN THE GLASS SO
SOMETIMES A LITTLE HARD TO TELL
SO JUST- WAVE AT ME THEY DON'T
SEEM TO HAVE YOUR ATTENTION BY
SEA CENTER ROCK. HAS A QUESTION.
I WORK THIS MIKE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW- I AM
PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT AN AREA
THAT LIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS
ALSO ONE OF THE MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALTHOUGH WE IN
THIS CHAMBER AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY OF SPENT A GREAT DEAL
OF TIME WORKING TO ESTABLISH A
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND MANY OF
THE SAME FOLKS HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO. DO
EXACTLY THE SAME THING AND THAT
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREA. YOU
NEED TO START EARLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE PROPERLY
MOTIVATED- AND EDUCATED SO THAT
THEY MAY SUCCESSFULLY ENTERING.
BY THE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THAT WE ESTABLISH UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. THIS BILL
DOES EXACTLY THAT IT'S AN
EXCELLENT BILL. AND I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
US A CENTER GROVE. I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A QUESTION
SENATOR I'M MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
I KNOW SINGER BETTE KERN COUNTY
WE SPLIT IT AND- I APPRECIATE
YOUR HEART FOR MAKING SURE
THAT- YOU KNOW WE HAVE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS OUT THERE TO
TREAT ESPECIALLY ARE REAL
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE. MINIMAL
HEALTH CARE- ANYWAYS BUT I
VOTED FOR YOUR BILL LAST YEAR
HAN I APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR
DIVERSITY OF DIVERSIFIER
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL DOES
NOT ADD. ANY MORE SLOTS IT JUST
ALLOWS FROM THE SAME SLOTS TO
BE SHUFFLED BETWEEN DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND NOT JUST PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HAVE
YOU GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TO HOW WE
MIGHT EXPAND THE CAPACITY FOR
MEDICAL SLOTS IN OUR MEDICAL
SCHOOLS. AND. THE COMMISSION TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION ZURCHER.
YES TO THE CHAIR SORRY. IN
ORDER THANK YOU MISTER CHURCH
SERVICE THIS BILL IS TO REALLY
ADDRESS IT SUBMITS BUILDING THE
PIPELINE AND IT'S TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HEALTH HEALTH HEALTH
EQUITY- OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN ALL REGIONS OF
THE STATE- THIS IS NOT
SPECIFICALLY ON A- BILL THAT
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE- THE SLOTS
THAT ARE ALLOCATED. AND IN
MEDICAL SCHOOLS THIS IS TO
BUILD THE PIPELINE EARLY ON SO
THAT THEY CAN GET TO MEDICAL
SCHOOL. I APPRECIATE THAT AS I
DO APPRECIATE THAT I WAS
LOOKING FOR THE IDEA OF. WE
DON'T EXPAND THE SLOTS AND WE
REALLY NEED TO EXPAND SLOT SO
THAT WE CAN AND PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS IN THE FUTURE
THAT WILL STAY IN CALIFORNIA.
SPECIFICALLY OROVILLE COMMUNITY
CENTER URBAN POPULATION AS
WELL- BUT I APPRECIATE THE BILL
I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL IDEA I
DO UNDERSTAND HOW IT CREATES A
PIPELINE- I JUST WISH THERE WAS
A WAY TO EXPAND SLOTS AS WELL.
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY SAYING
ON I IT THAT JUST HAVE A BRIEF
COMMENT QUESTION ALSO FOR THE
AUTHOR SELF AGAIN THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER TAUGHT OF FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORD I KNOW THE TWO
OF US HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT ACTUALLY TRYING TO
EXPAND- MEDICAL SCHOOL
POSITIONS WAS RESIDENCY
POSITIONS I KNOW THAT YOU WORK
WITH ME ON THE- BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
THE FUNDACION- RESIDENCY
POSITIONS AS WELL SO CAN TO SO
WE CAN TRY TO EXPAND THE SLOTS
CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO. HOW THIS
PARTICULAR BILL BUT ACTUALLY
HELP AND I KNOW THAT'S A ROCK
MADE SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THIS
AS WELL- BE ABLE TO HELP US
ACTUALLY EXPAND CAPACITY FOR
TAKING CARE OF PATIENTS IN THIS
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY. YES
ABSOLUTELY WELL IT'S REALLY HOW.
WE HAVE OTHER GREAT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE BEING THAT ARE OFFERED
HERE IN THE STATE THAT REALLY
ADDRESS IT KIND OF TOUCHING TO
OUT WHAT THE COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD MENTIONED THE SLOTS
AND A RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND
THOSE ARE VERY MUCH NEEDED BUT-
YOU HAVE TO REALLY BE
INTENTIONAL INTENTIONAL AS TO
WHERE WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
PROVIDER SHORTAGE OBVIOUSLY IT
SAYS IT'S NOT A STATE WIDE.
ISSUE AND IT WILL GET ONLY
WORSE BUT YOU GOTTA BE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT WHERE THE
SEVERE SHORTAGE HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN AND
HISTORICALLY IT HAS BEEN AN
REGION'S OUT LIKE THE ONES THAT
I REPRESENT REGIONS LIKE
OPTIMIZE I'D PUT A COLLEAGUE
FROM THE- RIVERSIDE REPRESENTS.
AND THIS BILL WENT THROUGH THE
OPPORTUNITY ZONES WILL LOOK AT
WHAT I READ WHAT. OPPORTUNITY
OUR HEALTH CARE OPPORTUNITY
ZONES- REQUIRED THAT THAT LEVEL
OF ATTENTION AND FOCUS IN ON IT
AND SO YOU GOT TO START EARLY I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A GREAT. IT'S
A GREAT BILL THAT ALSO LOOKS TO
SAVE MONEY TO THOSE. SEEKING TO
PURSUE A MEDICAL DEGREE
BECAUSE- ARE WE ALSOKNOW
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE THAT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE A MEDICAL DEGREE
YOU HAVE A LOT OF DEBT. AND THE
WHOLEIDEA BEHIND THIS BILL IS
TO. COLLABORATE BETWEEN THE
ENTRY OF THE- PRIOR TO ENTERING
MEDICAL SCHOOL COLLABORATE
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT SCHOOLS
AND FIND A WAY TO. MAKE IT MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES. OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SAYING NONE- YOUR
TOTAL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER TRICK I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THIS BILL IS ABOUT HEALTH
EQUITY AND MAKING SURE THAT.
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE BUT THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY
I'D ACHIEVING THEIR AMERICAN
DREAM AND PURSUE IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION. OKAY OKAY IT'S- THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
ROCK THE MOTION IS- DO PASS AS
AMENDED. AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE- REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI PAN HI MELINDA'S AYE
MELENDEZ AYE EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
AIKEN SALAS HI AND SALAS I GREW.
HER TADO I FOR TOTAL AYE LEYVA
LEYVA AYE LEE MON ROTH ALL
RIGHT ROTH AYE RUBIO HI RUBIO
AYE WIENER ALL RIGHT. WIENER
AYE. OKAY- I. THAT NINE NINE
OKAY THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
BUT THE BILL ONE. OF OKAY-
ACTUALLY DIED CAN YOU. HE
CALLED THE ABSENT EDITOR GROVE
GROVE I OKAY. THE BILL HAS A
TEN DENVER- CENTER EGGMAN DID
YOU I WAS GONNA MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- OKAY WE'LL DO
THAT THE END BUT HOLD ON. SO WE
ARE AT THIS POINT- WE AT THAT'S
TEN ZERO BUT WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL- FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT- NEXT BILL UP AXES WE
HAVE CENTER DORADO. SO ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FIFTY SIX. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO PLEASE BEGIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I'M HERE TO PRESENT-
SB FIFTY SIX A REINTRODUCTION
OF- OUR HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS
HELL FOR ALL SENIORS WILL
EXPAND MEDI CAL ACCESS TO
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND SENIORS. AGES SIXTY
FIVE AND OVER AT OR BELOW A
138% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE. MAKING LESS THAN
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. I WOULD QUALIFY FOR THE
PROGRAM IF NOT FOR THE
DOCUMENTATION STATUS. DESPITE
THE TREMENDOUS ADVANCES TO
REDUCE THE RATE OF UNINSURED
DOWN TO A HISTORIC LOW OF. SIX
POINT 8% UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE EXCLUDED FROM
THE ACA OR COVERED CALIFORNIA.
STUDIES SHOW THAT ROUGHLY 90%
OF UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIA DOGS
REMAIN UNINSURED. COMPARED TO
JUST 10% OF ALL OTHER
CALIFORNIANS IN THE SAME INCOME
RANGE. OF THE NEARLY TWO POINT
TWO MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT ONE AND A
HALF MILLION REMAIN UNINSURED
AND A ONE MILLION ARE LOW
INCOME. THEY ARE SHUT OUT
BECAUSE THEY WORK FOR
INDUSTRIES THAT DO NOT PROVIDE
HEALTH INSURANCE. THEY WORK AND
ESSENTIAL LOW PAID INDUSTRIES
LIKE FARMWORKERS ARE GOVERNMENT
WORKERS. UNDER CURRENT LAW LOW
INCOME UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS ARE
ONLY ELIGIBLE FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AND PREGNANCY
CARE. NOT INCLUDING DOCTOR
VISITS TO GET PREVENTATIVE CARE
FOR CONDITIONS SUCH AS ASTHMA
OR DIABETES OR HEART CONDITIONS
THAT MEANS THEY RELY ON
EMERGENCY ROOMS WHEN THEIR
CONDITION ESCALATES TO A POINT
OF CRISIS. UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS
MAKE UP NEARLY 10% OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE AND PAY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS AND LOCAL
AND STATE TAXES YET THEY ARE
EXCLUDED FROM ACCESSING THE
LIFESAVING SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
THAT THEIR TAX MONIES HELPED TO
FUND. LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT MR
BODY THIS SEVENTY SIX YEAR OLD
GENTLEMAN WHO COLLECTS
RECYCLABLES TO PROVIDE FOR HIM
AND HIS WIFE TO SURVIVE HE
CANNOT AFFORD HEALTH CARE. OR
THE FATHER DUCIC GARCIA. WHO
HELD OFF FROM GOING TO THE
DOCTOR BECAUSE WHEN HE BROKE
HIS ARM HE WAS THAT HE FEARED
THE COST WOULD DEVASTATE THE
FAMILIES ALREADY DIFFICULT
ECONOMIC SITUATION SO INSTEAD.
HE OPTED TO MAKE A HOMEMADE
SPLINT IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WE SHOULD EXTEND HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE TO EVERYONE. I
PROPOSE THE NEXT STEP SHOULD BE
ARE UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS. MORE
THAN HALF OF THE DOCTOR
UNDOCUMENTED OR PART OF MIXED
STATUS FAMILIES. UNDOCUMENTED
PARENT OR GRANDPARENT CAN TAKE
THE CHILD OR GRANDCHILD TO SEE
A DOCTOR WHEN THEY'RE SICK BUT
THE PARENT OR GRANDPARENT
CANNOT DO THE SAME FOR
THEMSELVES. ALMOST TWO THIRDS
HAVE LIVED IN THE US FOR MORE
THAN TEN YEARS. OF THE FIFTY
FOUR THOUSAND DEATHS LET DENOTE
WHEN IN THE COLD. LATINOS
ACCOUNT 4406% OF THOSE CASES
AND LATINOS OVER SIXTY FIVE
ACCOUNT FOR ALMOST 40% OF THE
DEATHS IN THAT AGE BRACKET. SO
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS SUCH AS
ASTHMA AND HEART DISEASE COULD
HAVE BEEN TREATED AND HELPED.
AT HOME IN ONE PART OF MY
DISTRICT IS LOS ANGELES LATINO
RESIDENTS HAVE BECOME INFECTED
WITH THE VIRUS AT MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE RATE OF WHITE ROSES
RESIDENTS THEY ARE NOT JUST
STATISTICS. THEY ARE
CALIFORNIANS THE COST OF DOING
NOTHING IS GREATER THAN THE
COST OF COVERAGE OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM WORKS BEST WHEN ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
PREVENTATIVE TREATMENT. THE
EMERGENCY PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
CRISIS IS NOT GOING AWAY WHEN
MORE PEOPLE FROM WEALTHY AREAS
GET A VACCINATION WE MUST
ADDRESS THE NUMBER OF UNINSURED
AND THIS IS ONE IMPORTANT STEP
IN THAT DIRECTION. WITH ME I
HAVE A SEVEN GARCIA FROM TOLD
ACT WHO WILL SHARE HER STORY
LOSE GUY AIGLES EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR TOWER DECK WHO
WILL PROVIDE TRANSLATION. AS
WELL AS WELL SAID THE ORDER OF
CASIO'S LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR HEALTH ACCESS TO PROVIDE
PULP POLICY TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR- AS A-
THERE IS A TWO MINUTE PER
WITNESS I WILL FORWARD THE
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR THE
TRANSLATION PART OF IT- BUT-
AGAIN REMINDER FOR THE WITNESS-
I'D IS TWO MINUTES FOR THE
ACTUAL. TESTIMONY THAT SHE'S
GOING TO GET. AND FOR EACH ONE-
SO WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD
BEGIN WE HAVE ISABEL GARCIA- I
BELIEVE IS GOING TO TESTIFY ON
THE PHONE LINE- SO IF YOU COULD
PLEASE- MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ISABEL GARCIA TO THE PHONE LINE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU.
AND IT ALSO GETS WILL NEED LOSE
LOSE K. GOES HE'S GONNA
TRANSLATE AS WELL I DON'T KNOW
HOW DID A SWAP PHONES-
MODERATOR YOU AND I HOPE YOU'VE
GOTTEN FACT THAT FIGURED OUT.
YEAH WE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR
ISABEL GARCIA'S LIFE OKAY DON'T
WORRY WE'RE HERE. OF. IF YOU
READY PLEASE BIGELOW YES. WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AFFORDABLE YOU GONNA
NINETY LET ME- SIMILAR I'M NOT
A- YOU KNOW FIGURES TO THAT.
SEVERAL PRODUCTS BUT A LIST
BELOW. THANK YOU FOR BECAUSE
SUPPORT YOU HE IS GOING TO BE A
MONTHLY IT'S A LEVEL. HELLO
COMPANIONABLE AFFECTED MONTHLY
HERE. THANK YOU BOOKS YOUR-
WELL HELLO- SEVEN ZERO THE
FATHER RIGHT OW BECAUSE
POPULAR LITTLE TOO FAR THANK
PUBLISHED HE OUT BUT SHE COULD
FOR WHAT YOU WANT TO HAVE AND
I'M BE READING IT FOR IN THEN
I'M GOING TO AHEAD AND- SO BEAR
WITH ME. WHEN I THOUGHT OF THIS
THE NEW IS. EIGHT SEVEN PM.
PHONE NUMBER THEY THOUGHT IT ET
BALL AND- CALIFORNIA. BANGLES
HAVE BEEN THANKS CORN YOU.
THREE METAL IT'LL THAT'LL AND I
GOT YES I'M A HIM THE MOTHER
LOOKED AT. ONCE OKAY ALSO
UPDATE TO. JACKET PLACE TO BE
IN THE AT THE RECORDING OF YOU.
AREN'T YOU DON'T ETHNIC MORE
UCBCP THIS. YET DETANGLE. YES
THING WORKS AS THOUGHT AT THE
MANY. REPORT THAT. YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T THE PHONE. YOU MAY
FEDERAL. VALDIVIAN DON'T THEY
MAY. IT FOR OVER A VIDEO OF.
FOR MORE ON THE COMMERCIAL. ACT
HANDLE MOTHER THINK THEY THINK
WHY YOU'RE SEEING WILL BENEFIT
YOU AND INCREDIBLE. SPECIALTY
FINANCES INTO THE WATER. AT THE
BEGINNING OF OUR CALL VIDA I'D
SAY IT'S A- AT THE PARTY. BUT I
WOULD WHILE WATER MISS HIM SO
THE MOVE APPLE. K. GENERAL
PEOPLE I'M NOT. INMATE BEATEN
FROM ABOUT. LETTER THAT. YOU
DON'T WILL BE RE. IT'S NOT
DON'T. YOUR TWO MINUTES NOW SO
IF YOU COULD TRAINS. HELLO MY
NAME HE GOT A- HERE I'M A
MEMBER OF BOTH A KIND OF AN-
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS OLD BY WANT
TO THANK THE VIRGIN GUADALUPE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO FIFTY. I AM
I'M SUFFER FROM CO IT THERE HAD
BEEN MANY MANY DIFFICULT DAYS.
I DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE AND BECAUSE OF FEAR I
HAVEN'T TO THE- I DIDN'T ON
REMEDY AND- THANK TO GOD. MANY
OF MY OF FRIEND HAVE DIED. I IT
DIFFICULT FOR TO GO TO SLEEP
BECAUSE I. NOT BEING TO BRING
IT IN WAKING UP. BECAUSE THAT
MIGHT- EIGHT I PREFER FOR MANY
ILLNESSES I HAVE NEVER ASKED
THE- ANY. I HAVE TO THINK MY
DAUGHTER ON MY BEING A SINGLE
MOTHER. I WORKED MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS IN FIELD WITH ANY
BENEFIT. I HAVE MY LIFE AND TO
THE STATE. RIGHT NOW I FEEL MY
AN OLD DRAGON THAT NOT GOOD.
BUT FOR ANY. BECAUSE OF MY AGE.
AND I DON'T AND I AM THE HERE
TRYING TO PROVIDE THIS KIND AND-
I HAVEN'T BEEN TO THE DOCTOR
ALTHOUGH I. I'VE BEEN HAPPY TO
MUCH FOR YOU. BUT I DON'T HAVE
I DON'T MANY. MANY OLDER LIKE
MYSELF THAT HAD GIVEN THEIR
LIVES DISCUSS. I'M ASKING YOU
BOWL OF CONSCIENCE AND PRECIP.
ALL THE ELDERS LIKE TO HAVE
GIVEN THEIR LIVES TO. BY GOOD
FOR THIS COUNTRY THANK SUPPORT
AT FIFTY SIX. I THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH- ARE NAY WITNESS IS-
JOSE TORE. CONSEILLERS FROM
HELP TAX IF YOU CAN PLEASE
BRING- PRINT THE LINE. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN CAN EVERYONE
HEAR ME YES PLEASE AGAIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN JOSE
TOWARD ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACTING CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT SB FIFTY
SIX WHICH WULD EXPAND. ALSO
MADE ACCOUNT ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE SENIORS OVER THE AGE
OF SIXTY FIVE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. RIGHT NOW
IN DOCUMENTS SENIORS ARE ONLY
ELIGIBLE FOR RESTRICTED SCOPE
MEDICARE WHICH COVERS ONLY
EMERGENCY ROOM CARE IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM IS HONESTLY THE
LEAST EFFICIENT MOST EXPENSIVE
WAY TO PROVIDE CARE AND IS NOT
A SUBSTITUTE FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE BENEFITS. COVERED
UNDER FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL NOW
MORE THAN EVER UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS NEED PRIMARY AND
PREVENTATIVE CARE AND THE
DISEASE MANAGE MANAGEMENT TO
ADDRESS CHRONIC MEDICAL
CONDITION THAT YOU'RE SIMPLY
HAVE. AND THAT MAKES COOPER
NINETEEN MORE SEVERE AND MORE
DEADLY BOTH IN THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AND AFTERWARD THE
UNINSURED LIVE SICKER BY
YOUNGER AND R. ONE MEDICAL
EMERGENCY. AWAY FROM FINANCIAL
RUIN. WHEN YOU COME. IN CARE.
ESPECIALLY PROUD THAT EXACT THE
MATTER CONDITION. THAT HAS
TARGETED SENIORS IN THE SAME
COMMUNITY. OF ESSENTIAL AND
EXPOSE WORKERS JUST LIKE IN THE
CASE OF IS THE PROGRAM'S SPEZIA
WHO JUST SHARED HER STORY ON
HOW COLD IT HAS GREATLY
AFFECTED HER. SHE IS NOT ALONE
IN HER STORY. BY EXPANDING
MEDICAID OUT TO UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS WE CAN COVER ONE
SEGMENT OF THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIANS
UNINSURED. AND STRENGTHEN THE
HEALTH IS THAT WE ALL RELY ON.
WE WOULD TAKE A LARGE STEP TO
ENSURE EVERY SENIOR IN OUR
STATE HAS ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
WHEN THEY NEED IT REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY WERE BORN BY PASSING
SB FIFTY SIX. FOR THESE.
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- WE'RE NOW
MOVE ON TO- WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT OF AGAIN THIS IS SB
FIFTY SIX SO WE'RE GONNA BEGIN
WITH THE GALLERY OF THEIR
TESTIMONY SO TO GET NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION SO IN THE
GALLERY ON SB FIFTY SIX IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BRAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION A VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OKAY SAY NO OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY AGAIN THIS IS
ON SB FIFTY SIX IN SUPPORT. AS
SAYING NINE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE SO MODERATOR-
HE PLEASE- PROMPTS INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO SERVE TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU MEDICARE FOR COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FIFTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THE END. ZERO
IF YOU WANNA GO AHEAD AND OPEN
THE LINES FOR INSTANCE THEY'RE
AVAILABLE. BLIND FIFTY ONE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. SHE HELLO I'M CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. PLEASE BEGIN
HI THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR MUNSTERMAN BURKE- GREETING
MY NAME MARIO LOOKALIKE I'M A
DOCTORAL CANDIDATE IN SOCIOLOGY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SANTA BARBARA AND HEALTH POLICY
RESEARCH SCHOLAR WITH THE
ROBERT WOOD JOHNSON FOUNDATION
THE VIEW THAT YOU'RE TODAY ARE
MY OWN OF THE PROWLER COMMUNITY
LEADER AND THE CONSTITUENTS OF
COMMUNITY MAP COMMITTEE MEMBER
SENATOR MONEY GOING ON IN
DISTRICT NINETEEN. I'D LIKE TO
SHOW MY SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE SIX
DIFFERENT BOOK OF MEDIC HOW TO
INCOME ELIGIBLE SENIORS AGE
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER THANK YOU
CARL THANK YOU THANK YOU WHICH
IS TAKING NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION BUT THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- NEXT.
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
SIX. HELLO TO PAY. YOU'RE MY
OPEN. THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS
THEIR BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. I JUST SAW BEHALF
OF ST JOHN'S WELL CHILD AND
FAMILY CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE AGAIN ON SB FIFTY
SIX BLIND. THE LION ONE HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT MIKE IS UP. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THERESA
STARK WITH KAISER PERMANENTE A
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE AT ONE HUNDRED NINETY ONE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
HEALING SOUP WITH BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE AT ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
OSCAR SANDOVAL- WITH THE LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND- JUST GOING TO
SUPPORT- THAT SENATOR DRESSES
ALLOCATION THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU AND NEXT LINE SB
FIFTY SIX. ONE FIFTY SIX YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. HI JENNIFER
MALEIC THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SENATOR OUT OF
THROUGHOUT THE BILL SENATE BILL
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ANDREA PERRY
REPRESENTING AUS MAD WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
A LINE OF THIRTY NINE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MADDIE INTEGRATOR I'M A MEMBER
OF THE ORGANIZATION CARE ACT
AND I'M CALLING FROM THE AND
THEN ENTIRE NINE THE PORCH AT
THREE FIFTY SIX I HOPE YOU
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS VIVIAN DAY ARE
MALE I'M A MEMBER OF TODAY'S
LEGAL CENTRE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
FIND A ONE HUNDRED FIFTY YOUR
MARKET OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
GENEVIEVE FLORES HARO WITH
ANYTHING GOING TO CONNECTING
WORK AND I'VE BEEN PROJECT FROM
MICHAEL DRUNK THE PART OF SB
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WHY TWO HUNDRED NINE YOUR MY
GET UP AND- GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS CLEAR RAMPING WITH
JUSTICE IN AGING WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. BLIND
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. THE MESSAGE THE LAND
I'M CALLING TODAY DEDICATION
TODAY TWENTY HERE AND IN AND
I'M CALLING SUPPORT AND. FIFTY
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WHY THIRTY
FIVE YOUR MY GET UP. THE LEGAL
IF YOU DON'T BUT TO THE HEARING
IN THE YOU'LL- IF IT CAN CAUSE
A. THANK YOU CRISIS TEXT LINE.
LINE SEVEN YOUR IS OPEN. HI
THIS BENJAMIN CHAN FROM THE AND
OREGON CENTER FROM. SB SIX
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU NEXT.
ALAINA ONE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI THERE
ARE NONE NUMBERS ON IT NOTHING
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF IN THE
ENTIRE AND I ACTUALLY PEOPLE
FOR SB SIXTY ONE DOLLAR PER DAY
THANK YOU EXLINE. I KNOW ONE
HUNDRED NINETY TWO YOUR MIKE AT
THE- WHAT A SERVICEMAN IN THE
AMOUNT OF MATURITY SO YOU'RE A
LITTLE BIT ON THE SYMBOLIC LAW
THAT AND THEN EMPIRE HERE FOR
YOUR INSTAGRAM SEE WHEN THEY
CITIES- COMPANION CYCLE OF THIS
BUT I'M HOPEFUL YOU'LL- GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
STRATEGICALLY SIGNED THE NUMBER
OF. THE ORGANIZATION TOLTECS
I'M CALLING FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORTS
AND REQUEST SUPPORT FOR SB
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. PROCESS.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. YEAH LINE
IT NINETY SO YOUR MY KIDS OPEN.
HI EVERYBODY MY NAME IS NOW I
WENT TO MY TO MAKE RIGHTS AND I
INTO OF AN FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
NEXT ONE. LINE SEVENTY THREE OR
MY COULD OPEN. ARAMBULA NUMBER
EIGHT ZERO NINE GETS A LITTLE
THINGS GOING THE PROGRAM IS NOT
AVAILABLE AT ELEVEN. O'CLOCK
YOUR THE TO THE IMPORTANT BY. I
FOUND ALSO QUITE PROCESS. ONE
NINE MEMBER OF QUALITY AND I AM
CALLING ANOTHER AND I THINK FOR
A BIT PACIFIC ALLIANCE PLEASE
ALSO BRING THREE FOUR BUCKS
WELL YEAH. DRESSED EXLINE. GET
UP. HI CENTERS ARE GETTING A
JOB BANANAS ON THE OF THE ALL
THESE FOR HUMAN RIGHT BUT THAT
THE UC CAMPUS ARTICLE USED TO
BE OR AND FIVE SIX HE THANK YOU
NECKLINE. THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
SAN. YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
BUSINESS WHEN ON BEHALF OF THE
FOR COMMITTEE- ON THE- CAL. IN
STRONG OF THE B. FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE TO HUNDRED EIGHTY HERE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS HUGE CAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BLUE OAK NETWORK EVERYONE
STOCKS UP IT'S GOING TO BILL
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU THANKS.
BLIND HER AND NINETEEN YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. A GOOD ACTORS
THAT I MEMBERS OF JEFF HANSON
CALIFORNIA SO THE HELP IT'S
GOING TO BE. SIX THANK YOU
EXLINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTEEN HERE MIKE AT THE OPEN.
HI THIS IS PHOEBE ABRAMOWITZ
WITH HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. BLIND EIGHTY THREE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS A ROBOT AMONG
WITH CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF AT THE
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. WHY TWO HUNDRED
TWELVE YEAR MIKE IS UP. EACH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR THE
MEMBERS THIS IS I THOUGHT
CAñADA BLACKENED SKELETON DOT
TO HELP ADVOCATES AND UNDERTOOK
TO SUNDAY IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
THE FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU EXLINE.
ONE TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN YEAR
MIKE IS THAT. HI MY NAME IS
NANCY NUMBER TO LONG BEACH
IMMIGRATION REGULATION AND I AM
SUPPORT OF. SB FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU EXLINE. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER PEOPLE WISHING
TO COME. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
NOW LET'S MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION- IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY FOR
FORMALLY LISTED- TESTIFIES FOR
OPPOSITION BUT IS THERE ANY.
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY FROM THE
GALLERY. THE NON LET'S REMOVE
THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY ARE THERE
ANY ONE TEST. THAT'S FINE
OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY FORTY
TWO AGAIN THIS IS S. B. FIFTY
SIX. SAYING NONE LET'S MOVE ON
TO OUR TELEPHONIC LINE
MODERATOR WE PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION S. B. FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMON IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FIFTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. MRE PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE TO SINCE YOU'RE ABLE TO
FOR OPPOSITION WITNESSES. CAN
WE HAVE ONE COMING THROUGH
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT WHILE
I GET THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER
RIGHT AGAIN THIS IS ON SB FIFTY
SIX.
THE PERSON AVAILABLE. IT
IS TAKING JUST ONE MOMENT LINE
ONE HUNDRED K. FOURTEEN YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. THANK YOU. HELP
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR MIKE ITSELF. THIS IS
WENT AWAY WITH QUESTIONS AND
ALL ON POVERTY COLLEGES THIS IS
FOR SUPPORT I HAD TO MAKE IT
INTO THE BACK QUEUE PARTICIPANT
THE PART OF THE EIGHTY SIX I
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH SO THAT
WAS SUPPORT ADDRESS NY ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY SIX.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. PLEASE BEGIN. ONE
ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. LINE NINETY ONE
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. I REMEMBER I
WAS ACTUALLY ON THE SUPPORT
LINE BY MY NUMBER GETTING A
CULTURAL QUALITIES FOR THAT
UNLIMITED THEM WITH WEDDING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF NEXT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OKAY THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. AND IS THERE
ANY WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIFTY SIX. ON THE PHONE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED THREE YOUR MY GET
UP. SH CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THIS IS BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
I TOO WAS IN LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY SIX THAT MY NUMBER WAS
CALLED TRIPARTITE FOR THAT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
TESTIFYING ON S. B. FIFTY SIX.
ONE ONE HUNDRED NINE YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. SENATOR PAN MEMBERS NO
I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU. EXLINE BLIGHTED FORTY NINE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI THIS
IS KELLY BRADFORD I ALSO
EXPERIENCED PROBLEMS I'M A
SUPPORTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE ALL IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY SECOND. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES ON SB.
FIFTY SIX. LINE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY TWO YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU EXLINE. WHY TWO HUNDRED
FORTY ONE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
YOUR MEMBERS KATHY MUSTARD WITH
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU-
MODERATOR HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE
ON THE LINE. WE HAVE TWO MORE
PEOPLE WAITING TO PROVOKE I'LL
TAKE THOSE TWO- AND THEN AGAIN
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE-
TRY TO GET ON THE LINE SO THAT
IF YOU'RE NOT THE THEN WILL
TAKE THESE LAST TWO IN THE MOVE
ON TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT. MODERATE PLEASE CONTINUE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
YOUR MIKE ITSELF. YES THIS IS
MARIANA MORE- FROM INSURING
OPPORTUNITY CAMPAIGN TO END
POVERTY AND CONTRA COSTA
SPEAKING STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I THANK
AND IN LINE TWO HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SALLY CHAIN WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER HE WRAPPED IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOT TAKING
ANY MORE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY SIX- JUST TO BE
FAIR- V. IT UP DOESN'T SUPPORT
JUST CLEAR THE LINES- IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON. THE
LINE. WE HAVE ONE MORE COMING
THROUGH THE STATE ONE OKAY IT'S
ALWAYS ALL RIGHT THEN WHAT
THEIR LINE. LAST CHANCE FOR
OPPOSITION. DO I BE FAIR AND
BLIND TWO HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT-
MY COULD OPEN. BY ONE WITH A
LINE CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT WHAT ABOUT THE
ABOUT THE- THE TECH ISSUE ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT FIFTY FIFTY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SO APPRECIATE ALL THE SUPPORT
THEY THINK OF YOU GET AN
ADEQUATE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
OPPOSITION IF THERE WAS ANY- TO
CLOSER TO QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST A
COMMENT I WILL I WANT TO THANK
THE- AUTHOR OF. THIS MEASURE
FOR HER EXTRAORDINARILY EXTRA
DAY ACTUALLY IN CONTINUING TO
PUSH- ISSUE FOR. YOU KNOW WE
WERE THE THIS ISSUE COUPLE OF
YOU AGO AND THE BY COMMITTEE.
WHEN WE WERE EXPE OF MEDIC CAL
AND SO OF US BUT INCLUDING THIS
OFF. QUESTION WHY ARE OR OR OUR.
OLDEST AND MOST VULNERABLE.
EXISTENCE OF THE STATE WERE
LESS OUT AND CONTINUE TO BE
LEFT OUT OF OUR- MEDICARE
PROGRAM. ENTIRELY UNFORTUNATELY
WE WERE UNSUCCESSFUL IN THAT
EFFORT AT THAT TIME. I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT THEN I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT NOW. ALLIES
THAT WE LIVE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET IT'S
UNPREDICTABLE. AND IT'S
CONSTANTLY CHALLENGED IN ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER- BUT THIS IS A
AN ESSENTIAL ISSUE IT'S A
CRITICAL ISSUE IT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
NOW. I THINK THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT MEASURE I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR HER
EFFORTS AND I WANT TO URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU A CENTER
WINNER. USING THE- THROUGH THE
FIRST OF. A THIRD AS A RUBIO
THANK YOU TRACK CIRCUITS OFF I
THINK SO THIS FOR ALL RIGHT
HOLD ON OKAY THE FIRM ACCENTS
I'M JUST GONNA CALL PEOPLE'S
NAMES AND TRY TO FINISH BUT-
OKAY. I DID RIGHT SENATE
GONZALEZ SENATE MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER TO AND I WOULD LIKE TO
EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU SENATOR I DID
ALSO I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED VERY
HARD. WITH MNY OF THE
ADVOCATES THAT HAVE CALLED IN
AND I WANT TO THANK THEM AS
WELL ESPECIALLY LONG BEACH
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS COALITION WHO
HAVE- BEEN JUST REALLY
PASSIONATE ON THIS ISSUE MANY
OF OUR OF FAMILIES WERE
UNDOCUMENTED- ARE OLDER.
DOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS ARE
STILL WORKING MANY TIMES AND SO
I THINK THIS IS A AN INCREDIBLE
APPROACH TO BE ABLE TO INCLUDE
THEM IN A WAY THAT IS MINDFUL
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS CALL BUT
NINETEEN CRISIS SO. AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU AYE SENATOR
BUT ALSO AND- I WOULD LOVE TO
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE
OKAY THANK YOU- I DID SEE
CENTER GROVE'S MICROPHONE GO UP
SO I'M JUST GOING TO. THAT
NUMBER BUT STRICTLY IN ORDER
PERCENT OF GROSS. I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I DO APOLOGIZE
TO THE CHAIR AND TO THE AUTHOR
AND I'M KIND OF BOUNCING
BETWEEN COMMITTEES AND SO I DO
APOLOGIZE. FOR THAT- I KNOW
THEY'RE STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL BUT I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IF THE AUTHOR WOULD
NOT- OBJECT TO ANSWERING THEM.
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM IS A
FEDERAL STATE PARTNERSHIP
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
REIMBURSEMENT- ON THE FINANCIAL
SIDE. IF THE STATE DOES NOT
RECEIVE THE FEDERAL FUNDING-
FOR THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM
ALLOWING MEDICAL. MEDICARE FOR
AND DOC. INTO WILL YOUR BILL
STILL REQUIRE THE STATE TO
PROCEED. AS A SOLELY- FUNDED OR
STATE ONLY SPEND A POGRAM. YES
I AM AWARE THAT THIS WOULD BE-
OUR STATE A STATE FUNDED
PROGRAM NOT A FEDERAL FUNDED
PROGRAM. SO IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
GONNA BE APPROVED BY THE FEDS
TO REIMBURSE THE STATE FOR
MEDIC CAL REIMBURSEMENTS. AT
THIS POINT. AT THIS POINT WE
DON'T HAVE THAT AND SO WE HAVE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE IT'S A
STATE FUNDED PROGRAM OKAY- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER STATES IN THE
NATION THAT HAVE A PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO THIS THAT YOU'RE
AWARE OF. YOU KNOW I HAVE IN MY
NOTES THAT THERE ARE- SIX OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE OF FOUR
CHILDREN- I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT A LIST OF WHO THEY ARE
BUT I WOULD. I COULD PROVIDE
THAT FOR YOU. THANK YOU I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE MORE AND- IS
THERE ANY DOCUMENTATION THAT
YOU HAVE ON ANY OF THOSE OTHER
STATES THAT ARE FINDING.
CHILDREN AS THIS BILL WOULD
YOUR BILL WOULD COVER ADULTS
BUT THE SIX STATES THAT PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR CHILDREN- DO YOU
SEE ACOSTA RESERVE AN ESTIMATED
COST OF WHAT THAT WOULD BE FOR
THAT THE TAXPAYERS OF THE
STATE'S. I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
IS. THAT IN THE OTHER STATES-
THERE'S BEEN ESTIMATES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- LAST YEAR I BELIEVE
IT WAS A NINETY FIVE MILLION
THE FIRST YEAR- AND UPWARDS I
THINK APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED. PLUS MILLION- THE
FOLLOWING YEARS. IT MAY HAVE
CHANGED BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT- THAT'S MORE OR LESS I
THINK. AND THANK YOU MA'AM AND-
ARE YOU CONCERNED AT ALL IN ANY
WAY THAT THE BILL IF PASSED
WOULD- IF THE BILL OF PASSED TO
PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED SWITCHED
OVER SIXTY FIVE WITH THIS TYPE
OF BENEFITS. DO YOU SEE
INDIVIDUALS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA- FOR THIS BENEFIT
BECAUSE IT IS A VERY GENEROUS
BENEFIT. WHAT WHAT I SEE IS
THAT THE PRIMARY REASON THAT
IMMIGRANTS COME TO THIS COUNTRY
IS EITHER BECAUSE OF.
PERSECUTION RELIGIOUS POLITICAL
PERSECUTION OR BECAUSE OF
EXTRAORDINARY ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS- AND WHAT IT TAKES TO
BE ABLE TO LEAVE THEIR
COUNTRIES WHETHER IT'S- ACROSS
THE OCEAN OR- A FEW COUNTRIES
AWAY- IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
SACRIFICE AND IT'S RISK TAKING-
I HAVE NEVER KNOWN OR TALKED TO
ANYONE WHO SAID THAT THEY CAME
HERE BECAUSE OF OUR- HEALTH. OF
COVERAGE SO I HAVE. NO REASON
TO THINK THAT THIS WOULD CAUSE
ANYONE TO LEAVE THEIR
COUNTRIES- BECAUSE OF THIS-
CARING. THE OTHER THING IS.
WE'RE PAYING. JUST WITH REGARD
TO THE OTHER QUESTION SENATOR
ALL WE'RE PAYING RIGHT NOW FOR
EMERGENCY CARE WERE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY CARE. THAT IS
FAR MORE COSTLY THAN
PREVENTATIVE CARE AND IT SEEMS
TO ME THE SMARTEST WITH REGARDS
TO- WITH REGARDS TO COST. IS
THAT WE- THAT WE DO IT IN THE
FRONT- AS PREVENTING NOT AT THE
END WHEN IT'S ALREADY. A CRISIS
AND IT COSTS SO MUCH MORE.
THANK I DO UNDERSTAND THAT
PEACE AND THAT'S EVIDENT WHY
ALL THE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
ARE ON THE SIDE OF THE BILL IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WOULD
REDUCE COSTS FOR EMERGENCY ROOM
CARE- I DO UNDERSTAND THAT I
JUST. I HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OFFERED TO
AND DOCUMENT IT'S WHEN WE HAVE
SO MANY US CITIZENS THAT ARE
UNEMPLOYED THAT ARE TRYING TO
DO WITH EDT BENEFITS LOSS OF
WAGES LOSS OF JOBS LESS
BENEFITS. AND IN YOUR OWN
ESTIMATE ON BASED ON THE NUMBER
SHE GAVE WAS NINETY FIVE TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
COVER THIS COST. BUT I
APPRECIATE YOU ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS THAT I LAID OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU LET'S START THERE WIENER
WATCHMEN NEXT. THANK YOU- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- I'VE ON
FULLY SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION
WHILE SERVING IT'S- MORAL
IMPERATIVE FOR US TO ENSURE
THAT ALL OF THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO- TO
HEALTH CARE- AND THE SENIORS
YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK THEY'RE
COMING HERE TO HEALTHCARE THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WHO HAVE OFTEN BEEN
IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR MANY MANY
YEARS- YEAH WHO HAVE
REESTABLISH HERE WHO HAVE. I
STARTED BUSINESSES HERE WHO
WORKED IN ANY PAYING TAXES AND-
AND THEIR IMPROVED STATE IN A
PART OF OUR STATE. THEY SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE DOCUMENTS- AND I
THINK WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE HEALTHCARE AND AS THE
AUTHOR. INDICATED IF YOU KNOW
RIGHT NOW WE'RE FORCING PEOPLE
TO GO TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM-
THAT IS MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
TAXPAYERS AND ACTUALLY
PROVIDING. PREVENTATIVE AND
EARLY INTERVENTION CARE- IT IS
GOOD IDEA THE A PROGRESSIVE
STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA WOULD
ALLOW. HI SENIORS TO LANGUISH
WITHOUT HEALTH CARE IS
UNCONSCIONABLE AND- WE NEED TO
DO THIS I KNOW THERE'S A COSTS
BUT IT IS. A WRITER'S COSTS AND
I HEARD AND I DON'T. THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER CENTER RUBIO AND
YOUR MAXIMUM. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I'M ALSO- CROWD TED
MY NAME AS A CLOT THERE TO THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BEING PERSISTENT AS
WELL. I AND I'LL JUST USE HER
WORDS- AND THE COST OF DOING
NOTHING IS MUCH GREATER. THAN
TRYING TO HELP THESE VULNERABLE
SENIORS GET CARE. AND AS MANY
ALREADY STATED- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY WERE GETTING
PREVENTIVE CARE AND NOT HAVE TO
PAY WHEN THE CRISIS IS ALREADY
HERE. I BELIEVE THAT ALL
SENIORS DESERVE OUR COMPASSION
AND OUR CARE. AND I ALSO WANT
TO REITERATE THE WORDS OF THE
WITNESS ON THE PHONE WHO STATED
THAT SHE GAVE HER LIFE. TO
CALIFORNIA. PICKING GRAPES AND
VEGETABLES TO PUT OUR OUR TABLE
SO THAT WE CAN BE HEALTHY. SO I
BELIEVE THAT SHE DESERVES THE
SAME CARE FROM US. APPOMATTOX
HERE TO READ BUT THE LOOK AT
THE WHOLE OF THE ODA. AND THAT
YOU'RE MEANT THEY THE OKAY
COASTAL DAY ASSET NAVA IS MUST
GET ON THE CABLE SO THE IDEA
THAT I LIKE IN THE THEIR STATE
THAT. HE MENTAL. GOING ON IN
THE LEFT NO AT&T ALSO. I IS THE
BOB. I THE LOCAL SECTION YELLOW
SAID THAT THEY SEE ALONG. YES
THEM AMOUNT SAY MAY A SECOND
TIME IN LOOK WE DON'T EIGHT AM.
REPORT IS STILL A STORY I WILL
AGREE ALSO THIS BUT OUT THOUGHT
CALL ON THIS THIS THAT. HE THE
LOCALS GET I GUESS. THANK YOU
ARE HEARD TONIGHT WILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER IR
EDMUND. THANK YOU CHAIR AND I
DO LIKE TO ADD VOICE MY- HAVE
ALREADY SPOKE THINKING THE
AUTHOR FOR HER TO NOW. AND
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS. AS
WHO REPRESENTS A- LARGE. OF
THAT- CENTER VALLEY. WE KNOW
THE VALUE. OF A- OVER NINETEEN
COULD. AND AS LONG AS WE HAVE A
PASSED CITIZENS FOR P. THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO HELP HERE
WHO. WILL NOT BE ABLE TO.
PEOPLE OF UP LARGE SEGMENT OF
THEIR LIFE WORKING TO PUT FOOD
ON OUR TABLE AND OUR SERVICE
INDUSTRIES- TO NOT HAVE HEALTH
CARE WHEN THEY'RE- AFTER OVER
SIXTY FIVE JUSTICE DOES NOT
FEEL LIKE A- A MORAL IMPERATIVE
THAT ANY OF US WANT TO AND-
EMBRACE. WE KNOW THAT
PREVENTIVE CARE ISSUES AROUND
THE SHE'S. PULLING YOUR LOW
WAGE WORKERS AROUND DIABETES OR
HEART DISEASE- CANCER ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE ELEVATED
BECAUSE OF. A LOW WAGE WORKER I
AM A LIFE AND SO FOR WHEN
PEOPLE GET TO THAT AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE TO NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE
HEALTH CARE TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH THOSE ISSUES THAT HAVE
ACCUMULATED OVER A LIFETIME
JUST FEELS WRONG SO I AM HAPPY
TO BE VOTING FOR THIS AND BE A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS AS WE TRY TO
PROVIDE CARE TO THOSE OF US WHO
NEED IT MOST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR EGGMAN ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING NONE-
SANDRA'S ONLY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. I
WAS PROUD TO VOTE FOR. YOUR
PREVIOUS BILLS ON THIS I KNOW
THAT. WE AS A SENATE HAS. PUT
THAT IN OUR PREVIOUS BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND WERE ON. ASKED
SADLY- THEY DID NOT MAKE IT.
THROUGH TO THE FINAL BUDGET BUT
PERHAPS- WE MIGHT SUCCESSFUL.
THIS YEAR- WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- ALL MY COLLEAGUES-
I'M VERY TOUCHED BY ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS. AND DAHLE IN IN HONOR
OF- YOU SEVEN GARCIA AND SO
MANY OTHERS LIKE HER. WHO HAVE
IN FACT INVESTED THROUGH TAX
DOLLARS. THEY ARE NOT JUST COME
IN HERE FOR SOMETHING FOR FREE
THEY'RE WORKING FOR AND THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH URGE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND I TO
WANT TO THANK AS WELL GARCIA
THE END FOR TESTIFYING IS OUR
MOTION ON THE BILL. OKAY I SEE-
YES THAT'S ARGUES OFFICES MOVE
THE BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
BUT REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HAN HI
CAN I MELINDA'S OKAY. MELENDEZ
NO EGGMAN HI EGGMAN ARKANSAS
ASIDE GONZALEZ I GROW HER TADO.
LEYVA ALL LEYVA AYE LEóN ROTH
ALL RIGHT ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
RUBIO AYE WIENER HI WIENER AYE.
SEVEN ONE. OKAY SO THAT'S
CURRENTLY THE LOTUS SEVEN ONE
WILL BE HOLDING THE ROLE OPEN
FOR- AND FOR ME THAT ABSENT
MEMBERS THANKS VERY MUCH
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU POLITICS
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FIFTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR WIENER IF YOU
WERE PRESENTED THE DESK PLEASE.
MEDIAN THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIRMAN- I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL- SENATE BILL FIFTY
SEVEN- WHICH WILL. AUTHORIZE
THREE PILOT CITIES SAN
FRANCISCO OAKLAND. AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. TO PILOT. A
SAFE CONSUMPTION SITES TO
ADDRESS. THE OVERDOSE EPIDEMIC
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING. A TO
HELP GET PEOPLE INTO RECOVERY.
BOB MY FIRST ONE TO. NON CENTER
MEN WHO HAS BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE SINCE BEFORE I WAS
EVEN THE LEGISLATURE. ANA AND
SHE HAS FOUGHT THE GOOD FIGHT
FOR YEARS INCLUDING GETTING
THIS LEGISLATION ON TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- WHO UNFORTUNATELY-
COULD NOT SIGN A BILL- BUT WE
ARE DETERMINED. TO MAKE THIS A
REALITY TO ADDRESS. THESE THIS
VERY VERY REAL. ONE THIS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A LOCAL CONTROL
BILL IT SIMPLY AUTHORIZES
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE
REQUESTED TO BE IN THE BILL
EACH OF THESE- SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND L. A. COUNTY HAVE
OFFICIALLY REQUESTED TO BE ON
THE BILL. AN AUTHORIZING THEM
TO MAKE THE DECISION LOCALLY
WHETHER TO DO IT AND UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WHERE AND SO
FORTH THIS IS ABOUT LOCAL LOCAL
CONTROL FOR THIS PILOT PROGRAM.
FIVE SIX CONSUMPTION SITES ARE
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
ARE PROGRAMS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
USE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES-
THAT- THE THAT THEY BRING WITH
THEM UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
STAFF. TRAINED TO PREVENT AND
TREAT OVERDOSE IS TO PREVENT
HIV AND HEPATITIS INFECTION.
AND TO FACILITATE ENTRY INTO
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT AND OTHER SERVICES
SUCH AS HOUSING. THESE SITES
ARE NECESSARY INTERVENTION TO
PREVENT OVERDOSE DEATHS.
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE- OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS EXIST IN TEN COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD. THEY HAVE
BEEN RIGOROUSLY RESEARCHED AND
THEY HAVE BEEN SHOWN WITH PEER
REVIEWED STUDIES TO REDUCE
HEALTH AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH DRUG
USE- INCLUDING PUBLIC DRUG USE
TO REDUCE OVERDOSE DEATHS. I TO
REDUCE SYRINGE LETTER TO REDUCE
HIV AND HEPATITIS INFECTIONS
AND TO KEEP PEOPLE ALIVE. ARE
THESE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS IN
TEN COUNTRIES AROUND HE WORLD
OPERATING MANY OF THEM FOR
DECADES THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A
SINGLE RECORDED OVER THOSE
STAFF. EVER IN ANY OF THESE
FACILITIES NOT ONE OVER DEATH
COMPARE THAT TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON OUR STREETS TODAY.
THE CENTERS ALSO REDUCE
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS AND
PARAMEDIC CALLS WE KNOW THAT IN
OUR CITIES ARE EMERGENCY ROOMS
ARE OFTEN OVERLOADED- COVE IT
HAS SHOWN US WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU LOCK HOSPITAL CAPACITY. AND
THESE SITES AVOID SENDING
PEOPLE TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
UNLESS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL. BYE STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN CONTRARY TO SOME OF THE
VERY MELODRAMATIC CLAIMS OF
SOME OF THE OPPONENTS THAT THE
CENTERS DO NOT INCREASE CRIME
IN THE SURROUNDING AREA. IN
FACT THERE ARE SOME STUDIES
THAT SHOW THAT IT DECREASES
CRIME IN THE SURROUNDING AREA.
THEY REDUCE SYRINGE LETTER
WHICH I KNOW IN MY COMMUNITY.
THAT IS A HUGE ISSUE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE BILL DON'T WANNA
SEE SYRINGES ON THE GROUND. AND
THE SITES REDUCE SYRINGE LETTER.
AT LEAST SITES HELP GET PEOPLE
IN THE RECOVERY AND THAT IS THE
ULTIMATE GOAL WE WANT PEOPLE TO
GET THE HELP. THAT THEY NEED.
WE KNOW FROM STUDIES. THAT A
GOOD PERCENTAGE OF THESE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO USES SITES AND UP.
AND RECOVERY OR THEY AT LEAST
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF DRUGS THAT
THEY ARE CONSUMING. WE ARE IN A
TRUE EXPLOSION OF OVERDOSE
DEATHS. FROM AND IT'S GOTTEN
WORSE WITH COVERT OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS SINCE THE SHELTER IN
PLACE STARTED THE DAILY RATE OF
OPIOID DEATHS IN L. A. COUNTY
GREW BY 58% IN SAN FRANCISCO
LAST YEAR MORE THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE DIED OF OVERDOSE
DEATHS. IN OUR CITY. AND IN THE
FIRST FEW MONTHS OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE ARE ON PACE TO
BREAK. THAT RECORD NUMBER OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS. WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW IS NOT WORKING AND WE
NEED TO GET OUR CITY'S TOOLS TO
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT. WE ALSO
KNOW FROM STUDIES THAT THESE
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS IN
ADDITION TO SAVING LIVES SAVE
MONEY AS WELL. THIS A TAXPAYER
FUNDS IN TERMS OF REDUCING
WHO'S GOING TO BE OUR- THE BILL
REQUIRES A BEFORE CITY AUSTIN
BY A VOTE OF THAT CITY COUNCIL
OR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. BUT
THEY MUST CONVENE AND TAKE
INPUT FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
OVERCOME PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS THE BILL ALSO SUNSETS
IN SIX YEARS SO WE CAN
EVALUATE. THE PROGRAMS. THE
ALTERNATELY WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION DOES IS RECOGNIZE
THAT DRUG ADDICTION IS NOT A
CRIMINAL ISSUE IT'S A HEALTH
ISSUE. THAT REQUIRES HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS WE SHOULD PROVIDE
OUR CITIES WITH ALL AVAILABLE
TOOLS. TO HAVE THIS HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS AND TO SAVE
PEOPLE'S LIVES THE BILL IS
SPONSORED AND SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD ARRAY OF ORGANIZATIONS.
WHOSE JOB IT IS TO HELP PEOPLE
WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER-
INCLUDING SOME OF OUR SPONSORS
SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ADDICTION MEDICINE. AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. FOR CALLING THIS
IS AN IDEA WHOSE TIME HAS COME
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTES- WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
NOT PHYSICALLY WITH ME BUT IN
SPIRIT. R. I. DAVID CONN- ANDY
WHO'S AN ADDICTION PSYCHOLOGIST
AND IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE. AND PICK
ISON WHO IS THE PRESIDENT CEO
OF HEALTH RIGHT THREE SIXTY-
WHICH IS AN AMAZING PROGRAM IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHICH AMONG OTHER
THINGS HELP PEOPLE HEALTH
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. HE'S
ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM-
EXECUTIVES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR WIENER- SO WE
HAVE FAR TOO LEAD WITNESSES AS
YOU MENTIONED WE HAVE- THE
DOCTOR CAN AND DOCTOR AISIN-
EACH OF YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES MAXIMUM FOUR MINUTES AT
THE PRESENT SO- MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE BRING- FIRST DOCTOR
CAN ON THE LINE. TO TESTIFY.
THERE. WE'RE TRYING TO ISOLATE
THAT LINE JUST ONE SECOND OKAY
THANK YOU OKAY THIS IS KIND OF.
AND. DOCTOR DOCTOR HERE AND YOU
HEAR ME YES IS A DOCTOR CHANCE.
YES ALL KIND OF SLOW RIGHT NOT
AT LAW DOT CAN FLOW SO CAN OKAY
LOOKING FOR DAY CAN. NO TO DO
NOT- OKAY NEED TO TALKING TO
DIFFERENT PER RIGHT YEAH AND AT
IT THE DATA THE. IT'S LINE
SHOULD BE OPEN DOCTOR. YES
HELLO DOCTOR ON YOUR IN YOUR-
YEAH IT BEGIN TWO MEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME'S DOCTOR DAVID KAHN
I'M IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE OR C. SAM
SHORT. YOU CAN REPRESENTS OVER
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PHYSICIANS AND ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS YOU'RE THE VOICE
OF DETECTION TREATMENT WILL
COST BECAUSE BOXERS OF
LEGISLATION. AUTHORIZING PILOT
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
ARE- COMPETES FOR SHORT. IN MY
EXPERIENCE PEOPLE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TAKE TIME TO CHANGE WE
NEED TO MATCH THE AVAILABILITY
OF TREATMENT SERVICES WITH THE
DEMAND. THE FIRST LAST AND
ENDURING TASK OF EGYPTIAN
MEDICINE IS TO KEEP PEOPLE
ALIVE. AS SENATOR WIENER
MENTION WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
AN OVERDOSE CRISIS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TIMES MORE PEOPLE
CHAPTER CISCO DIED FROM FATAL
DRUG OVERDOSE AND KOBLET.
MOREOVER THESE ARE PATIENTS
HAVE BEEN TREATED POORLY BY THE
TRADITIONAL MEDICAL SYSTEM.
I'VE BEEN FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT THE IMPACT
CLINIC IN VANCOUVER. WHICH IS
AN OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAM.
AND I'M I RECOGNIZE THERE WAS
THE SAME. MAN MAKE THAT I SAW
WITH MY OWN OPIOID TREATMENT
PROGRAM A METHADONE PROGRAM
THAT RAN THE SAN FRANCISCO VA
MEDICAL CENTER. INTERCOOLER
DOES PREVENTION PROGRAMS IT'S
CLEAR THEY PRODUCE PUBLIC DRUG
USE YOU SEE DECREASE. IN
DISCARDED SERVICE CARELESSLY
DISCARDED SYRINGES. CRIME IS
REDUCED. HIV AND HEPATITIS C.
INFECTION RATES DECREASE. AS
MENTIONED THERE BEEN MILLIONS
OF USERS OBSERVE WITHIN SUCH
PROGRAMS AND NOT A SINGLE OVER
DOES THAT TO DATE. I MORE
PEOPLE WOULD ACT THE PROGRAM SO
MUCH MORE LIKE TO ENTER AND
STOP USING DRUGS. MOREOVER
THESE PROGRAMS REACH THE
PATIENTS THAT I CANNOT AS A
POSITION WORKING IN ADDICTION
TREATMENT. AND OVERDOSE
PREVENTION PROGRAM IS TREATMENT
THERE'S NO CONFLICT BETWEEN
SUPERVISORS SUPERVISING DRUG
USE AND STOPPING TRUCKS THEY'RE
PART OF THE CONTINUOUS CARE.
I'M IN THE BUSINESS OF HARM
REDUCTION ABSENCE APARTMENT
HARBORED ACTION FOR A FIRST JOB
IS TO KEEP THE PATIENT A LOT
OVER THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
PROBABLY PRUDENT I'VE SEEN WITH
MY OWN EYES. ANCHORAGE'S SENATE
HELP COMMITTEE DID TAKE AN AYE
VOTE ON SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ON TIME-
LET'S THEM MOVE ON TO THAT GUY
ICIN DR VICTOR ISON. WE BRING
THIS AFTER NINE MANY MISTAKEN
I'M I'M HERE- THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ALL TODAY MY NAME IS THE COULD
I THINK HAVE YOU HEARD IN THE
CEO OF HEALTH FOR THREE SIXTY
AND ALSO. ON THE BOARD OF SCAD
PEOPLE TO PROCEED Y.
DESTINATION DEDUCTION TREATMENT
PROVIDERS WE BOTH A CO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL. I'M ALSO A FORMER
INJECTION HEROIN USER AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING IN THE TREATMENT
FIELD FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
RIGHT BUT YOU CAN TREATMENT HAS.
BUT TREATMENT HAS EVOLVED OVER
THE YEARS AFTER AS HEALTH CARE
RETURN. AND OVERNIGHT.
ACCORDING TO THE EVOLVING
SCIENCE DON'T TREATMENT
PREVENTION OF. WELL THE ANSWER
IS THERE- LET AT DID YOU MEET
YOUR- YOUR DEVICE THAT'S NOT MY
LINE. MY LINE RIGHT MODERATOR
CAN YOU DO YOU KNOW THIS IS
WAKING. WE HAVE ISOLATED THAT
LINE AND NEEDED THEM OKAY OKAY
WHAT TO PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY.
THANK YOU- FRIEDMAN HAS EVOLVED
OVER THE YEARS S. HEALTHCARE
MUST ACCORDING TO OF ALL THINGS
SCIENCE AND TREATMENT IS
EFFECTIVE. BUT IT'S NOT
EFFECTIVE IN THE SAME WAY FOR
EVERYONE FOR THOSE WHO FOR WHOM
WE HAVE NOT SUCCESSFULLY REACH
WE NEED TO BE WILLING TO DO
SOME THINGS DIFFERENTLY. FROM A
TRIP IN PERSON PROVIDER
PERSPECTIVE FOCUSED PREVENTION
PROGRAMS HAVE TO CRITICAL
PURPOSES TO REACH THOSE WE HAVE
NOT REACHED A SEPARATE TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM DYING
BEFORE WE CAN REACH THEM IT'S
REALLY THAT SIMPLE. BUT A LONG
TIME TO BE PROVIDED WITH TV
SERVICES. MISSING ELEMENT IN A
CONTINUUM OF TREATMENT SERVICES
TO THOSE WHO SAY WE SHOULD BE
SPENDING MORE MONEY ON
TREATMENT WE SAY YES WE SHOULD
AND THIS IS A PART OF IT. IT IS
A FALSE ECONOMY TO SAY IF WE DO
ONE WE ARE NOT COMMITTED TO
DOING THE OTHER. THERE'S A
PREVAILING MYTHS THE PEOPLE WHO
STRUGGLE WITH ADDICTION MARKET
OF SO CALLED BOTTOM BEFORE THE
SEQUEL COVERING WELL LET ME
DEBUNK THAT MYTH FOR YOU. MANY
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE WITH THEIR
DRUG YOU STILL LIVING IN ABJECT
MISERY WE CANNOT MAKE THEM MORE
MISERABLE CRIMINALIZATION AND
INCARCERATION. OR DEMONSTRABLY
FAILED POLICY RESPONSES TO
ADDICTION ONLY SLOWING OUR
PRISON POPULATIONS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES. AND
COUNTLESS PEOPLE DIED ON THEIR
WAY TO THIS MYTHICAL BOTTOM
NEVER GETTING AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR TREATMENT. NO MISERY AND
SHAME DO NOT LEAD PEOPLE TO
RECOVERY ONLY HOPE IN
CONNECTION WITH THE HEALING
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
BUILD CONNECTION AND LEAD TO
HOPE AND LINK PEOPLE TO CARE.
AND DO IT EVALUATION OF OTHER
SUCH PROGRAMS IN CAT IN CANADA
HAVE SHOWN THIS TO BE TRUE.
THIS IS A LIFE OR DEATH MATTER
IT MAY SEEM DIFFERENT BUT ONCE.
UPON A TIME SYRINGE ACCESS
PROGRAMS OF NEEDLE EXCHANGES
WAS CONSIDERED RADICAL
METHADONE PROGRAMS A RADICAL
AND MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT RATHER TIME IS UP
IT'S TIME TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
SINCE WE BEGAN DISCUSSING THE-
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THANK
YOU FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE
DIED EITHER WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A SYSTEM. THANK. YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT- THAT LOOK NOW MOVES
TO OTHER WITNESSES AND SOME.
NAY ALL ORGAN. AND TO- SO SIR
ANYONE TO. IN THE- ON SB SEVEN.
A SINGLE IN THE GALLERY. DO WE
HAVE A WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON
S. FIFTY IN ROOM TWENTY. OKAY
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE- MODERATOR-
KEEP PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TESTIFIED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FIFTY SEVEN.
AND THEN- PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER YEAH AND THEN PLEASE
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY
BEFORE WE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FIFTY SEVEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE. BUTTON ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
TO PLEASE LET ME KNOW HOW MANY
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT.
SO FAR WE HAVE. NINE PEOPLE
EIGHT PEOPLE ARE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT- ONE THING I'M JUST GOING
TO BE CONSCIOUS OF THESE I'VE
HEARD THERE MAY BE A LOT OF
PEOPLE TESTIFYING THIS IS ONLY
THE THIRD ITEM IN OUR HEARING
WE STILL HAVE ANOTHER SEVEN
ITEMS TO GO WE DO HAVE A HARD
STOP TIME SO IF THE TESTIMONY.
GOES ON TOO LONG I MAY PUT A
NAME TO BE SURE AT LEAST EQUAL
TIME FOR BOTH SIDES BUT- AND
THEY PUT A CAP ON THE TOTAL
NUMBER PUBLIC COMMENT WE TAKE
IT SO IF- IF THAT'S GOING TO
IMPINGE ON THE REST OF OUR
TESTIMONY SO WITH THAT. WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE LINES.
COLLIDED TWO HUNDRED. FORTY TWO
YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN. THIS
TESTIMONY SUPPORT UNDER SEVEN.
WHITE TWO HUNDRED FORTY TWO
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. LINE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR MY
KIDS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA ACT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT FIND. WHY
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE YOUR
MIKE ABOUT THE- GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA THANKS REPRESENTING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HELLO
TANTRUM M. WITH THE STUDENT AT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS
GOING SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU THANKS LINE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
YOUR MY KIDS UP. BLIND TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE YOUR MIKE
AT THE OPEN. MY DOCTOR ARE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE SIXTY NINE YOUR BIKE IT UP.
HI THIS IS CHRISTINA LADY AND
THAT RESIDENTS AND THEN TO GO
ON A MOM AND I SUPPORT SB FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WHY
NOT TWO HUNDRED FORTY YOUR MY
KIDS UP. BIGELOW DELUCA ON
BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND MAYOR IN
THE OAKLAND CITY COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. WHY TWO HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR YOU MIGHT GET UP. WESLEY
SABER ON BEHALF OF GLIDE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND STROKES SUPPORT
OUR GRATITUDE TO THE AUTHOR AND
CO SPONSORS OF THIS LIFESAVING
THAT THANK YOU IF YOU'VE JUST
TO NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
PLACE NEXT. NEXT LINE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR YOUR MIKE
ABOUT WHAT. EACH HEARING KANSEN
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
EXPLAINED. LINE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO
WILL BE HAPPY TO COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO BE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXLINE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX YOUR MY
KIDS UP. BACCARIN CALLING BACK
IT'S FOR DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
LIKE TO READ THE LIST OF CO
SPONSORS FOR THE LEGISLATION TO
THE RECORD PLEASE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE
NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION HEALTH RIGHT THREE
SIXTY. CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF DRUG AND ALCOHOL PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES TARZANA TREATMENT
CENTER AND APOSTOLI THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF SOUL A LIST OF- IF
SUPPORTERS AND ANALYSIS AS WELL
THANK YOU. EXINE WHITE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR MIKE
IS UP. MEMBER CUNNINGHAM DALY
RETIRED HOUSE. IN THE MARGINS
IN THE DAY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU EXLINE. LAKE HUNDRED FIFTY
YOU'RE MY COULD UP. HELLO MY
NAME IS KATHERINE K. WITH THE
NATIONAL CLUB- AND WE ARE IN OF
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER PEOPLE WISHING TO
COMMENT. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH.
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO CAN DETECT
FISHER'S NOTE THERE ARE PEOPLE
ON THE LINE. SURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AIRLINE TO FORTY TWO YOUR
MIKE IS UP. GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
PEOPLE WISHING TO COMMENT OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE UNDERSTAND
TWO PEOPLE REGISTERED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SO FIRST
THOUGH LET'S BEGIN WITH THE- I
JOHN LEVEL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
KOTICK OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SECOND
PLEASED WITH THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEED NIGHT THERE IS OKAY-
MR LEVEL PLEASE- BEGIN. OKAY I
AM NOT HEARING SOUND YET DO WE
HAVE- USING THE MICROPHONE ON
HERE. OKAY ARE YOU SPEAKING CAN
YOU ALL HEAR ME OKAY I CAN HEAR
YOU NOW OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU JOHN LEVEL- WITH THE GROUPS
THAT- CHAIRMAN PAN THAT YOU-
YOU MENTIONED- WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL- FOR SEVERAL
REASONS FIRST OF ALL WE BELIEVE
THAT GOVERNOR BROWN GOT IT
RIGHT WHEN HE VETOED THE BILL
THAT CAME TO HIM THE FIRST
TIME- BECAUSE OF A LACK OF THE
COGNIZABLE PATHWAY TO
TREATMENT. SECONDLY THE TIMING
OF THIS BILL RIGHT NOW GIVEN
THE COVE AND- NINETEEN- ISSUES
IS JUST SIMPLY OUT OF SYNC
LET'S LOOK AT A COUPLE OF
STUDIES OF THE- OF THE PROVINCE
OF ALBERTA DID A STUDY OF THE
SIX- DIFFERENT- INJECTION
SITES- IN THEIR PROVINCE AND
THEY FOUND A COUPLE OF THINGS
FIRST OF ALL IT'S A MAGNET-
INJECTION SITES ARE A MAGNET.
FOR PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES TO GRAVITATE TO THAT
LOCATION BUT SRPRISINGLY THE
USE OF THE ACTUAL INJECTION
SITE BY CONTINUOUS USERS IS
RELATIVELY LOW IN THE ALBERTA
PROVINCE IT RANGES FROM TWENTY
FOUR PERCENT. DOWN 23% OF THE
DIFFERENT SIX SITES IN
VANCOUVER THE CONTINUOUS USES
5% WHERE'S EVERYBODY ELSE
EVERYONE ELSE WHO'S DRAWN INTO
THAT CREATES A CAULDRON OF DRUG
USE THAT RESULTS IN DEATHS IT
IS CORRECT THERE ARE NODE THERE
ARE NO DEATHS AT ANY INJECTION
SITE BUT IN THE PERIMETER
AROUND THOSE INJECTION SITES.
THERE ARE DEATHS IN FACT IN THE
ALBERTA STUDY IT WAS FOUND IN
THE PERIMETER AROUND THE- SITES
SIXTY FOUR PERCENT- DEATHS BUT
LET'S TALK ABOUT COVERT NOW
YOU'RE DRAWING. A VULNERABLE
GROUP OF PEOPLE. IN TWO EIGHTY-
IN A CAR. AND THAT OVER
PROBLEMS IN FACT- THE- YEP DONE
ON LAST FRIDAY IN THE GLOBAL
NEW SWITCH WATER LEVEL YOU'RE
TWO MINUTES IS UP. BUILT NEW
TIGHTS. THE VANCOUVER AREA THE
DOWNTOWN EAST SIDE MR LEVEL
YOU'RE TWO MINUTES IS UP- I'LL
GIVE YOU A LITTLE EXTRA TIME
BECAUSE THE OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT WHEN BUT THAT YOU CAN.
THINK ABOUT WRAPPING IT UP.
YEAH IN ONE TOWN EAST SIDE
WHICH IS WHERE THEIR DEBT-
THEIR SITE IS. IN THE VACOUVER
AREA THAT IS THE HIGHEST
INCIDENCE. OF COVERT NINETEEN.
IT JUST BLOWS AWAY EVERYBODY
ELSE. OF THIS HAS THE THIS WE
BELIEVE IT'S GOT TO BE. PAID
ATTENTION TO AYE THANK YOU I
WILL STICK AROUND IF PEOPLE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS- ABOUT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR LEVEL
THERE'S A SECOND WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- KENNETH LOW- BRING
KIND OF FLOW ONTO THE PHONE
LINE. I'M HERE. ALL RIGHT-
PLEASE THE- THIS CANTALOUPE IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE PLEASE BEGIN
YEAH. YES I'M HERE SO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE BEGIN.
OKAY TWO MINUTES OKAY MY NAME
IS KIND OF LOW YEAH. MY NAME IS
KENNETH LOW A RESIDENT OF
WINTER BUT BC CANADA AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE AND YOU COMMISSION
REGARDING DRUG INSIGHT THE NAME
OF THE SIXTEEN FACTORS HOUSE.
THANK YOU FOR. SHARING TRYING
TO ANSWER FOR YOU CAUTION
REGARDING SAFE INJECTION HOUSE
FIRST ONE OF SAFE INJECTION
HOUSEKEEPING OVERDOSED ON
SAFELITE ACCORDING TO A REPORT
FROM THE B. C. SANTOS SPECIES
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
NUMBER OF OVERDOSE DEATHS IS
STILL INCREASING EVEN AFTER
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF THE OPERATION
OF THE SAFETY CONCERNS. IT'S UP
TO SHOW THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
OVER TWO DOZEN. 200-082-2000
SEVENTEEN THE HIGHER YOU START
GETTING HIGHER AND HIGHER THAN
A NATURAL CAUSE OF DEATH ALMOST
LIKE CAR CRASHES SUICIDE
COMBINE. AND IN THE CORNER WE
SERVICE- REPORT ON THAT AFFECT
WHERE YOU LEFT IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE SHOW TO SAY WE ARE A
TEAM. SO INITIAL MOST DRUG
USERS DO NOT USE SAFE INJECTION
HOUSE NO MATTER HOW HEAVY
ADVERTISED EXISTENCE OFF THE
SAFE INJECTION HOUSE. IN THE
LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS. ETHICAL
REPORTS FROM THE- OF THE FAMILY
THIS IS OFTEN. YOU KNOW WHAT TO
BECAUSE SEVEN. GIVE US A ONE
PLEASE COME. YOU SEE ONE
OVERDOSE DEATH WHAT HE WENT
ANYWAY. SO AFTER CHANGING FOR
MORE TOOK POLICY. AND YOU CAN
ONLY SAVE ONE. ANYWAY DO YOU
THINK THIS GOOD REACHED TRAVIS
CHECK HEALTH. I DO NOT THINK SO.
RUSSIAN AND THE IN YOUR HOUSE
PROVIDES ENVIRONMENTS BUSINESS
AND BY. ACB NEWS WERE ON TEND
TO THE TWENTY COAL. THE COMPANY
OF THE CHINA CURRENTLY A QUOTE
BEEN HEARING SO MUCH AN
ENTRANCE YOU SCARED TO COME
DOWN TO CHINATOWN. THE REASON
SAFE INJECTION HOUSE WHICH
LOCATE JUST. THE STREET ALL
TRYING TO TALK ANOTHER CALL.
THE WIND BLOW UP THE TO SHOP
WHERE. FORTY EACH MONTHS LOS.
MORE SHOP OWNER NOW DO YOU
STILL TO WORRY COURSE. IN THE
WINDOW BECAUSE THEY KNEW WHAT
THEY WOULD PREFER. YOU CAN'T GO
ANYWHERE BECAUSE TO THE
INTERSTELLAR. AND IT'S ALWAYS
ACT. OKAY- I HAVE SEEN THAT
LOOK AWESOME I DID AT LEAST A
HUNDRED IF NOT OCCUPY THE
TREATMENT THE STREET THANK DR
YOU- MISTER THANK SORRY YOU'RE
TIME IS A- THANK THANK SO MUCH
FOR TO. ALL RIGHT BOB WHEN I
GOT MOVED TO WHAT OTHER WHAT.
AND OP- NAME OR- AND TO. SO
BEGINNING THE PUBLIC GALLERY OR
ANY TO TWENTY OPPOSITION OUR-
SCENE NINE MOVED ROOM TO FORTY.
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY NOT POSITION.
NOT SEEING ANY OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION- MODERATOR WE PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO S. B.
FIFTY SEVEN- WHICH INTENSIFIED
OF ON THE TELECONFERENCE OF
THIS AND THEN- PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY BEFORE YOU
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR COMMENT IN OPPOSITION. TO
SB FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND SO FAR WE HAVE.
SEVENTEEN PEOPLE WAITING TO
PROVIDE COMMON. OKAY WELL WE GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN- SO UP PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES AND- AGAIN IT'S
NAME ORGANIZATION AND THEN
POSITION WHICH OF THIS CASE
IT'S OPPOSITION TO AGAIN THIS
IS- S. B. FIFTY SEVEN. LINE ONE
HUNDRED I APOLOGIZE LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YOUR MY
KIDS UP. HI I'M TONY LEAVE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO I STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS DISASTROUS BILL
SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR MY KIDS UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORY CELLS ARE LOW ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN YOUR MY KIDS UP. THIS
IS KELLY READ ON BEHALF TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA SAFE URGING A NO
VOTE ON SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU NECKLINE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE I COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JESSE ST I AM A MOM OF A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD SON MY WHOLE
FAMILY AND MY ENTIRE GROUP OF
TRAINEES COMMUNITY PEOPLE ARE
IN OPPOSITION SB FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR.
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU EXLINE. WHY
LET NINETY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD THAT. HI MY NAME IS
BENJAMIN CHUNG ON THE RESIDENTS
AT THE CISCO DISTRICT ELEVEN
AND I'M OPPOSITION SB FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
THANKS LINE. WHITE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTEEN YOUR MY KIDS UP. WHITE
ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NOT
AT THE MOMENT I LIVE IN
LEICESTER CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT ALL YOU'RE DOING IS
ENCOURAGING DRUG USE THANK YOU
WHICH IS THE AND NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION THANKS SO
MUCH NEXT LINE. WHY IT TOO
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD UP. HELLO- GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME PRINNY BROWN I'M- FROM
MOUNTAIN VIEW- TRACKS AND
ROBBERIES THAT ARE CLOSELY
RELATED TO THE CRIME SCENE
QUITE. ON ANYTHING AS SOON AS
OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND- POSITION
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WHITE A
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY YOU'RE MY
COULD UP. THIS IS DOCTOR JUDY
ISSUE FOR CERTIFIED POSITIONS
IN INTERNAL MEDICINE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT
TIME. ONE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ANGELINA CHUNG SAN
FRANCISCO RESIDENT OF DISTRICT
ELEVEN AND I STRONGLY AGAINST
SB FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS LINE. ONE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY
COULD UP. WHITE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. LINE TWO HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN YOUR MY GET UP- GREG BIRD
WITH A CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANKS LINE. THE LINE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO YOUR
MIKE AT THE- FRANKLY PRESIDENT
OF ORGANIZATION FOR JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY REPRESENTING A HUGE
NUMBER OF. RESIDENCES ON A
SOCIAL BAY AREA WE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS DISASTROUS BILL
WHICH PAVES THE WAY. THANKS IN
ADDITION POLITICS YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. WHITE ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO HELLO HELLO
YES PLEASE SEND ME YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
HELLO YES PLEASE SYNDICATE YOUR
NAME AND IF THERE'S ANY
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT THAT
PRESUME YOU'RE OPPOSED SINCE
YOU'RE TESTIFYING NOW. YES HI
MY NAME'S CONNIE AND I'M
CALLING FROM SAID SACRAMENTO ON
SUNDAY UP CLOSE SB FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU NEXT SLIDE. LINE AT
NINETY FIVE YOUR MIKE ABOUT.
THE LINE BUT- THE DAILY. THAT
WHY NINETY OR MY COULD. LOOPS.
HELLO HELLO YES PLEASE AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION YOUR POSITION
ON SB FIFTY SEVEN. HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MY NAME IS
CARLA LOW I AM PRESIDENT OF
AMERICANS AGAINST LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS MIXED MESSAGE I DON'T
THINK THANK YOU. SB THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
BLIND TWO HUNDRED NINETY YOU'RE
LIKE IT'S UP. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOE NG AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CHINESE AMERICANS EACH THE
TRIPLE AND COLUMN I STRONGLY
AND THE WHOLE GROUP STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FIFTY SEVEN IT JUST
BRINGS BACK A LOT AND CABLE
THANK THANK OU STORE THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU AND
PLEASE. A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. IF WAS A HOW TO GET A
RESIDENT PLEASANT HILL I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. THANK YOU
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH AGAIN
WE'RE ON SB FIFTY SEVEN AND I
HEARD THAT OPPOSITION- NEXT
LINE PLEASE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
FIVE YOUR MIKE AT THE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE OF YOUR MY
COULD OPEN. A LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO HELLO YES PLEASE IN THE
KOREAN LOW. AMERICANS AGAINST
LEGALIZING MARIJUANA STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
YOUR MAKE IT UP AND. THAT'S
WHEN YOU MISTER MEMBERS RANGE
FROM AND WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
HEY MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PEOPLE WISHING TO
COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MODERATOR LET'S NOW MOVE TO
COMMITTEE MEMBER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY CENTER EGGMAN
NINETY SECONDS ALICE NEXT.
BECAUSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING THIS FORWARD SEEMS
WHENEVER WE TALK ABOUT
VULNERABLE PEOPLE WE- WE ALWAYS
HOW THESE ARGUMENTS ABOUT WHO'S
DESERVING AND WHO'S NOT
DESERVING OF CARE AND
TREATMENT- I JUST LIKE TO SAY
SOMEONE WHO AUTHORED THIS FOR A
WHILE. IT'S A HARM REDUCTION
MEASURE RIGHT WE KNOW THAT WE
KNOW PEOPLE WHO WHO HAVE SEVERE
DICTIONARY ARE DEALING EVERY
DAY WHICH THE SHAME AND GUILT
THAT THAT GOES ALONG WITH THAT.
AND REACHING OUT FOR HELP. IS
NOT AN EASY THING- DID WE DID A
PRESS CONFERENCE AND I'LL NEVER
FORGET IT WAS TWO DIFFERENT
MOTHERS WHO CAME IN WITHOUT ME
ASKING BUT THEY CAME IN TO
TESTIFY. ON TO BE A PART OF THE
PRESS CONFERENCE THEY BOTH HAD
CHILDREN. WHO HAD DIED FROM
OVERDOSES AND SAID THEY REALLY
WISH SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAD
BEEN AROUND. AS WE NEVER KNOW
WHAT IT'S GOING TO BE TO TURN
THAT ONE PERSON AROUND AT ONE
TIME. IN THIS KIND OF THING ARE
WE ALL DESERVING OF CARE AND
HELP OR OR JUST SOME OF US.
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU THE ONES
THAT PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS IS A MAGNET FOR. PEOPLE TO
COME AND USE. THE POPULATION
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE. GENERALLY HOMELESS IN
USING ON THE STREETS OR ELSE
THEY WOULDN'T BE USING ON THE
STREETS AND OVERDOSING. AND THE
ONLY WAY FOR A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS TO WORK IS IF YOU PUT IT
WITHIN A FIVE BLOCK RADIUS OF
WHERE PEOPLE ARE ALREADY
ACTIVELY USING OUT ON THE
STREETS. SO IT'S KIND OF A DO
IT DOES NOT. IT IS NOT DROP
PEOPLE YOU PLACE THEM WHERE THE
PEOPLE ARE USING IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO PUT THEM IN A SUBURBAN
NEIGHBORHOOD BY A MALL WHERE
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE. FOR
BUSES TO GET THERE THAT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE ANY AND ANY GOOD
SENSE. SO WE KNOW THEY WORK WE
KNOW THEY REDUCE OVERDOSES WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE WHO USE THEM.
WILL THEN AT SOME POINT GET
INTO TREATMENT. I JUST WANT TO
CLOSE BY AGAIN THANKING MY AT-
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. BY SAYING THIS IS A
LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE. AND JUST
ON THE ON THE ONE NIGHT THAT I
WAS NOT ABLE TO GET THE VOTES
FOR THIS BILL I. HAD A NICE
EMAIL FROM SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
LAW SCHOOL NOW BUT JUST SAID.
YOU KNOW. I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
YOU I DON'T KNOW THIS BILL BUT
I CAN TELLYOU. THERE WAS A
TIME WHEN I WAS USING I WAS
LIVING ON THE STREETS AND I WAS
LIVING IN MY CAR. AND TO THINK
THAT SOMEBODY WOULD CARE ENOUGH
ABOUT ME TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS. MEANS A LOT SO SOMETIMES
JUST THE. THE PUTTING FOR SOME
THAT SAYS WE YOU WE CARE OF.
YOU AND WE'RE GONNA COMING BACK
TO THE STATE. UNTIL WE CAN
PROVIDE. THE HELP THAT YOU NEED.
TO YOUR LIFE AROUND. SO I WOULD-
AT ENCOURAGE MY CALL. AT TO
CASTING. VOTE ON THIS AND- BILL
THAT MOVES THE- ON. THAT MOVED
FORWARD. ON PEOPLE REDUCE THE
HARM TO THEIR BODIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN SAID
GONZALEZ. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I TO WANT TO SEE IF YOU
TO SEE AND SO. WE FO THIS
ISSUE FOR IT I AM ALSO IN SO.
HAVING A SEEN EVEN SITE IN-
TRAVEL WHEN I WENT ANSWER-
THERE APPROACH. THERE WAS
REDUCE NOT ENDING DRUG USE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT BUT IT WAS
ALSO THE CESSATION OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. AND ALSO REDUCING
OPEN CONSUMPTION BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY PREVENTING PEOPLE
FROM DYING. OVER SERVICE THEY
WOULD ALSO HELP WEAN PEOPLE OFF
SYRINGES TO OR- OTHER MORE SAFE
A SAFER METHODS. AND IT WAS
REALLY A GOOD. EYE OPENING PRO
FOR EVERYONE OF US TO A- THAT
THIS IS ONE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. BUT NEEDS TO
COMPLEMENT THE FULL PORTFOLIO
OF SOLUTIONS AS MENTIONED BY
CENTER EGGMAN- INCARCERATION IS
NOT THE ANSWER- AND CERTAINLY
PAYING AND SPENDING
CONSIDERABLE DOLLARS AN
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS. THAT
COULD BE PREVENTED IS ALSO NOT
THE ANSWER. I COME FROM A CITY
LONG BEACH THAT ONLY HAS ONLY
EIGHT HUNDRED POLICE OFFICERS
TWO OF WHICH ARE QUALITY OF
LIFE OFFICERS. THAT WORK ON
THIS ISSUE THIS IS A CITY OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
ALONG BEACH FIRE DEPARTMENT WAS
FOUR HUNDRED. MEMBERS AND ONLY
TWO MEMBERS THAT WORK ON THIS
ISSUE PROACTIVELY. THIS IS A
VERY DIFFICULT FOR OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. WE HAVE DATA FROM
DECADES OF SUCCESS NOT IN CAL
I'M NOT IN CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY BUT FROM EUROPE
IN OTHER AREAS. THAT DO A
DOCUMENT SUCCESS. THE FAVORITE
PART OF THIS BILL IS THAT IT IS
A LOCAL COMMUNITY PROCESS AND
MANY CITY COUNCILS AND
SUPERVISORS ARE ACTUALLY
ALREADY DOING THE WORK TO STUDY
THE ISSUE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
FRUITFUL DISCUSSION AND
HOPEFULLY HAVE THESE- SITES AND
PROGRAMS IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY SO WITH THAT. I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU ARE TO THE
AUTHOR AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATE ROTH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. YOU KNOW I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE THOSE FROM.
VARIOUS AREAS OF THE STATE WHO
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
INCLUDING. SOME IN THE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THAT I'M
PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT. AND AS
I RECALL WHEN THIS MEASURE CAME
UP IN THE PAST AT LEAST IN THE
DISTANT PAST- I HAVE TO SAY I
WAS NOT ONE OF THOSE WHO STOOD
UP. TO SUPPORT IT. AND I'M NOT
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF THAT BUT
I HAVE TO SAY AND I'VE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THAT DRUG
USE AND OVER DOSING- IS A
CRISIS. IN THE STATE AND OF
FRANKLY. IF THOSE IN THE
JURISDICTIONS COVERED BY THIS
BILL WANT TO STEP UP. AND TRY
SOMETHING INNOVATIVE IN AN
ATTEMPT TO PUT AN END TO.
TERRIBLE DRUG USE AND
OVERDOSING DEATHS IN OUR STATE-
I'M ALL FOR IT SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND I
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I MISS ANYONE OKAY I
DON'T- ALL RIGHT SO I WOULD
JUST. JUST A FEW REMARKS
MYSELF- FIRST OF ALL- THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR WIENER FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORWARD I LIKE US ARE
ROTH WAS NOT- EXACTLY IF I
THINK- SENT EGGMAN THE NEW THAT-
AND- YEAH I INTRODUCED HAVE SO-
SOME. DON'T BUT I ALSO POINT
THAT MY CALL. TO THE ONES WHO
ACTUALLY IN THIS FIELD HAVE
TOLD ME THAT THERE'S TOO MANY
THERE'S HAVE IN SUPPORT. OF
THIS BE ABLE TO SAVE PEOPLE'S
LIVES WILL GAIN THEM ACCESS
PEOPLE WHO NORMALLY WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY SEEK HELP- BUT- WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO STILL
REACH THEM OUT OF REACH OUT TO
THEM WHEN THIS HAPPENS. I ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT- IN THIS BILL
THIS THIS IS THREE PILOTS AND
ONE OF THINGS I **** THE CHAIR
IS THAT DO WE HAVE. SUPPORT FOR
THIS BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AT
LEAST LOCAL LAW EFORCEMENT'S
NOT OPPOSE COMING OUT OPPOSED.
I THINK THAT HAVING- SOME BUY
IN FROM LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WOULD THERE NOT ACTIVELY YOU
KNOW. RAISING CONCERNS IT'S
BEEN SOMETHING ALSO THAT'S OF
IMPORTANCE FOR THE PILOT SITE
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN MY MIND AND
THAT IS THE CASE AND EACH OF
THESE THREE PILOT SITES. SO
AGAIN THIS IS A PILOT- THERE'S
THREE- THERE PUT SOME IN MY
FIELD OR ARGUE THAT WHY IS THIS
ONLY A PILOT- THE DATA WE HAVE
SO FAR IS ACTING. PRETTY GOOD
SENSE OF THIS IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURE A BUT THIS IS AT
LEAST AN INITIAL STAFF AND I DO
APPRECIATE- BOTH THE LEADERSHIP
OF- CENTER EGGMAN AND NOW
CENTER WIENER AND IN MOVING
THIS FORWARD IN THREE
COMMUNITIES THAT SAID WE'RE
INTERESTED IN DOING THIS. WEEK
BROUGHT PEOPLE TOGETHER AND WE
WANT TO. WORK THIS OUT WE LOOK
AT THE DATA WOULD SINCE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL PLACES WE ALSO YOU
CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN OUR PLACES
OUR LOCALITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THAT CERTAINLY I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS. MY I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL. BUT
CENTER WE DO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I THANK YOU RESEARCH I
PUT. HIM AND YOU TO MICHAEL.
FOR THOSE REALLY INSIGHTFUL
REMARK AND- FOR KEEP AN OPEN.
ON THIS ISSUE. YOU KNOW WE SOME.
THAT IF YOU. IF YOU PUT A SITE
LIKE THIS AND- IT'S OF LIKE.
WHITE CHANGE P. AND MAKE THEM
WANT TO STAY USE. DRUGS A REAL.
IT'S NOT. IT'S A NINE SAN OR-
WERE WITH ALL. RESPECT THIS IS
A- CONDITION. PEOPLE EITHER YOU.
OR THE YOU PEOPLE ARE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE- AND I JOB. IS TO
DO WHAT WE CAN TO TRY HELP THEM.
THE HEALTH AND SIR. AND THAT
MEAN RECOVERY WHERE THEY YOU
ANTI AND WE ALL I'LL TELL YOU
EVERY SINGLE PERSON I KNOW. WHO
HAS BEEN ADDICTED. AND WHO HAS
BEEN ABLE TO TRANSITION INTO
RECOVERY AND STOP USING EVERY
SINGLE ONE AND I KNOW A LOT OF
MY COMMUNITY THIS IS NOT A
RANDOM ISSUE THIS AFFECTS ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES SO DEEPLY
NOT JUST HOMELESS PEOPLE FROM
EVERY SECTOR OF OUR SOCIETY ARE
SUFFERING EVERY SINGLE PERSON I
KNOW. WHO HAS STRUGGLED.
SUPPORTS US. AND IT IS OF THE
PEOPLE I KNOW PERSONALLY AND
I'VE TALKED TO THEM AND I
TALKED ABOUT THEIR STRUGGLE AND
SO MANY OF TOLD ME I WISH THAT
THIS HAD EXISTED WHEN I WAS
USING WHEN I WAS LIVING IN AN
ELEVATOR WELL. WHEN I WAS ON A
PATH TO DEATH I WISH THAT THIS
HAD EXISTED WHEN I CONTRACTED
HIV. FROM SHARING NEEDLES I
WISH THAT THIS HAD EXISTED.
THIS IS ABOUT SAVING LIVES. AND
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE UC SITES
THEY'RE ALREADY USING. BUT
RIGHT NOW FAR TOO MANY OF THEM
ARE USING ON OUR SIDEWALKS AND
BEHIND GARBAGE DUMPSTERS AND IN
OUR PARKS NEAR WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE OR WHERE PEOPLE WORK. THE
QUESTION IS NOT WILL PEOPLE USE
OUR ONE DAY BUT WHERE DO WE
WANT THEM TO USE THAT WE WANTED
TO BE ON THE SIDEWALK IN
UNSANITARY CONDITIONS IN FRONT
OF PEOPLE WHO WERE WALKING ON
THE STREET POTENTIALLY WITH
THEIR CHILDREN. WHAT DO WE WANT
THEM TO BE IN A SAFE INDOOR
HEALTHY SETTING WHERE WE CAN
ENSURE THEY SURVIVE WHERE THEY
CAN WE CAN ENSURE THEY HAVE A
CLEAN HER. AND WE CAN HELP THE
GET IN RECOVER I ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU FOR SOURCE A MOTION.
SOME OF OKAY SO MOVED BY CENTER-
AND SO THE MOST. IS DO PASS BUT
FIRST WE- TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIX- SIX PLEASE THE ROLL.
CAN BY HAND HI MELINDA. EGGMAN
BY A ARKANSAS HI AND SO I GREW
NO. GROUP NO TADO. LEYVA ALL
LEAVE AYE LIMóN ROTH- ROTH AYE
RUBIO. WIENER HI WIENER. RIGHT
THE CURRENTLY SIX- WILL HOLD
BILL OF FOR- ABSENT- MEMBERS
THANK YOU SIR MY RIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
CENTER ALLEN- IT'S AS B. TWO
FIVE WELCOME. THANK YOU SHARE
AND- GOOD AFTERNOON MA'AM SO
THIS BILL SB THIRTY FIVE. SIX
TO PROVIDE LEGAL AND REGULATION
FOR THEM SALE AND OF HEY
DERIVED PRODUCTS IN CAL HISTORY
FOLKS HAMPUS BASICALLY. AND YOU
KNOW. KERIS PLANTED WOULD WITH
MY LOWER THC LEVEL SO IT HAVE
THE CYCLE ACT. OPPORTUNITIES
HAVING TO PAY THAT'S GROWN
PROCESS- THE WORLD FOR OF
CONSUMER GOODS FOOD AND TAX.
BECAUSE BY CARE ITEMS- PAPER IN
FACT BE MADE OUT OF HEMP. ONE
OF MY COMMONLY KNOWN
INGREDIENTS COURSE DRIVE FROM
HAND IS CBD WERE IS A NON CYCLE.
DERIVATIVE DOES NOT ANY THC.
NOW PERMITTED UNDER LAW I
CURRENTLY MORE THAN HALF OF
STATES IN THE COUNTRY PERMIT
HEMP'S. TO BEING AS AN AND- IN
FOOD AND THAT. AND I SO. YEAH
CAL ALREADY PER AND RIGHT THE
MINUTE IN SALE OF KEY. DERIVED
C. PRODUCTS. BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO HAVE DERIVED PRODUCTS AND AS
I SAY THIS IS A- SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR PLAN. JUST LOWER THC
LEVELS LOWER LEVELS. HOW WHEN
IT COMES TO HECTOR I PRODUCTS
RULES ARE MURKY. SOON RE YEARS
THIS HAS LED TO CALIFORNIA A
PUBLIC. ISSUE IN NUMEROUS NO OF
I- VOLUNTEER KIND OF AND- JUST
LETTERS AND EMBARGOES RELATED
TO HEMP DERIVED CBD PRODUCTS.
SO SOME OF YOU ARE AWARE THE
CONVERSATION AND DEBATE IN
SACRAMENTO SURROUNDING HEMP IS
ENTERING ITS THIRD YEAR I'M
AUTHORING THIS PROPOSAL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. IDEA CURRY. AND TO GIVE
THE SENATE I AMPLE TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THIS
POLICY TO HOPEFULLY IMPROVE
UPON THE STATUS QUO THAT
DEPRIVED. THE HEMP FOLKS
INCLUDING THOSE WERE LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA FROM COMPETING ON A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WITH. WITH
WITH THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN
MAJORITY THE STATE'S UNITED
STATES. MCCARTY TO W. H. OTHER
WILL HAVE ORGANIZATION EXPERT
COMMITTEE ON DEPENDENCE. C. B.
D. WELL TELL HAS A GOOD SEAT
PROFILE AND ANY ADVERSE SIDE
EFFECTS ARE RARE. AND LIKELY
DUE TO INTERACTIONS WITH OTHER
MEDICATIONS A PATIENT MAY BE
ON. IN ADDITION WHO'S PUBLISHED
FINDINGS THAT HEMP DERIVED CBD
DOES NOT LEAD TO ABUSE. OR
DEPENDENCE. WE PUT THIS BILL IN
THE PRINT IN MID JANUARY- JUST
THIS PAST FRIDAY OUR OFFICE WAS
NO. OF A LETTER OF OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN AT
THE REQUEST OF A NUMBER OF
CANNABIS RETAILERS. INCLUDING
SOME WITHIN MY DISTRICT AND OF
COURSE THE DISTRICTS OF SOME
SOME OF YOU SOME MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE- I JUST WANT TO
SAY I'M VERY OPEN TO WORKING
CONSTRUCTIVELY WITH THIS
COALITION. MY STAFF ACTUALLY
MET WITH HIM OVER THE WEEKEND
I'VE GOT A MEETING ON THE BOOKS
OF THEM SCHEDULED FOR LATER ON
THIS MONTH. I KNOW MARK UP OR
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE FROM THE
COALITION HAS YET TO BE IDEA
PRESENTED TO OUR OFFICE.
HOWEVER THEY HAVE COMMUNICATED
TO MY STAFF THAT THEY'RE NOT
TRYING TO STOP. THE BILL TODAY
BUT TO ENCOURAGE CONVERSATION
ABOUT AROUND ASPECTS OF THE
POLICY THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
I AM I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
HAPPY I AM TO ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION. I WAS ONE MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO OUR BEST. I TO
ADDRESS WHY. WOULD WE CAN. THAT
THEY THEY HAVE RAY. A MANAGER
ALSO. BY THIS. IN OUR- ON PAGE-
TENDED IN. I'M YEAH. KNOW THE
BIG KNOWS I'M SAY THIS. WERE
WITH THE COMMITTEE THE IN THE-
ON THOSE ISSUES TO THE BILL
MOVED. TODAY ONE FINAL. THIS
REALLY IS DELTA. THERE'S BEEN
SOME RECENT STORY IN THE NEW
YORK. AND ALSO THAT OF. CERTAIN
BUSINESSES OUTSIDE A CAL THAT
ARE YOU CHEM TO X. AND BECAUSE-
OF ANOTHER. CAN OF NINE. THE
DEL EIGHT WHICH MAY HAVE SO.
PROP SO I DO WANNA SAY RIGHT
NOW IT'S- CERTAINLY BY DIE IS
NOT MY INTENT ALLOW KERR LAW OR
BILL BE CERTAIN. BY WHO TO
CREATE AN TALKS THE MASK AS A
HAVE. I SAW WORKING ON AN
AMENDMENT WANT TO ANY SURE THE-
IS AN ACTOR. YOU KNOW RELATIVE
THE SCIENCE IN IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH IT BUT- FARM ACT- STICK.
AND I WORK ON THE NOW WORKING.
TO MAKING THIS AMENDMENT AND
CONFER WITH THE COMMITTEES
MEMBER. THE STAFF. ON THE
LANGUAGE BEFORE THE BILL IS
HEARD THE SENATE. COMMITTEE SO
WE WE'RE- WE'RE WORKING ON THAT
NOW I WILL YOUR STATUS WILL BE.
SHE THE- EVENT BOTH AND ALSO-
SO. FOR SHOULD THIS THIS BE GET
OUT OF COMMITTEES. THE NEW
JOINING ME TODAY LEGAL. ARE
MARTIN HAS HERE THE GUY- HERE
ABOUT HOW OF THE U. S. HEMP ROW.
WE ALSO HAVE A CHEN CAN IS HERE.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAN INDUSTRY. THANK
YOU CENTER. AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITTING TO TAKE THE-
FOR FAMILY TECH. MEN THAT THE
COMMITTEES WILL. WHICH WORKING
AT RIGHT NOW SOMETHING YOU.
RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH
THAT. OF SO FIRST HAVE RAN MARK
WHO I SEE IS UP IN THE- TO-
PLEASE PLEASE BE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RANDOM ON THE
OF THE U. S. HIM FOR. M. AS
WELL AS A CANNABIS BY THE OF
COOLEY. I WANT TO POINT OUT
FIRST THE- THIS REFER A LOT
HARD WORK BY THE LATE. AND THE
GOVERNOR OFFICE. OVER THE LAST
YEARS- MO OF THE ISSUE WE THINK
BEEN WERE. THERE ARE STILL A
HANG OUT THERE THE WE WILL
COULD TO WORK ON YOU. YOUR CAN
AND OTHER OF THE- THIRD OVER
OUR OF. THAT WERE VERY PROUD TO
PER WITH THIS BILL. NUMBER ONE
IS CAN. SAY ON THERE'S A- IN
THE BILL THAT MAKES VERY STRONG-
SIR. WERE TO LABELING. OF
WARNINGS FOR PRESS WOMEN. WOMEN
CHILDREN- ITSELF- ALSO-
WARNINGS ABOUT NOT MAKING.
ABOUT THE- HEALTH BENEFITS OF A
OF A HEMP CBD. THAT IS NOT A
MEDIC VALID. THE OTHER THING
THAT WE'RE- REALLY PUSHING THIS
BILL IS BRING NEW. IN THE K.
IT'S GOING TO CHEN. NEW JOBS.
AND GENERATE NEW. FOR THE STATE.
OF RIGHT NOW. AND CREAMS ARE
ALLOWED BUT FOOD BEVERAGE.
DIETARY AS WELL AS PEP. ARE
ONCE COME IN. THE STATE. WILL
SEE AN- TEN REVENUES FROM THEM.
THE CV ANDERSON IS PROJECTED TO
BE ABOUT SIX. DOLLAR OVER
COUNTRY. IN THE NEXT TO YOU.
WELL WE'LL PUT SEE TO THREE.
JOE CAL. OVER THE SO SAME TO
PERIOD. I ALSO WANT TO PLAY OUT
THAT WE- HAVE WE EVER SEEN
CONCERN FROM THE- CALIFORNIA
FARM. WE ARE WE'RE WITH THEM
YOU KNOW THEY CONCERN ABOUT
SOME THE PROBLEMS. PROHIBITED
POT. IN THE BILL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AT ASPEN. AS WE
AS SOME LANGUAGE. TO WHAT. TO
BUT WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING
OUT THERE BECAUSE AS WELL. IN
THE REPUBLIC I CAN. HAS ME TO
IT TO THE MEMBERS. SOME WILL TO
SB NINETY. IS A COMP. THE IT
DEALS WITH- SENATOR I BILL
DEALS WITH EVERYTHING. COLD WE
URGE SUPPORT THIS BILL YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
NEXT WE HAVE IN SUPPORT ANY
CHEN. OF THE CAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IS. SURVEY COMPLETE
BRING A JENKINS ON TO THE PHONE
LINE. FOR IT AMY TAKEN LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY TO MINUTES THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AMY JANGAN ON BEHALF
THE K. CANNABIS AND THIS
AFFAIRS. WITH THE CIA WE'RE
VERY CLEAR TO BE PART A DIVERSE
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THAT YOU FIVE AS A MEMBER OF
THE- WE HAVE HOPE SHAPE BILL.
NEW CONSUMER SAFETY STANDARDS
IT CONTAINS COMPREHENSIVE
TESTING PROTOCOLS THAT NEAR THE
STATE'S REQUIREMENTS FOR
CANNABIS WHICH WILL ENSURE A
LEVEL AND EIGHTY AND PEACE OF
MIND CURRENTLY AFFORDED TO
COUNT THE CONSUMERS INCLUDES
RIGOROUS CONSUMER SAFETY
PROTOCOLS INCLUDING ADVERTISING
AND LABELING STANDARDS. BASED
ON EXISTING CANADA STANDARDS
AND ENSURE ONGOING
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION
AMONG HEMP AND CANNABIS
LICENSING AGENCIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AT THE FACILITY
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST UNLICENSED
MANUFACTURED. BELIEVES AND MANY
OTHER PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
ARE SUPPORTED BY THE CIA WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THERE IS MORE WORK
TO BE DONE TO MAKE THIS BILL
EVEN STRONGER CLARIFY PORTIONS
THAT MAY BE UNCLEAR AND ENSURE
THE PROTECTION OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IN THE PROCESS.
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT WE ARE
PLEASED TO WORK ON WITH THE
AUTHOR INCLUDE ENSURING GREATER
CLARITY THAT HEMP PRODUCTS ARE
TESTED IN FINAL FORM CLOSING
ANY LOOPHOLES AS DISCUSSED YOU
ENSURE THAT PRODUCTS SOLD TO
CONSUMERS DO NOT EXCEED TWO
POINT 3% THC OR CONTAIN ANY
OTHER. PSYCHOACTIVE DERIVATIVES
DEVELOP A SUCCESSFUL PATH TO
PROHIBIT YOU PERMIT THE
MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF
SMOKABLE AND HEALTHCARE
PRODUCTS AND ESTABLISH A CLEAR
AND BALANCED PROCESS AND
PROMPTLY WITH THE INCORPORATION
OF HANDS INTO THE CANNABIS THE
FIGHT SCENE WILL ALSO
PROTECTING THE INTERESTS. OF
THE OPERATOR STATE CCA WISHES
TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS
ONGOING. COLLABORATION WITH THE
ACCOUNT OF THE KIND OF THREE TO
ADDRESS ANOTHER CRITICAL
PRIORITIES AND WE REFLECT-
EITHER TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MUCH. RIGHT NOW THE HOUSE
MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AGAIN MONEY óRDENES.
AND TO ARE ONLY WE'LL START
WITH THE GALLERY HOURS AND LIKE
A LITTLE AFTER ONE. OKAY SONORA
DOLLAR LITERALLY THREW INTO
INVENTORY FORTY AREN'T ANY.
SAYS FIND FORTY FORTY YEARS
LET'S MOVE ON YOU ARE TELECOM
LEARNING- MODERATE IT NOW
PLEASE- INCREASED FROM
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A SPECIES USE
FROM FIVE. OKAY MISTER MAHER
FOR CALLING ON THE OR OR UP AND
YOU- THIRTY FIVE FIVE PRESS ONE
AND- OKAY WE'RE GOOD WITH. THEM
NUMBER VIA AT BAYLOR HERE- AND
WE JUST TO CLARIFY. SET A TO
GET THAT FIXED NO NOT YET NOT
YET. ATTENTION EVERYONE PLEASE
UTILIZE YOUR MUTE BUTTON WHEN
NOT SPEAKING IF AVAILABLE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT I DON'T HEAR ANY
FURTHER ECHO RIGHT NOW SO WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND- AGAIN
INSTRUCTABLE TO- WANTED TO GET
RID OF THE TELEPHONIC SERVICE
AND PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR.
WITNESSES TESTIFYING AGAIN IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO THIRTY FIVE.
ONCE AGAIN TO PROVIDE COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE A VIEW COMMENTS
COMING TRIPS ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHILE WE GIVE THEM THEIR
LINEUP. THANK YOU. HANDLE LINE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE YOU'RE
A MIKE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ANY BERNACCHI ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA HAVE COUNSEL- THE
COUNSELORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO THIRTY FIVE- DR-
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
LINE ONE HUNDRED YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. THE LION ONE
HUNDRED YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
BLIND FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. KYLE TERADA NATURAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
TIME. LINE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
YOUR MIKE AT THE OPEN. MISTER
TERRY MEMBERS STILL DIVIDE WITH
PLASMID VISORS ON BEHALF OF
CANOPY GROWTH IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. BLIND A
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
YOUR MY KIDS UP. POLICE ARE
PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LANE SIXTY SEVEN NEAR MY COULD
OPEN. THANK YOU DAN FREEMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE EVEN ENTERPRISES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE WALL.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE
IS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURNED
OTHERS PIC I'M NOT CLEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE KRONOS GROUP IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY YOUR MY GET UP AND- CAN
MEMBER KATELYN AGAIN SAID THAT
CARBON AND CARRIED THEIR
REPRESENTING CHARLOTTE'S WEB IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO THREE
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. A LINEOF ONE HUNDRED
YOUR MY KIDS UP AND. LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE YEAR MIKE IS UP.
WINDS THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY DROPPED IT
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
PEOPLE WISHING TO BRING A LET'S
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AS A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO THIRTY
FIVE IN THE GALLERY SAYING NONE
LET'S REMOVE THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OR TO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THREE NINE LET'S MOVE ON TO
TELEPHONIC LINES OF MODERATOR
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WASN'T
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWO THIRTY
FIVE AND PLEASE OPEN THE LINES-
WHEN. THEY'RE READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. TO S. B. TWO THIRTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE. TEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE.
ZERO OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE A
BILL COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE THEY GIVE THEM
THEIR LIVES THANK YOU. C.
OPERATOR COULD YOU CALLED UPON
TO SPEAK YOU'LL BE FOR TWOS
LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE THAT'S.
TWO ONE. THANK YOU OBLATIONS
MIKE. LINE ONE HUNDRED YEAR
MIKE IS UP. HI THIS IS EVEN
YOUR HEART WITH THE HIGHER
PASSED THE COUNTRY IN HIGH TECH
DISTRIBUTION IN LOS ANGELES AND
WE OPPOSE SB TWO THIRTY FIVE
ELEVEN AND IT. OKAY THANK YOU
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I JUST
REALIZED I HAVE SKIPPED OVER WE
DO HAVE- SCHEDULE WITNESSES FOR
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION I
THINK I JUST BREEZE RIGHT OVER
THE- SO- LET'S LET'S. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND HEAR FROM THEM I
APOLOGIZE. SO WE DO HAVE TAYLOR
RUSSIAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION- SO. WE
CAN LINE UP- TAYLOR RUSSIAN- TO
TESTIFY AND THEN WE HAVE ADAM.
HI JOSIE HOPEFULLY PRONOUNCE IT
CORRECTLY AS WELL SO. WE CAN
GET- FIRST OF ALL- TAYLOR
RUSSIAN FOR THE FARM BUREAU
FIRST AND THEN- TWO MINUTES.
THEN THEN THE STRUCTURE- ADAM
PAGE HAS A JAZZY. AND MR OCEAN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN APOLOGIZE
MISTER RUSSIAN BACKED UP PLEASE
BEGIN. SORRY IT'S- THERE ARE.
WELL DON'T WORRY I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TAYLOR OR
SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU WE'D LIKE TO THINK
SENATOR ALAN FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL I'M IT'S RARE THAT
AGRICULTURE CAN ADOPT A NEW ACT
MONEY AND HAS REALLY PROVIDED
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR FARMS TO
DIVERSIFY AND INCENTIVES FOR
NEW AND BEGINNING FARMERS TO
COME INTO THE MARKET WITH THAT
SAID WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
AND REQUEST AMENDMENT INTEREST
THE PINE WILL FOCUS ON TWO OF
THEM. FIRSTLY THE BILL PROPOSES
THAT ALL HEMP PRODUCT BE TESTED
IN ACCORDANCE WITH CANADA
CONTAMINANT STANDARDS I THINK
WE'LL HAVE TO PRACTICAL
PROBLEMS FOR BARNSLEY
MANUFACTURED THIS ONE EXAMPLE
THE STATE IMPOSES YOU'RE A
TOLERANCE LEVEL FOR PESTICIDE
RESIDUE FOR CANNABIS THAT
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
FEDERALLY APPROVED PRODUCT IT
CAN BE USED ON CAMPUS HOWEVER
AS A FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED FROM
THE FIGHT AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITIES THERE ARE FEDERALLY
AND STATE APPROVED PRODUCTS
PAN. THEREFORE ENCAMPMENTS
SANDERS HUGE FOR OTHER
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITIES SHOULD
SUFFICE BURGER ALSO CONCERNED
THE BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE
PRODUCTION AND SALE OF LOCAL
FLOWER IN CALIFORNIA WE
UNDERSTAND THE SENSITIVITIES
AROUND INHALATION BUT THERE IS
AN EXISTING THERAPEUTIC MARKET
FOR THIS PRODUCT AND TYPICALLY
PROVIDED BY OUR SMALLER URBAN
HEMP FARMS AND MOREOVER
IMPLEMENTATION WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT WILL PERHAPS
UNINTENTIONALLY PROHIBIT THE
SALE OF ANY RAW FLOUR EVEN IF
IT'S NOT INTENDED FOR
INSTALLATION SO. THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVE USES FOR RODRIGUEZ
FLOWER ADVOCATE FOR OTHER
<c.red>ERBACEOUS ACT PRODUCTS LIKE</c>
SAGE AND LAVENDER I WE'VE BEEN
WORKING REALLY CLOSELY WITH THE
SPONSORS ON THE PROVISIONS THAT
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THEIR
CONSIDERATION WITH THE
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS
INCORPORATED FOR THE COURTS
REMOVED IN OUR POSITION AND
HOPEFULLY SUPPORTING. THE
MEASURE IN THE NEXT WEEK THANK
YOU. THANK VERY MUCH NOW LET'S
BRING A ADAM JODY. FOR THE LONG
BEACH COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATE.
THANK YOU- HELLO MY NAME IS
ADAM HE I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE LONG BEACH COLLECTIVE
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF A
LARGE COALITION OF CANNABIS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CANNABIS OPERATORS FROM LONG
BEACH SAN FRANCISCO COACHELLA
VALLEY SANTA ANA LOS ANGELES
AND MANY OTHERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB TWO THIRTY FIVE IN
LESS AMENDED WE RECOGNIZE THE
INTENTIONS OF SB TWO THIRTY
FIVE HOWEVER THERE ARE SERIOUS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SHOULD
THIS BILL PASS WITHOUT MEN.
HAVE BEEN CANNABIS PLANT ARE
ONLY DISTINGUISHED BY THE
AMOUNT OF THC THE PLANT MAY
PRODUCE AND ARE OTHERWISE
SCIENTIFICALLY THE SAME. BOTH
COULD USE THE SAME KIND OF THE
NIGHT SUCH A P. V. D. N. PH.
WHAT'S ARE ONLY CHIU OF HUNGER-
BROTHER HUNDRED KNOWN CANONIZED
AVAILABLE. IN ITS CURRENT FORM
AS WE 235% THE CLEAR PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT BY ALLOWING YOU
ACCESS THE PSYCHOACTIVE
PRODUCTS. SUCH AS GUMMIES
INFUSED WITH CANNABIS NIGHT
KNOWN AS DELTA EIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR ALAN FOR RECOGNIZING
CONCERNS A DELTA EIGHT- AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AT THAT
SPEED TO THIRTY FIVE PASSING
ALLOWS FOR PRODUCTS SUCH AS
THOSE TO BE IMMEDIATELY SOLD
TO. YOU THROUGH RETAILERS SUCH
A CALCULATION BURKE RESTORED
AND OTHERWISE. CAN'T EVEN ON
BEING THE SAME WHETHER HIM OR
CANNABIS DERIVED MUCH REQUIRE
THE SAME SAFETY HAZARD. SB TWO
THAT THIRTY FIVE DOES NOT
ESTABLISH SUCH A REQUIREMENT IN
FULL PARITY WITH CANNABIS
DERIVED PRODUCTS NOR DOES IT
REQUIRE AND CONSUMER FINAL FORM
TESTING TO ENSURE THAT PRODUCTS
HAVE NOT LEACH HEAVY METALS. OR
OTHER TOXINS FROM THEIR
PACKAGING. LACK OF THIRTEEN
TESTING THAT- TESTING CENTER
THREATENS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE TV MARKET
SHE'S OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND IS EXPECTED TO REACH TWO
BILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I
THREE TO THIRTY FIVE MINUTES
OUT ON OPPORTUNITY TO GENERATE
MUCH NEEDED ADDITIONAL TAX
REVENUE FOR A STATE SIMILAR TO
HOW. CANNABIS DERIVED PRODUCTS
HAVE. IN AT SUCH AS ONE OLD-
MILLIGRAMS FOR LESS UNTENABLE
CAN CHEN OVER HUNDRED MILLION.
PER YEAR IN TAX REVENUES. AT
THREE TWO FIVE SHOULD BE A MAN
SHOULD BE AMEND TO ALLOW FOR.
TAX FOR DR PRODUCTS WELL AT THE
LAB CANNABIS INDUSTRY. TO
INCORPORATE HEMP DERIVED
PRODUCTS WITH IN THEIR SUPPLY
CHAIN TO ENSURE A BIRTHMARK AND
FAIR MARKET THAT WOULD PROMOTE
THE VIABILITY OF BOTH HIM. AND
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY. THAT
DRESSING THESE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE IN ADVANCE. WILL
PRIORITIZE PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK
YOU LABOR STANDARDS. AND RAISE
NEEDED REVENUES FOR THE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT. APPRECIATE
THAT- THAT'S NOW MOVE BACK TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINE AGAIN
APOLOGIES TO PEOPLE MAYBE WAY
ON THE LINE LET'S AGAIN
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION. WHEN
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE- CAN
PLEASE. PROMPT- THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. AND THEN WILL TAKE
AGAIN NAY OR IS OF THE ON.
AGAIN THIS IS ON A MEDICARE.
FOR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO IN LINE
ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. MY APOLOGIES LINE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI THIS IS KEVIN
MCCARTY WITH CAPITAL COMPLIANCE
MANAGEMENT AND OPPOSITION
MEMBERS THE PROBATION SMOKABLE
FLOWER IS AMENDED OUT OF THE
BUILDING THANK YOU. THE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION.
EXCELLENT BLINDED LIVE THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN YOUR MIKE
IS UP. HELLO MY NAME IS HAVE
YOUR MIND SET THEM ALIGHT THE
CANNABIS RETAIL BUSINESS OWNER
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
DELTA NINE THC AND I'M CALLING
IN TO OPPOSE SB TWO THIRTY FIVE
LEFT AMENDED. THANK YOU. NEXT
LINE. A LINE OF THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY YOUR MIKE IS UP. KERN ON
THE ECONOMIC COUNTY GROWTH
ALLIANCE PROVIDED LIST OF
CONCERNS OF POTENTIAL MOMENTS
THE AUTHOR WE APPRECIATE
ALLOWING US TO SPEAK WITH US
WORK WITH US YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
BE ABLE TO REMOVE ANY
OPPOSITION OF OUR CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE NEXT LINE. LIGHTER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE YEAR MIKE
IS UP. HELLO THIS IS JERD TYLO
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
KINGDOM. AND OPPOSITION SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE A MONTH ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU NECKLINE. BLIND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI EMILY WITH
CORNERSTONE A WELLNESS
DISPENSARY IN LOS ANGELES AND
WE OPPOSE SB TWO THREE FIVE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. LINE THREE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO THANK YOU HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR ME YES. BECAUSE WE
HAVE A QUESTIONS AND IT COULD
TAKE A GOOD IT'S JUST BECOME AS
NEED FIFTY SIX OKAY WE'RE YOU
KNOW WE'RE ON SB TWO THIRTY
FIVE. SO OKAY IT IS FREE TO
TALK SERVICE SORRY OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINE THREE
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT YOUR MY
KIDS UP. WINDS THREE HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY KIDDO.
LINE OF THREE HUNDRED AND FOR
THREE THREE YOU'RE LIKE IT'S
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
CASPARY I WORK IN A LICENSED
DISPENSARY THAT MINORITY OWNED
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
WE OPPOSE B. TWO THIRTY FIVE
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU
MATTER HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
WAITING ON THE LINE. THIS POINT.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SIX MORE
PEOPLE WAITING OKAY- WE ARE YOU
KNOW WE ARE GETTING CRUNCHED ON
TIME SO WE'LL TO HAVE PEOPLE
CAN JUST. SEDER TO GET NAME
ORGANIZATION OPPOSITION-
QUICKLY THAT BE HELPFUL SO
LET'S JUST. ROLL THROUGH THOSE-
SO MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE NEXT LINE. A LINE OF THREE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD UP. HI SABRINA FREDERICK
WITH BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP
AND WE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED I
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
TWENTY ONE YOUR MAKE IT UP. ONE
TWENTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO YES NAY MORTICIAN AND
POSITION. MY NAME IS RICHARD
SOCIAL EQUITY OUT NAY THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN HOWEVER ON BEHALF
OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS SO SUCK WE
AFRICANS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT LINE. BLIGHTED EIGHTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO YES THREE BILLION DOLLARS
REPRESENTING. HELLO THE JUNGLE
CYCLE I REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO CANNABIS ALLIANCE
LESS AMENDED WE OPPOSE SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
MICHAEL LONG WITH. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN UP I APOLOGIZE THEY
DROPPED LINE TWO HUNDRED OR
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
YEAR MIKE ABOUT. CLUBROOMS
CHAIRMAN THIS IS A BURKE
CURRICULUM HALF OF THE UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS NOT
IN A POSITION AT THIS TIME JUST
ONE OF. THE VENDORS HAS WHAT
THE AUTHOR AND SEVERAL OTHER
LAUNCHES A MENTAL ONE BOOKS IN
ORDER TO YOUR DOCTOR WILL BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT ANY BILL THAT.
DOESN'T THREE HEMP PRODUCTS
WITH TRACEABLE TO ISSUE CONTENT
DISSEMINATION CANNABIS PRODUCTS
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S THE
DIRECTION LISTINGS ARE GOING
INTO JUST WANTED FIFTEEN OTHER
CRITICAL THINKING THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THERE'S WHICH TAKING NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION BUT FEEL
FREE TO SEND LETTERS TO THE
COMMITTEE. EXPRESSING A MORE
DETAILED OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
RIGHT NEXT LINE. WHY ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR- JACQUELYN GALLO
GREEN CONTROL CAN OFFICE UNLESS
AMENDED THE YOU THANK YOU SO
LEAST THAT COUNTER WAS ALREADY
SIX SO IS THERE ANY MORE. NO
MATTER CARE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
PEOPLE WISHING TO CONTACT
EXCELLENT OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT- IS THERE ANY KIND OF
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I SEE
SEVEN GONZALEZ. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
QUICKLY SAY- HERE THAT THE
COALITION'S- OPPOSITION- CLAIMS
LOUD AND CLEAR AND I THINK ADAM
JOSIE FROM LONG BEACH CO A
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION FOR-
CALLING IN AND I AM CONFIDENT-
EVEN WITH THIS PASSAGE
POTENTIALLY OF THE BILL TODAY
THAT- THE- AUTHOR WILL BE
WORKING. WITH THE COALITION AND
I WOULD. YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH HIM AS
WELL TO ENSURE THAT WE DO GET
MANY OF THESE QUESTIONS
ANSWERED SPECIFICALLY AS IT
PERTAINS TO TESTING WHICH I
KNOW. STILL HAS A LOT OF-
REQUIREMENTS ON THE HEMP
INDUSTRY BUT ALSO- ALLOWING THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO SELL. HEMP
PRODUCTS AS WELL WHICH I KNOW
IS A SHARED GOAL AND BEING
WORKED ON SO I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT- I WILL BE VOTING
YESTERDAY AND I JUST THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR. BEING OPEN TO THESE
AMENDMENTS AND THESE IDEAS
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I DO HAVE A CONCERN I KNOW I
SUPPORTED THIS BILL IN THE PAST
BUT I HAVE A CONCERN IT WASN'T
SOMETHING THAT WAS SHARED. BY
THE OPPOSITION SO I MAYBE OFF
TRACK BUT A LOOK FOR THE AUTHOR
TO CORRECT ME. THE CALIFORNIA
CITY CALIFORNIA SUBMITTED ITS
PLAN TO THE USDA- FOR ITS
CANNABIS PROGRAM IT'S AN
INDUSTRIAL HEMP PROGRAM. AND
THE USDA SENT BACK THAT
PROGRAM. TO CALIFORNIA WITH
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT NEEDED TO
TAKE PLACE AND THEN THOSE
AMENDMENTS WERE SENT BACK.
ACTUALLY THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
THEM TODAY. THE HELP TO GET
THEM BACK TO THE U. S. D. A. SO
THAT THE REGULATIONS CAN GO
INTO PLACE- BY MARCH TWENTY
SECOND SO THERE'S CLEAR
GUIDANCE. ON INDUSTRIAL HEMP
PROCESSING FOR CALIFORNIA.
MEETING THE STANDARDS THE U. S.
STATE D. S. PUT FORTH FOR
CALIFORNIA'S PLAN. MY CONCERN
AND I WOULD HOPE THE AUTHOR CAN
ALLEVIATE THAT CONCERN IS THAT.
WILL THIS BILL- CHANGE ANYTHING
TO DELAY THAT PLAN PROCESS.
THEY SHOULD BE IN PLACE BY
MARCH TWENTY SECOND. PENDING
ANY- OTHER OBSTACLES. THE
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR YES
RICHARD NO I AM NOT AND NOTHING
I MEAN IN LESS TIME. TOTALLY
MISSING SOMETHING I JUST CAN'T
SEE HOW HOW THIS WOULD. A DELAY
WHAT WOULD TELL ME TELL ME MORE
ABOUT HOW YOU THINK THAT MIGHT
HAPPEN AS A RESULT OF THIS. SO
I HAVE- OBVIOUSLY OF INDUSTRIAL
HEMP GROWERS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND THEIR CONCERN IS-
THAT WITH THE USDA'S AMENDMENTS
TO THE CALIFORNIA PLAN
LEGISLATION THAT'S PASSED IN
THE BUILDING COULD AFFECT THAT.
AND I'M JUST ASKING FOR A
CONFIRMATION THAT YOU DON'T SEE
HOW YOUR BILL. WOULD AFFECT
THAT- CALIFORNIA PLAN BEING
SUBMITTED. BACK TO THE USDA BY
THE TWENTY SECOND AND- HAVE YOU
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH SECRETARY
ROSS THE FARM BUREAU OR THE
UNDERSECRETARY REGIONAL BRANDS.
REGARDING THIS TO SEE IF IT'S-
IF IT IS A POSSIBILITY THIS
BILL WILL AFFECT THAT. MOVING
FORWARD. NO I HAVEN'T
PERSONALLY- I. KNOW I KNOW RAND
MARTIN HERE IS RUNNING POINT ON
THE- ON THE STAKEHOLDER SIDE
COMMITTEE ANSWER THAT. MISTER
MARTIN ACTUALLY THAT'S ABOUT
MISTER MARTIN I THINK IT'S
GOING TO THE MICROPHONE IF YOU
WISH HIM TO ALSO. ADDRESS THE
OPTION BUT- BUT CERTAINLY I AM
VERY HAPPY TO MEET WITH YOUR
FOLKS AND ALSO TALKS ACTUALLY-
TO MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T
BECOME A PROBLEM LIKE THIS IS.
AS I'M. SURE YOU CAN APPRECIATE
THAT THIS IS WHERE WE'RE NOT.
THE TRY TO DO ANYTHING WILL BE
ON THE UP NO I DO APPRECIATE
THAT AND I AND I. THAT NOT WHAT
YOUR INTENT IS I WAS JUST ABOUT
AND THEN THE TEN A CONSEQUENCE
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE'RE SO
CLOSE TO THE MARCH TWENTY
SECOND DEADLINE SO I'M- CURIOUS
ABOUT YOUR TAKE ON. HOW YOU
THINK THE LEGISLATION WOULD
AFFECT THIS- AMENDMENT PROCESS
HAS BEEN GOING BACK AND FORTH
FOR A FEW MINUTES. YES I THINK.
SO I DON'T I DON'T SEE HOW
WOULD HOW WOULD CAUSE TROUBLE
BUT CERTAINLY OKAY HERE THAT'S
YEAH THAT PROJECTS WERE GETTING
REALLY SHORT ON TIME SO-
CENTER- IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
JUST MIGHT MAKE YOU WHICH GIVE
A BRIEF ANSWER TO THAT IT'S A
SERVICE QUESTION MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE IT'S REALLY
HARD TO HEAR UP HERE AND I AM
NOT SURE WHAT SENATOR GROW IS
ASKING ABOUT. I THINK WHAT IN
ORDER TO SAVE TIME WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE SENATOR AND HER STAFF.
AND DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE AND
MAKE SURE THAT SHE'S SATISFIED
THAT- WHATEVER CONCERN IS NOT
GONNA HAPPEN. OKAY I THINK IT'S
INTERFERENCE WITH FEDERAL
PROCESS CORRECT. IT'S A
CALIFORNIA PLAN SUBMITTED TO
THE U. S. J. WITH AMENDMENTS.
THAT ARE DUE BACK ACTUALLY
THEY'RE DISCUSSING IN TODAY AND
IT'S DUE BACK ON THE TWENTY
SECOND SO THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PLAN CAN GO FORWARD. ON
INDUSTRIAL HIM AND I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR AND I KNOW THAT
HE'LL REACH OUT AND I JUST
THINK YOU COULD- LET ME ASK A
QUESTION. OKAY THANK YOU
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN FOLLOW UP
WITH. CENTER GROVE ON DATA.
CENTER WIENER. HE WAS CHAIRMAN
I JUST WANNA. LOT MYSELF WITH.
A CENTER. IS ON I. APPRECIATE
THE OFFER. WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE COALITION. THE BILL.
INCLUDING THE SAN FRANCISCO
CANNABIS RETAILERS ASSOCIATION.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT
WE'RE NOT PUTTING THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AT A DISADVANTAGE AND-
THAT WE'RE TREATING- EVERYONE-
IN THESE INDUSTRIES FAIRLY SELF
CONFIDENT. THE AUTHOR WILL WORK
DILIGENTLY WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND- BASED. ON THAT
REPRESENTATION I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. I THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE SIR ALAN
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THE
BILL- I THINK- APPRECIATE. YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I KNOW YOU'RE ALSO
WORKING MY COMMITTEE STAFF ON
FINALIZING SOME TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND THEN HOPEFULLY
WE CAN ALSO ADDRESS US INTO
GROUPS ACT. QUESTION AND- THAT
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY.
SIGNIFICANCE AREN'T THERE-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
YES TO THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
ROBUST REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF
CALIFORNIA'S HEMP DERIVED CBD
MARKETPLACE WHILE ELEVATING
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS-
WITH STRICTEST IN THE NATION
TESTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
MIRROR THOSE FOR CANNABIS
ALONGSIDE STRONG CONSUMER
PROTECTION LEAVING PROTOCOLS.
THE LEGISLATION INSURERS
CALIFORNIA PLAYS A PIVOTAL ROLE
IN THE RESPONSIBLE GROWTH OF
THIS INDUSTRY. I ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
FOLKS WHO RAISE CONCERNS
INCLUDING MY COLLEAGUES AND
DONE. YOU KNOW I WILL ACTUALLY
REACH OUT TO YOUR OFFICE-
CENTER GROVE IN THE FOLKS IN
THE IN THE VALUER INDUSTRIAL
HEMP. GROWERS AND JUST WENT
WITH THE I WILL SEE IF HE WOULD
MIND THE BILL IS REALLY ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER CULTIVATION-
SO I DON'T ANTICIPATE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE FEDERAL
PROCESS BUT I AM ABSOLUTELY.
COMMITTED TO TALKING TO YOU AND
THEN THE IN THOSE FOLKS ABOUT.
INSURING THAT DOESN'T END UP
BEING THE CASE- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WORLD WHEN I TRY TO GET AWAY
THE AGRICULTURAL PROCESS WHERE
WE'RE TRYING TO COMPLEMENT OUR
PRICES BY DEALING WITH WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER THEY HAD PLAN. IS
HARVESTED. AND ULTIMATELY THIS
IS ABOUT TRYING TO CREATE A OF
CANNABIS CBD IS ALLOWED TO BE
SOLD HAVE CBD ARE TO BE ALLOWED
TO BE SOLD. AS LONG AS
STANDARDS ARE MEANT AND HOW
WITH THAT SPIRIT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IF YOU
GIVE ME THE. OPPORTUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
CENTER ALLEN IT JUST ONE GLASS
COM APOLOGIST AFTER YOUR- IS
THAT I DO APPRECIATE WERE.
GREEN REGULAR STRUCTURE.
BLURRED THERE. IN PLACE THIS
AND THAT'S VERY. TO ME. IS
THERE A MOTION ON THIS BILL. SO
MOVED OKAY TO MOVE I CENTER
EGGMAN- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON AGRICULTURE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ONE REMIND
MEMBERS TO SPEAK INTO THE MIKE
WHEN YOU VOTE PAN FIGHT CAN I
MELINDA'S HI. MELENDEZ AYE
EGGMAN. HI EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ.
AYE CONSOLES AYE GROVE AYE.
GROVE AYE HER TOTEM. LEYVA HI
LEYVA AYE LIMóN I LIMON AYE
ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
WIENER HI WIENER HI OKAY THE
BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TICKETS ARE THIRTY
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT- JUST A
REMINDER WE STILL HAVE SIX
BILLS TO GO WE IN AN HOUR AND A
HALF SO THAT'S FIFTEEN MINUTES
PER BILL- SO I JUST ASK THAT IF
PEOPLE CAN KEEP THEIR REMARKS
BRIEF- OBVIOUSLY WE DO WANT TO
HAVE FULL DISCUSSIONS OF YOUR
QUESTIONS AND SO FORTH PLEASE
ASK. BUT JUST WE ARE A LITTLE
SHORT ON TIME NOW SO CENTER
NEWMAN- ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB TWO
FORTY TWO THANK YOU MISTER
MISTER AND SANDERS- I AM HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF S. B. TWO FOUR TWO
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE INSURERS TO
REIMBURSE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS FOR REGIONAL
COSTS RELATED TO THE NECESSARY
PROCUREMENT OF PP AND TESTING
SUPPLIES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
RIGHT BEGIN MY REMARKS ABOUT
THAT LIKE TO KNOW THAT I'VE
ALREADY AGREED TO THE THREE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED. TO FROM
THE OPPOSITION- AND ONE FROM
THE CHAIR- THIS LEGISLATION
BEFORE TODAY NOW AMENDED SEEKS
TO PROTECT OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND PREVENT. THE SPREAD
OF CODE NINETEEN WHILE ENSURING
THAT SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZED
MEDICAL PRACTICES. CAN REMAIN
IN BUSINESS AND OPEN TO TREAT
PATIENTS IN THEIR CARE. TODAY
MORE THAN A YEAR INTO A
HISTORIC PANDEMICS SMALL TO
MEDIUM SIZE POSITION PRACTICES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. FIND
THEMSELVES INCREASINGLY
STRUGGLING. AS A DIRECT RESULT
OF PANDEMIC DRIVEN CHANGES TO
PROTOCOLS COMBINED WITH THE
IMPACT OF SUCCESSIVE LOCKDOWNS
AND STANDI GUIDANCE. TO AVOID
MIXING AND TRAVEL A GREAT MANY
MEDICAL PRACTICES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCE STEEP DECLINES. IN
PATIENT VISITS AND REVENUE. YOU
GUYS CAN YOU SCHOOL JUST A
LITTLE BIT THAT WAY. THE
ETCETERA CONSEQUENCE A GROWING
NUMBER OF PRACTICES HAVE HAD
HAD EITHER- TO EITHER CLOSE
OFFICES ARE FOR LOW EMPLOYEES
IN RECENT MONTHS SOMETIMES
PLACING. IN JEOPARDY THEY'RE
VERY VIABILITY TO CONTINUE AS
GOING CONCERNS. AS CONTEXT A
RECENT CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SURVEY OF THREE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
PHYSICIANS. FOUND THAT ALMOST
HALF OR 49% OF PRACTICES HAVE
HAD TO LAY OFF OR FURLOUGH
PHYSICIANS AND STAFF. WITH
FULLY 11% OF THOSE FORCED TO
CLOSE THEIR PRACTICES AT LEAST
TEMPORARILY. FURTHERMORE A
SURVEY BY THE PHYSICIANS
FOUNDATION. A NATIONAL NON
PROFIT ESTIMATES THAT 80% OF
ALL PHYSICIANS PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES NATIONALLY OR AROUND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND PRACTICES HAVE-PERMANENTLY SHUTTERED THEIR
PRACTICES AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
THE ECONOMIC STRESSES FORCED
UPON THEM. BY THE PANDEMIC.
CONCURRENTLY AS A RESULT OF THE
VAST CHANGES SPAWNED BY THE
PANDEMIC. INCREASED PP USAGE IS
THE NEW NORMAL MEDICAL SETTINGS
ARE NO EXCEPTION PATIENTS TO
MEDICAL AND DENTAL OFFICES. NOW
EXPECT TO SEE PP CONSTANTLY AND
CONSPICUOUSLY IN USE WHEN THEY
VISIT A DOCTOR'S OR DENTIST'S
OFFICE. THIS CHANGE IS STANDING
OFFICE PROTOCOLS HAS COME AT A
HIGH COST TO SMALL PRACTICES
NEARLY HALF A PRACTICE OWNERS.
RECENTLY SURVEYED BY THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REPORTED THAT THEIR SPENDING ON
PPP HAD INCREASED BY RATES OF
50% OR MORE OVER THE PAST YEAR.
TO ACCOMMODATE THE INCREASE
COSTS MANY SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZE
MEDICAL PRACTICES HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO LAY OFF STAFF OR
REDUCE THEIR OPERATIONS.
MEANWHILE PARTLY DUE TO THE
SAME DECLINES IN PATIENT DEMAND
THAT IF SO ADVERSELY AFFECTED
THESE PRICES HEALTH INSURANCE
TO HEALTH INSURERS HAVE ENJOYED
RECORD REASON PROFITS THIS
YEAR. IN SOME CASES MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE PROFITS FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. INDEED PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS FEAR THAT THE
INCREASED COST OF PP COMBINED
WITH THE DROP IN PATIENT VISITS
COULD RESULT IN A WAVE OF
CONSOLIDATION. THAT WOULD
INCREASE HEALTHCARE EXPENSES
AND DECREASE PATIENT ACCESS TO
CARE. MOREOVER IF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO LOSE THE SMALLER
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES IT WILL
FURTHER INTENSIFY THE STRESSES
ON OUR ALREADY OVERBURDENED
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AND MAKE
MEETING THE HEALTHCARE NEEDS OF
PATIENTS EVEN HARDER I SHOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS WOULD BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
SUCH RESULTS. AS WE FIGHT TO
ELIMINATE THE THREAT OF COVET
NINETEEN WE MUST ALSO ENSURE
THAT HARD WORKING DOCTORS CAN
MAINTAIN THEIR PRACTICES WHILE
PRESERVING PATIENT ACCESS TO
QUALITY CARE FOR THE GOOD OF
MEDICAL CARE IN THE LONG TERM
WE CAN'T LET THE ONE GOAL COME
AT THE EXPENSE. OF THE OTHERS
EVERYONE SHOULD BE CONTRIBUTING
DURING A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND INSURERS IN THIS
CASE ARE NO EXCEPTION. SB TWO
FOUR TWO WILL ENSURE THAT THE
BURDENS CREATED BY INCREASED
UTILIZATION PP IN MEDICAL
SETTINGS WILL BE FAIRLY SHARED
BETWEEN HEALTH INSURERS AND THE
SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZED PRACTICES
PROVIDING PATIENT CARE. IN THIS
VERY CHALLENGING TIME AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS OF THE CREDO EXCEPT
THE THREE AMENDED SUGGESTED BY
THE OPPOSITION AND BY THE
CHAIR. FIRST THERE WERE THE
ORIGINAL SCOPE OF THE BILL HAS
BEEN NARROWED BY INCLUDING A
DEFINITION FOR A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER SECOND THE BILL HAS
BEEN AMENDED TO SPECIFY THE
PLANS ARE ONLY HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR SUPPLIES USED. ON THEIR
MEMBERS THE MEMBERS OF THOSE
PLANS DURING A SERVICE AND NOT
ON A PRO RATA OR SOME OTHER
BASIS. AND THIRD LANGUAGE HAS
BEEN INCORPORATED THAT
SPECIFIES INSURERS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO REIMBURSE FOR PP IN
TESTING ONLY FOR THE DURATION
OF THE CURRENT. PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY OR UNTIL A PLAN IS
ABLE TO RENEGOTIATE WITH
PROVIDERS. WHICHEVER COMES
FIRST WITH ME TO TEST TO FIGHT
TO. START CAN. A POSITION WE
CHOICE MET GROUP. AND STEPHANIE
ST REDDING A PRACTICING DENTIST
IN THE CURRENT CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COUNSEL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU SIR
NEWMAN THAT'S- BRING UP FIRST
OF ALL DR ERIC HANSEN ON TO THE
PHONE LINE. YEAH OKAY HERE IT
IS- DR ERIC KANSEN I'M A FAMILY
MEDICINE PHYSICIAN NUMBER YOU
KNOW COUNTY. AND I CURRENTLY
PRACTICE IN ME UNDERSERVED
AREA- YOU DOING PRIMARY CARE
AND BASICALLY ABOUT A YEAR AGO
ALMOST TO THE DAY- OUR ABILITY
TO PRACTICE MEDICINE IN THE WAY
THAT WE'VE DONE IT FOR YEARS
CHANGED ABRUPTLY. AND AT THAT
MOMENT I ACTUALLY HAD TO GO OUT
AND REALLY RESTRUCTURED AND HOW
I WAS GOING TO BE PATIENT.
FIREMAN WHERE I WOULD HAVE A
POTENTIAL RISK TO EXPOSURE FOR
MY STAFF MYSELF BUT TO OTHER
PATIENTS. AND IMMEDIATELY WENT
UP ON A CELL PHONE FROM MY
OFFICE I ORDERED A LARGE SUPPLY
OF PPP KNOWING THAT THAT WAS
POTENTIALLY MY ONLY HOPE THAT
THE TURN UP FOR. YOU KNOW
KEEPING MY STAFF THAT IS SAFE
AND- AND BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO MY
PATIENTS- AT FOLLOWING THE-
SHUT DOWN JUST A FEW DAYS AFTER
THAT- IT BECAME APPARENT THAT
THAT PDP WAS ACTUALLY NOT EVEN
AVAILABLE AND THAT. OUR NORMAL
MEDICAL PROVIDERS OR MEDICAL
SERVICES PROVIDERS HAD. ALREADY
RUN OUT OF THEIR SUPPLIES AND I
WAS NOT GOING TO GET A MORE PP
WE HAD TO BASICALLY TRANSITION
TO VIRTUAL MEDICINE ENTIRELY
FOR ABOUT A THREE MONTH PERIOD.
I NEVER DID CLOSE MY DOORS BUT
AS THE SENATOR POINTED OUT MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAD TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS IN AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE I PRACTICE. FOR THE
MAJORITY OF HEALTH CARE
PROVIDED TO OUR PATIENTS IS IN
SMALL PRACTICES- IN THE SMALL
PRACTICE SETTING AN INDEPENDENT
POSITION REDDING- THAT THE
CATASTROPHIC SITUATION WHERE R.
E. OURS THEN BECOME THE NEXT.
LEVEL OF CARE WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY NOT APPROPRIATE WHEN
YOU'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT ARE
GRAVELY ILL GOING TO THE
HOSPITAL- FOR CODE AND THEN
OTHERS THAT ARE JUST TRYING TO
SEEK HELP AND GETTING EXPOSED
TO COLD ITSELF. WITHOUT THE
HELP OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY MEDICAL SOCIETY I WOULD
ACTUALLY WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE. PP TO GET ME
THROUGH THE NEXT THE MONTHS
AFTER THAT WAS ME OF A TO ME.
BUT THE POINT IS THAT WE- AS
AGAIN AFTER TO TURN AROUND. WE
TO MINISTERS OF. WE CAN TO
RECALL THIS. AND IT'S BASED
FROM THAT SHOULD BE. OF OUR
COMMUNITY LEADER PIPES ON THE
PART. OKAY ALL RIGHT ON THE
SITE IT'S FAR AS A YOU KNOW THE
KNICKERS- INDIAN. OF THE TOWARD
DIRE- TO A TO BE SUPPORTED IN
THE TIME OKAY THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. LET'S NOW
MOVE ON HERE TO- THE DOCTOR
STEPHANIE SANDRA E. BRING HER
ON THE LINE. THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN. TWO
MINUTES RIGHT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME DR TECHNIQUE
AND RT I RUN TO DENTAL
PRACTICES IN THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO AREA. I HAVE A TOTAL
OF THREE EMPLOYEES AND WE SEE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED PATIENTS PER
MONTH. I'M ALSO THE CHAIR OF
THE PDA GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COUNCIL AND I'M THINKING ON
BEHALF OF OUR TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS THAT. I'M
PROUD TO SEE THE DENTIST HAS A-
GOOD. TO BE ABLE TO TREAT OUR
PATIENTS LATELY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE ONLY POSSIBLE I
THINK IF WE CAN ONLY INCREASED
TREATMENT COSTS. IT'S BEEN
DENTAL TEAM MEMBERS COME FROM A
HIGHER RISK OF WORKPLACE
EXPOSURE TO AIRBORNE PATHOGENS.
APART EVERY DATE OF WERE UNABLE
TO WEAR MASKS THAT ARE PRESENT
IN PERFORM PROCEDURES THAT
TYPICALLY GENERATE AEROSOL
WHICH CAN SPREAD COVERT MORE
READILY. FOUR PP INCLUDING
CLOUDS BASED MATH. I NINETY
FIVE LEVEL THREE MAP HAD IN
DOWN IS NOT REQUIRED TO SAFELY
TREAT PATIENTS AND PROTECT MY
TOP LINE. MAKE PP MANDATORY AND
MEDICALLY NECESSARY. THE COST
OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT HAS GONE UP
EXPONENTIALLY SINCE THE START
OF THE PANDEMIC FOR EXAMPLE
BOXING GLOVES USED TO COST ME
AROUND NINETEEN DOLLARS. NOW
UPWARDS OF FIFTY DOLLARS DUE TO
INCREASED COSTS INSTRUCTIONS IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND INCREASED
LEVELS OF REQUIRED PP. MY
HUSBAND IS NORTH IT HONEST IN
OAK GROVE AND SEE HE'S HE'S
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE PATIENTS PER
DAY YOU'RE PROBABLY TWO BOXES A
BUMPER DAY. BUDGET INCREASED
OVERHEAD SIXTY DOLLARS PER
WORKING DAY FOR HIS BUSY
PRACTICE. YOU COST THEIR NEW
UNEXPECTED. AND NOT REGULAR
BUSINESS EXPENSES. CPP ONE AND
FIND SAYS YEAH US COVER PAYROLL
THAT THE BIG. BUT WE COULD
AFFORD TO RE UP THE DOOR THE IN
FREE SHUTDOWN OF DIANA'S. BUT
THOSE FALL HARSH ACCORDING ARE
PART THAT THE EFFECT DEPEND ON
NOW AND THIRTY MONTHS. MY CALL
BACK AT THREE OUTSIDE THOUSAND
DOLLAR IN PPPS. AND HELP MY
PARK HERO EXPENSES FOR ONLY
ABOUT A MONTH AND A HALF. IT'S
KIND OF A FIFTEEN FOOT HELPFUL
THAT TIME BUT IT DIDN'T THE
SAME PRACTICE FOR THE YEAR.
WITHOUT LOGICALLY TO MANDATE
THE COVERAGE DENTAL AND HEALTH
PLANS HAVE THE ABILITY TO STOP
AND START THEIR SUSPEND THAT
WILL. THE LARGEST DENTAL PLAN
PAID FOR PP FOR ABOUT SIX
MONTHS IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
ENDED ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
HOWEVER THE PANDEMIC AND
INCREASED COSTS REMAIN A HUGE
CONCERN PARTISAN. CITY THE
RAPID. AND ABOUT THAT. WE
BELIEVE THE FOR THE- TO SHAE
INFIRMITY COSTS AND THE URGENT
VOTE OR SB TWO FORTY TWO THANK.
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
MUCH APPRECIATE- NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO. OTHER TESTIFYING AND-
START WITH THE GALLERY- AGAIN
ON THIS IS ON- THAT'S- THE- YES
RIGHT. YES SAYS SB TWO FORTY
TWO A PLEASE BEGIN THERE CASE
NAME OR EXIST POSITION THIS
ADRIN MOHAMMED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
SPONSORS JUST HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
OKAY THANK YOU. SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY LET'S
REMOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY HAD
ANY WITNESSES TEST FIRING
TWENTY FORTY SEEN NONE LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE TELEPHONIC LINE.
MODERATOR WILL YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY TWO- PLEASE HAVE THEM- A
LINE UP AND THEN LET'S GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN. SURE IF LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT A NUMBER TWO FORTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. PLACE YOUR
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
CAMINO OKAY. RIGHT THERE'S NO
ONE SHOWING UP- LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO THE OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE.
TWO PEOPLE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION SO FIRST WE HAVE
BRIAN WHAT'S SAYS BOARD
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION DENTAL PLAN TO
BRING INTO THE PHONE LINE. THAT
FOLLOWED BY NICK LEWIS SAYS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS SO LET'S BEGIN
WITH THAT BRIAN WHAT'S. AS
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRIAN WHAT FOR PRESIDENT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
DENTAL PLANS FOR C. EIGHTY P.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT ON SB TWO FORTY TWO
INCLUDING RECENT CLARIFYING
THAT. TDP WHOSE MEMBERS COVER
85% OF THE MORE THAN THIRTY
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS WITH
DENTAL BENEFITS HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH SB TWO FORTY TWO.
YOUR MANDATE THAT HEALTH PLANS
REIMBURSE PROVIDERS FOR
BUSINESS EXPENSES INTENDED TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF DISEASE.
IT REQUIRES THAT ALL PLANS DO
THE SAME. THE MEASURE FAILED TO
TAKE INTO INTO ACCOUNT THE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
MEDICAL AND DENTAL PRODUCTS.
PERSONAL BENEFITS ARE VOLUNTARY
NOT BE MANDATED BENEFITS. AND
SECOND DENTAL PLAN PREMIUMS ARE
PROBABLY ONE TWENTIETH OF A
MEDICAL PREMIUM. GET THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY STATES WE MUST
PROVIDE A COMPARABLE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR MEDICAL
COUNTERPARTS. IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
TO REIMBURSE A COMPARABLE
AMOUNT BUT ONLY 5% OF
RESOURCES. THIS PROVISION WOULD
RESULT IN INCREASED PREMIUMS
BECAUSE PEOPLE EMPLOYERS TO
OFFER DENTAL BENEFITS. GDP
PLANS FULLY APPRECIATE THE
CHALLENGES THAT IS EXPERIENCING
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH IS WHY
DENTAL PLANS VOLUNTARILY
PROVIDED. FINISHED NEARLY
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
RELIEF INCLUDE DIRECT TV HE
GRANTS. INCREASED FEES LOANS
AND MANY OTHER PROGRAMS THAT AS
FAR REACHING DATA REQUESTED BY
THE STATE. ENDED TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MANY PLANTS BEGUN RAISING
THEIR STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT
FEES. TO ACCOUNT FOR HIGHER PP
COSTS. WENT UP TO NEARLY THIRTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS A DENTAL
PLAN SUPPORT. DENNIS ALSO
RECEIVE FEDERAL PPP LOANS
BERRIES PP ASSISTANCE AND JUST
RECENTLY THE STATE APPROVED
ANOTHER TWO BILLION DOLLARS. IN
SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF ON TOP OF
THE NATION REALLY COMING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
INSERTING INTERESTINGLY THE
BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE PROVIDERS
JUST BY NEED. AVERAGE JUST
BECAUSE OUR PLAN FOR CLAIMS.
CLAIMS BY THE PRE COLD LEVELS
AND IN SOME AREAS OVER PRE CALL
DOUBLES. THIS TREND BEARS
WATCHING A DENTAL PLAN A DENTAL
PLAN TO DENTAL PATIENT VOLUMES
CONTINUE TO INCREASE. WHAT PPE
COSTS CONTINUE TO GO DOWN
BEFORE ANY LEGISLATION IS
PASSED. BECAUSE B. TWO FORTY
TWO WILL RAISE THEIR PREMIUMS
AND JEOPARDIZE COVERAGE FOR
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS. FOR
CALIFORNIANS GIVE ME. S. YOUR
NO VOTE. THANK IS MUCH. MAKE
YOU NYCLU SAYS PLEASE. PLEASE
BRING A- NYCLU MACAU SAID HELP.
MODERATOR. I IF YOU JOHN IS A-
HOSTED LINE IS OPEN. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT OKAY. HE ISN'T ON THE IN
THE WORLD LET'S KEEP MOVING-
ALL RIGHT SO LET'S GO AHEAD AS
ANY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
FROM THE GALLERY. SAME NINE IN
ROOM TWO TWENTY FORTY OPTUS
MONEY OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
FORTY TWO NOT SEEING ANY. IF
THIS RESOURCE IS NOT ON THE
LINE AND LET'S GO AHEAD AND
OPEN THE LINE TO WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. TWO FORTY TWO. AND AGAINST
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
AT THIS POINT- PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE OPPOSED TO TWO FORTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND OUR FIRST LINE IS THREE
EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I'M
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT BUT DIDN'T
GET CALLED ON DURING THE
SUPPORT SECTION THIS IS KIM
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION. IN
SUPPORT BY I THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- JUST HEARD A IS A
SUPPORT THAT NO RIGHT. NEXT
CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT
LINE SO. FIVE THREE SEVENTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON A GERMAN
PAN THE SAME ISSUE WITH ME THIS
IS NOT MY PARNELL CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT- LOOKS PLEASE
CONTINUE. THE NEXT LINE PLEASE.
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND I THINK HE AND I
WOULD KEEP YOU PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
ALSO FLIP FLOP HERE IN SUPPORT
BASED ON PFT PUBLIC ENEMY THANK
YOU MODERATE HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE ON THE LINES. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THIRTEEN PEOPLE QUEUED UP.
OKAY AGAIN WE'RE VERY SHORT ON
TIME BUT I WANT TO TRY SO WITH
PEOPLE AND JUST QUICKLY- NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION I REALIZE
MIGHT HAVE SOME PEOPLE FLIP
FLOPPING HERE. WHICH IS ROLL
THROUGH THESE- NEXT NEXT BLIND
PLEASE. THAT'S THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. TERM
MEMBERS KATHY MUSTARD WITH
DELTA DENTAL OPPOSED THANK
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE THREE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
HI MY NAME'S AROUND ALSO LISA
CALLING- AND IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FORTY TWO ON BEHALF OF A
MIDDLE OF A COMMUNITY THAT. ALI
SOLUTION FROM US POLICY ON THE
WHEN I. YOU WHEN IT'S TIME
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
LINE PLEASE. THREE FIFTY YOUR
LINER OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS RUDY PUTS ON BEHALF OF
ANY OF THE WHAT THE MY THING WE
ARE SUPPORT OF SB TWO FOUR TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU EXCELLENTLY.
THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS ALEXEY BY
PHONE BECAUSE PRODUCE AND
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
AND SUPPORT SB TWO FOUR TWO
THANK YOU NEXT LINE PLEASE.
LINE THREE OH TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OUR SALONA AMERICA'S
PHYSICIAN GROUPS IN SUPPORT OF
NEXT LINE PLEASE. AND YOUR LINE
IS BLIND TO FORTY NINE. THIS IS
YOUR MEMBERS JOHN WHEN YOU'RE
ON THE UP AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS AND OPPOSITION.
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT NEXT LINE
PLEASE. THE LION THREE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
AND THAT COMES TO MIND THREE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STEPHANIE
WADKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
IN OPPOSITION OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. AND THAT
COMES TO MIND THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THAT'S
MIDDLE POLITICAL. YES DONALD UP
WITH JUNGLE MOST THEY LOS. OKAY
CRISIS THANK YOU LINE PLEASE.
WHAT COMBINED FOOD BUY TO SELL
EIGHT. JUST STRUCTURE MEMBERS
TEN BAD REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FOUR TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE PLEASE. LINE THREE
FIFTY FOUR. RIGHT CENTER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IF THE
COURT AS AMENDED THANK YOU NEXT
LINE PLEASE. BLIND ONE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ONE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE
ALONG THE LINE THREE SIXTY NINE
OUR LINE ONE FIFTY ARE YOU
THERE. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK GOODNESS
ARE ABOUT THE FUTURE MANY
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER AT HER
ONCE AGAIN WITH THE MUSIC ON
THE CAN ACTUALLY ORGANIZE
PROJECT IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE THREE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE SPOTLIGHT ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. OKAY
THANK YOU SELECT BUT MY COUNTY
AT LEAST I'VE COUNTED THIRTEEN
HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE ON THE
LINE. WE HAVE TWO MORE IN Q.
OKAY LET'S TAKE THE NEXT TO AND
THEN WE'LL WRAP IT UP. THANK
YOU AND THAT'S LINE TO THIRTY
ONE. NINE TWO THIRTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TENER IS JOHNNY CAN
AND ON BEHALF OF THE QUOTATION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANTS RIGHT
CHIRLA IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FOUR TWO OKAY THANK YOU. THE
NEXT ONE. AND OUR FINAL ONE
ADELINE THREE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LET ME YES. OKAY MY
NAME IS MARCO THESE ARE NOT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LOCAL BUT
IF YOU A COMPANY CANNOT HANDLE
BEHALF OR CALIFORNIA HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT IN SUPPORT OF GOOD
GALA. OKAY THANK YOU. AND I
UNDERSTAND IS THAT MISTER LEWIS
THIS IS TRYING TO CALL IN.
SENATOR YOU ANY IDEA OF THE
PRESENCE OF A NEED TO.
MODERATOR ARE YOU ABLE TO FIND
HIM AT ALL OR IS IT JUST NOT.
OKAY HE SAID HE'S ON THE PUBLIC
LINE MODERATOR YOU ABLE TO FIND
HIM AT ALL. AGAIN APPRECIATE IT
ONCE PATIENTS WITH OUR
TECHNOLOGY. HI HELLO HI
SERIOUSNESS ALL RIGHT- WE ARE
SEVERELY SHORT ON TIMES BUT- A
TWO MINUTES OR LESS. SERVICES
ARE YOU WANT. TIGHTER DEAR
VOICE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU ALL
RIGHT. YEAH WELL WE FIGURED IT
OUT. MISTER CHAIR. YEAH I WOULD
I WOULD JUST RIGHT INTO IT-
NICHOLAS WE CALIFORNIA'S OF
HEALTH PLANS WERE OPPOSED SB
TWO FORTY TWO- WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION WITH THE SENATOR
WE KNOW WAS INTENTIONS ARE GOOD
WE DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS A
SHORT SIGHTED PROPOSAL BEING
PROMOTED AT THE WRONG TIME. THE
NEW REIMBURSEMENT MANDATE FOR
HEALTH PLANS TO PAY FOR A BROAD
ARRAY OF BUSINESS EXPENSES. YOU
KNOW I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
ITS BROADER THAN PEOPLE HERE
INCLUDING WAS LIKE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS INTERESTING.
AND TRANSPORTERS SPECIMENS. SO
IT'S NOT LIMITED TO KEEP THE-
AND YOU KNOW I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
RECOGNISE IT FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME. LAST YEAR- PATIENT VOLUME
WAS DOWN TO THE DUE TO THE
GOVERNMENT'S RECOMMENDATION TO
HOLD ELECTED TO COME HERE. THAT
IS WHY EARLY IN A PANDEMIC
HEALTH PLAN TO STEP DOWN. TO
ASSIST OUR PROVIDER PARTNERS IN
A MYRIAD OF WAYS. EXTENDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE WHICH
INCLUDED THE DONATION OF P. P.
OF AND OTHER SERVICES- WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE BILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE AND FEDERAL ASSISTANCE TO
PROVIDERS TO SEE THEM THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC. I MEAN.
CONDITIONALLY BILLS DIRECTLY.
EXISTING PROGRAM IN THE- COUGH
FOR. IN URGENT PROCEDURES- AND-
ART DALY. THAT- NO ARE BACK TO
PRE PAY. LEVELS AND CLEAN ALL
YOU IN A READ ANALYSIS BY
HOWEVER YOU. BACK THAT UP.
PROVIDERS OR THE RECEIPT.
BILLIONS IN PER MONTH FROM
HEALTH PLANS OF PATIENTS IN
CAPITAL PAYMENT. ON THESE ARE.
THAT GO THE DOOR REGARDLESS OF
PATIENT IN INCOME FROM SIR AND
BUSINESS ADMIN. COSTS. MISTER
WORTH ABOUT FIFTY TO FIFTY FIVE
BILL DOLLARS PER YEAR AND AGAIN
NOT TIED TO PATIENT- IN OTHER
POINT ARRAY MISTER. AND MA'AM
IT. REALLY OVER THE LAST YEAR
IN PLANS ARE TO THE THIRTY WITH
IN PERSON SERVICES. WILL BE
OVERHEAD PER IN SOME CASES
ACTUALLY DECLINED THIS IS NOT
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION. HERE
OPENS TO THE CONSUMER HARM IS
AT BILL FOR HEALTH PLANS TO DO
CRITICAL PRISON OR ASK YOU TO
WRITE CONSUMERS TIME UP HERE.
AWAY FROM CARE TO NON. SERVICES
I MEAN WE- DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS
TIME SO WE ARE YOU TO VOTE NO
THANK AND- THANK. TECHNOLOGY
WHICH OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. THAT OF COURSE. AND
COMMON FROM THE COMMITTEE US
ROCK. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
YOU KNOW I READ. THAT THIS.
BILL WILL BE. FOR HEALTH- PLANS
AND OTHERS IMPLEMENT AND
THERE'S SOME KIND ISSUE BUT
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE
REIMBURSEMENT IS TIED TO
SPECIFIC PATIENT ENCOUNTERS-
AND A AND A BILLING CODE IN THE
TRADITIONAL MANNER THE BILLING
IS. IS CONDUCTED AND GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE'RE IN- I
PLAN TO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. THERE IS ONE ISSUE
HAVING TO DO WITH THE
DEFINITION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THAT'S WHEN I BRING
UP IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
LOCAL. MERGERS TO ACTIONS HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO DECLARE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES AND-
IF THAT'S TRUE AND GIVEN THAT I
WOULD ASK THAT THE AUTHOR TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT AND- PERHAPS
MAKE SURE THAT WE SPECIFICALLY
NARROW THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
EMERGENCY AND DEFINE IT TO. A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY THAT IS
STILL THE CLEARED UP THE STATE
LEVEL OR THE NATIONAL LEVEL. AS
HE MOVES THIS BILL FORWARD FROM
THIS COMMITTEE- ONWARD AND
UPWARD IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS ARE AT CENTER
MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I WAS TRYING TO GET SOME
ANSWERS TO THIS PRIOR TO THIS
POINT CENTER SURE IN TIME BUT I
WONDER IF THE AUTHOR COULD
JUST. CAN YOU JUST TELL ME WHAT
THE AMENDMENTS ARE. YES CENTERS
SO THE I CAN GIVE YOU THE
ESSENCE OF THE AMOUNTS I DON'T
HAVE THEM IN FRONT OF ME SO-
THE FIRST AMENDMENT- IT
NARROWED THE SCOPE WITH THE
BILL DELIBERATELY BY INCLUDING
AN EXPLICIT DEFINITION FOR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS SO IT
WASN'T- AMBIGUOUS OR VAGUE.
SECOND AMENDMENT IS SPECIFIED
AMENDED IS FOR THE PLANS WOULD
ONLY BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE- FOR
THOSE SUPPLIES USED ON THE
MEMBERS OF THOSE PLANS RIGHT SO
PLANS WERE GOING TO HAVE TO.
REIMBURSE ON A PRO RATA BASIS
TO SOME OF THE BAY CITY WOULD
TIE DIRECTLY. AS AN ROTH POINT
OUT TO ACTUAL SERVICES
PROVIDED- AND COACH PROVIDED
UNDER THE BUILDING- FOR THOSE
SERVICES- AND THEN THE LAST.
WAS ABOUT LANGUAGE TO REIMBURSE
FOR P. IN TESTING AND OTHER
COSTS- ONLY FOR THE DURATION OF
THE CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES I'D LIKE TAKE THIS
MOMENT. TO ACKNOWLEDGE- TED
WROTE THAT'S A GOOD POINT- AND
YOU KNOW BUT I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE. TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AT THE STATE LEVEL.
OR AT A MINIMUM. IS THAT WHAT
TO EXPECT PEACE. IT DOES THANK
YOU AND I'M JUST. I THINK I
WANT TO TOUCH ON- THE- YOU SAID
IT WOULD ONLY BE REQUIRED.
DURING THE CURRENT- HEALTH
ISSUE. SEVEN IT IS MEAN. FOR AS
LONG AS- LIKE. WHO HAS TO
DECLARE THAT WE NO LONGER HAVE
THIS HEALTH EMERGENCIES- TO
GENEROSA POINT WHICH IS A GOOD
ONE THE STATE THAT THE STATE
WOULD WITH AN CDPH ORDERS IN
ENDING THE STATE OF EMERGENCY.
HE GETS THE GOVERNMENT THAT THE
DEVICES CITY PH IS. A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY SO THAT THE
DECLARATION WOULD BE LIFTED
OKAY- AND I AND I ASK THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE.
IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY IS
DECLARED OFTENTIMES IT IT GOES
ON FOR YEARS IT DOESN'T AND YOU
KNOW RIGHT AWAY THESE THESE
COME ON FOR SOME TIME AND SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THIS WILL
BE- THIS STATE OF EMERGENCY
WILL B IN EFFECT. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAVE ANY INSIGHT INTO
THAT BUT I JUST THAT IS A
CONCERN OF MINE IS HOW HOW LONG
THIS WILL CONTINUE I THINK IT'S
A FAIR POINT SO- THE STATE
EMERGING COVERS ONLY THIS.
PARTICULAR CENTER BUT A WHOLE
RANGE OF OTHERS AND SO- IT YOU
KNOW IT ALSO APPLIES TO-
RESTRICTIONS ON BUSINESS
ETCETERA THE BLUEPRINT FREE
OPENING- AND SO IT WILL GET
LIFTED- AND ITS APPLICATION
WILL NO LONGER APPLIED A WHOLE
HOST OF AREAS I DON'T THINK
IT'S THE SAME- TO YOUR POINT OF
YOU KNOW SOMETHING LIKE A
DROUGHT. YEAH IT'S FAIRLY
EXPLICIT MISCARRIAGE AND I'D BE
GLAD TO GET YOU YOU KNOW THE
MORE CLARIFICATION. LETTER
THANK YOU. THIRTY GROVE. I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I'D
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR I KNOW-THAT HE IS- HIS INTENTION THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL IS A
GOOD INTENTION- I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ARE YOU LISTEN TO. YOU
KNOW ONE OF WITNESSES AND
TESTIMONY IS SMALL PROVIDER
THAT HAS BEEN. YOU KNOW-EXPENDING A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES ON ON PP COVERAGE.
A MY CONCERN LIES WITH SMALL.
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE WESTERN
HEALTH INSURANCE THAT PROVIDES.
COVERAGE I WOULD HATE TO SEE.
SUTTER HEALTH AND- I GUESS MY
REAL CONCERN IS THE DEFINITION
OF PP WHAT'S I'VE I'VE LOOKED
AT YOUR BILL AND I DO HAVE-
SOME. OF THE DESCRIPTION IN
THERE BUT IT'S NOT- IT'S NOT
SPECIFIC WHAT'S YOUR DEFINITION
OF PP. TO THE CHAIR. PRICES ARE
GROWING. LET ME ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION I THINK TWO TWO YEAR
AND- YEAH WE'VE BEEN DOWN TO
MAKE A- OF SASS SAYS FACTORED
IN THE OPPONENT. THAT
OPPOSITION BILL I I'M GLAD TO
RIVER AT IT WOULD BE A I DON'T
HAVE TO GO INTO. IN A BROAD OR
NARROW DOESN'T PPE- WHAT WE'RE
ASPIRING TO IS IN OKAY OF A
UNIVERSE SIX. DEFINITION OF
THOSE ITEM. THAT ARE THAT BEEN
A SPECIAL IS NO. FOR A CO SAVE
OF AND THAT CENTER- AND I'M I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THEIR LANGUAGE
AND THAT MAKES THAT POSSIBLE.
THIS IS YOU FOR THAT IN YOUR
BILL ON ON ON PAGE TWO LINES
THROUGH. IT SAYS SEARCH
PERSONAL PART EQUIPMENT OR PPE
INFO CAN SUPPLIES OR MATERIALS.
MEDICAL DIED EQUIPMENT
INCLUDING TESTING. TO PER SE.
THE COST OF TRAINS SPACE. IN
TO. SYSTEMS ARE AND- FOR
PROCESS TEST. AND OR ANY OTHER
REASON TECH. EXPO DOES VERY TO
AS AS A P. FOR. PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. SO I JUST WONDERED
IF AT ALL YOU COULD TELL ME
DOES IT COVER DISPOSABLE
MEDICAL GLOVES. IT THE I ASSUME
IT- YEAH. SOLIDIFY FOR MEDICAL
EXAM ROOM MEDICAL OFF SUPPLY.
ONLY WHEN USED IN THE CONDUCT
OF THE MEDIC EXAMINER DURING
THE PUBLIC OF EMERGENCY WAYS
THEY- AND DESERVE TO PUT. THAT
AND AGAIN WE WE'VE HAD A AMEND-
THAT'LL FOR IN THE BILLING
PROCESS TO BE VERY SPECIFIC
AROUND THOSE THE BILLING IN THE
COACH. SO N. I LOOKED AT AND I
TALKED TO SOME OF MY HOSPITALS
ABOUT SOME OF THE MEDICAL- IN
SOME DOCTORS WHAT IS SOME OF
THE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT OR THE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT%
THAT IS SUPPLIED. BY SEN YOU
KNOW BY I SAID YOU GUYS AND I
WAS TALKING TO THEM. I MEAN THE
LIST ITSELF LIKE YOU KNOW
SERVICE IN AND- DISINFECTANTS-
AT HAND SANITIZERS AND
DISPOSABLE HAND SANITIZER-
EQUIPMENT TO DISPOSE OF IT.
ONLINE AUCTION NINETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS WHICH ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE A HOSPITAL KANSAS WAS
THE LAB COATS DISPOSABLE SHOE
COVERS SAFETY GLASSES EYEWEAR
STATIONS INCLUDING THE PLANNING
ASSOCIATED WITH EYE WASH
STATION COMMITTEE KIT. I JUST
THAT IT THE BILL IS SO VERY
BROAD. THAT DOES NOT IT DOESN'T
JUST SAY PP LIKING YOU KNOW
DOWN IN IN FIVE MASS SERVICE.
AND SO MY CONCERN IS LIKE I
SAID IS THAT WHERE DOES THE
COST COVERAGE COME FROM IF
PLANS IF THIS BILL DOESPASS IN
PLANS ARE REQUIRED. TO COVER
THIS TO REIMBURSED- MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WHICH I UNDERSTAND
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL COST IF
THERE IS ADDITIONAL COST FOR
EVERY BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH PLEXIGLASS
MOVING THINGS PROVIDING MASS TO
YOU KNOW TO SERVERS AND- YOU
KNOW THERE'S A COST TO THIS
PANDEMIC FOR ALMOST EVERY.
SINGLE BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
THE CALIFORNIA IF NOT EVERY
BUSINESS- I DISTANTLY IT'S VERY
BROAD AND I'D LIKE TO SEE IF
YOU'D BE INTERESTED IN IN
SPECIFICALLY DEFINING WHAT P.
P. E. IS INSTEAD OF THESE BROAD
STATEMENTS. I SUPPOSE I AM TO
DO THAT SPECIALLY- CONCERT WITH
THE SPONSORS PROBABLY THIS IS
NOT A GOOD VENUE FOR DOING THAT
SO- WE HAVE AN DE. TO WORK. THE
OPPOSITION WITH THE CHURCH IN
THE- TO SURE THE LAND IS CLEAR-
AND IN CAN. WITH CONTENT. WHICH
TO PUT. PRACTITIONERS TO SMALL
AND MEDIUM SIZE PRACTICE. WHO
HAVE BEEN. BY THE CALL. OF CODE
REAL XIN- THERE A FRESH ABOVE
WHICH- I THINK YOU CAN. OVER
VALID ARE YOU REST- THOSE ARE
REAL TO THESE. AND I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IS RENTED CLEAR IN THE
LEGISLATION. THE YOU FOR THAT
AND BASED ON THE RESPONSES THAT
IT'S FOR SMALL AND MEDIUM OF
PRACTITIONERS- LIKE THE ONE
THAT TESTIFIED IN THAT IN THIS.
POSITION OF SUPPORT THE
GENTLEMAN WHO HAS A PRACTICE IN
SAN BERNARDINO- IS I AND I
AGAIN I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
READ THE ENTIRE BILL I JUST
READ THE FIRST THREE PAGES-
FIRST FOUR PAGES AND- IF- IS
THERE ANY LANGUAGE IN THERE
THAT LIMITS THE SIZE OF THE
PROVIDER SO IT'S NOT. YOU KNOW.
MAJOR HOSPITALS MAJOR LIKE
SUTTER HEALTH- WHEN COLLINS
HEALTH DON'T MEAN IT LIKE THAT
BUT IS IT JUST FOR SOME. MEDIA
PROVIDER. NOT CURRENTLY LANGER
BUT WITH WE TRIED ADOPT. FROM A
DIRECTION WHICH AROUND. THE
ACTUAL- SIR- IN THE BUILDING
PROCESS. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
AND I THAT AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR HONESTY THAT ARE YOU
HAVING I GUESS MIKE- IN MY CAN
IS THAT. YOU SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFIED THAT THIS PARTICULAR
BILLING YOUR INTENT IS FOR
SMALL OR MEDIUM PROVIDERS BUT
YET THERE'S NO LANGUAGE IN
THERE. YOU SEE IT'S FOR
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
BUT IT EXPANDS UP TO TECHNOLOGY
IN A VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS
THAT COULD BE VERY COSTLY. AND
T. INDIVIDUALS PROVIDING
SERVICES- THE PLANS TO RE
REIMBURSE SO- I CAN'T SUPPORT
THE BILL BECAUSE OF THAT AND IT
JUST SEEMS WAY TOO BROAD. AND
IT IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME THAT IT
DOESN'T JUST PROVIDE FOR SMALL.
INDEPENDENT PROVIDERS WHICH
WERE ON THE LINE WHICH WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE TAKEN
CARE OF BUT- IT'S FAR TOO
COSTLY OF THE BUILD. FOR THE
PLANS I WOULD THINK. SO THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. C. NINE NINE THE
RESULTS AND NEWMAN I WANT THANK
YOU SO MUCH- FOR- WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON- AS WELL THE
OPPOSITION ON AMENDMENTS I
THINK THE- GIVEN SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS FROM- GOOD FRIEND
CENTER GROVE I DO WANT TO
CLARIFY FIRST OF ALL IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL- FOR. EXAMPLE
THE INCREASE PAYMENTS ARE DUE
TO IMAGINE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
YOU'RE A SMALL OWNER LIKE I AM-
AND- YOU SUDDENLY YOUR COSTS GO
UP NOT JUST BECAUSE THERE'S A
PANDEMIC BUT BECAUSE THERE HAVE
BEEN A SPECIFIC PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDERS THAT YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW
BECAUSE THERE ARE NEW STANDARD
OF CARE GUIDELINES THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY LIBEL FOR IF YOU DON'T
FOLLOW- SO YOU COULD BE SUED IF
YOU DIDN'T FOLLOW THEM. AND
THERE'S ACTUALLY ADDITIONAL
EXPENSES THAT AND BUT YET WHEN
YOU NEGOTIATE YOUR CONTRACT
WITH THE HEALTH PLAN DOES
EXPENSES WERE PART OF THAT
CONTRACT BECAUSE THEY WERE DONE
PRIOR TO THE CODE BUT WHAT WE
DID SAY WHAT WE DID DO IN THE
AMENDMENTS TO SAY THAT IT'S NOT
JUST TILL THE END OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY IS THAT
ACTUALLY IF YOU. HAVE A NEW
NEGOTIATION WITH THE HEALTH
PLAN THAT NOW YOU KNOW WHAT
THIS EXPENSES ARE YOU CAN
CORPORATE INTO YOUR NEGOTIATION
THEN ACTUALLY AND THEN SO YOU
COULD NEGOTIATE NEW RATES THAT
WOULD INCORPORATE THOSE
ADDITIONAL EXPENSES THE OTHER
PART- THE AMENDMENT WAS
ACTUALLY TO NEVER AGAIN THERE
THE BILL SO THAT YOUR- AND THAT
IS SO THAT THE IT'S EXPENSES
RELATED TO HAVING TO FOLLOW-
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS AND OTHER-
AND- THE STANDARD CARE
GUIDELINES THAT WERE NOT
PRESENT PRIOR TO THE- PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. SO AGAIN THIS
IS NOT OPEN ENDED- IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC TO THOSE TYPES OF
EXPENSES I POINT OUT THAT AGAIN
AS YOU SAID CENTER NEWMAN- WE
ALSO SAID THAT IT'S ONLY FOR
THE PATIENT TO THAT PARTICULAR
PLANT A LOT OF PRACTICES
ACTUALLY SEE PATIENTS THAT ARE
COVERED PIPE PLANS OR MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN SO THEY'RE NEVER
GOING TO GET THOSE- THOSE
EXPENSES COVERED THERE BUT- I
DO APPRECIATE THAT YOU WORK
WITH MY OFFICE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THESE ISSUES.
WE DID NARROW THE BILL AND THAT
WAY TO BE SURE THAT'S VERY
TOUGH- TOWARD. SURE WE SUSTAIN
OUR- PHYSICIAN AND DENNIS DOWN
AND OTHER NOW BY WAY DOESN'T
HOSP SO HEALTH THE HOSPITAL'S
HAS NOT BEEN A FROM THIS BILL-
THAT ANOTHER THING THAT WAS
DONE AS A- AND- I THINK IT IS
IT DOES THE PURPOSES BILL TO
TRY TO. THE THE MAINTENANCE
WORK TRY TO STRAY THE RIGHT
BALANCE THE FACT THAT WORKED
WITH US MY COMMITTEES WELL AS
WHAT THE OPPOSITE- JUST FIRST
COMEY HER I'M SURE TO BE
ADDITION. CONVERSATIONS I DO A
PRE THE CONCERNS OR TRYING TO
STRIKE DURING BALANCE IN THAT
WE HAVE A- YOU KNOW AS AS A AND
DENTAL NETWORKS- DIED BECAUSE
ON THE DENTAL SIDE I JUST POINT
OUT- SAID WILL PERSONAL NOW
ABOUT. EXAMPLE OF DIDN'T A FACT
THAT NEED AND NINETY FIVE MASKS
ALL PRIOR TO THE UPPER- BECAUSE
OF THE OPERATING GO AND SAY YOU
HAVE TO AND I FIVE BY THE WE'RE
DIDN'T SHOW AND QUITE HIGHLY
PRICE- SINCE THE PANDEMIC. AND
SO THE ONLY THING ABOUT WHERE
TO THE WHAT HAPPEN TO THOSE AND
THEN OF HOW DO WE DISTRIBUTE AS
BECAUSE IN A WAY. THAT THAT
THAT- ALLOWS A PRACTICES TO CAN
SO THE WE STILL HAVE A TO THE
PEOPLE PROVIDING THE CARE SO-
AGAIN A REAL APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING AMEND AND WORKING I SURE
THERE'S A DISH WORKING TO DO-
SAID NEWMAN- SO WITH THAT- WE
YOU LIKE CLOSE. I'D BE MR SURE
YOU CLOSE BETTER THAN I EVER
COULD. AT THIS ONE OF THE
BETTER OF HAVING A DOCTOR IN
THE HOUSE. SO THANK YOU SO CALL
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON S.
B. TWO FOUR TWO. OKAY THANK YOU
THERE A MOTION ON THIS BILL
WILL OKAY AT BY CENTER ROCK-
LOS IS. LOOKING FOR A BREAK SHE.
I GROWTH. GROWTH KNOW HER TADO.
LEYVA FIVE LEYVA AYE THE MOM HI
LEON I ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WIENER AYE WIENER AYE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS LIKE TO MISS
RICHARD THAT EIGHTEEN OF. THE
TWO. HELLO HELLO HELLO- OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO THAT BILL IS OUT
EIGHT TWO STARS ON THE SHOW I
GOT EVERYONE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THE NEXT BILL IS ACTUALLY
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TWO FORTY
SEVEN BY A CENTER EGGMAN I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CARE.
SAID GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING SB TWO
FORTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD CREATE
A MUCH NEEDED A RARE DISEASE
ADVISORY COUNCIL IN AN
OMBUDSMAN IN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCY. THERE ARE OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND RARE DISEASES AMERICA
ROUGHLY ONE IN TEN AMERICANS
HAVE A RARE DISEASE WHICH MEANS
AT APPROXIMATELY FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE SUFFERING FROM
A RARE DISEASE ABOUT HALF OF
WHICH ARE CHILDREN. AND AT
LEAST. THE A THIRD WON'T LIVE
TO SEE THEIR FIFTH BIRTHDAY- SO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO THIS OKAY SO
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE CANCER
SOCIETY OF THE HEART DISEASE
SOCIETY OF BREAST CANCER
SOCIETY THERE'S ALL THESE
SOCIETIES FOR DISEASES BUT
THERE'S SO MANY RARE DISEASES
THAT DON'T HAVE A SINGLE PERSON
TO SPEAK FOR THEM- SO THIS
WOULD CREATE AN OMBUDSMAN TO BE
IN THAT AND THE DEPARTMENT. AS
WELL AS AN ADVISORY COUNCIL
SOMEONE THINGS LIKE PANDEMICS
COME UP- THAT WE HAVE SOMEONE
THERE TO BE ABLE TO ADVOCATE
FOR THESE FOLKS WHO OTHERWISE
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY ELSE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEM. THE COUNCIL.
THAT WILL GO ALONG WITH THE OPS
BUT BEEN WILL WORK TO EDUCATE
AND SUPPORT THE PERSON AND
THEIR DUTIES- THE RARE DISEASE
COMMUNITY IS DIVERSE
INTERSECTIONAL. MISSILE BROAD
STAKEHOLDER- A GATHERING IS
NEEDED- I WILL BE VERY BRIEF
PETITIONS FOR INTEREST OF TIME-
SIXTEEN OTHER STATES HAVE
SIMILAR LAWS THOUGH. THIS IS
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE. WE ARE
THE LARGEST STATE IN THE NATION
SO IT SEEMS LIKE WE SHOULD HAVE
THE- THE MOST REPRESENTATION
SPEAKING FOR THOSE. WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE A SEAT
AT THE TABLE SO THIS IS JUST
ONE SEAT AT THE TABLE. FOR OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND DISEASES- I HAVE
WITH ME TO SPEAK TODAY IS KATIE
F. HOFFMANN A PEDIATRICIAN AT
MARIN HEALTH MEDICAL CENTER. IN
ADRIAN SHAPIROBELLCORE'S
FOUNDER AND CEO OF ACCESS
ADVOCACY WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THOSE WITH SICKLE CELL
PATIENTS. THANKS SO MUCH CENTER
EGGMAN- SO LET'S- BRING ON TO
THE LINE- FIRST- WE HAVE-
DOCTOR KATIE HOFFMAN. AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY DR ADRIAN SHOULD
HERO. THOUGH CORES- SO LET'S GO
AND AGAIN I WOULD DIED. LEVINE
THE WITNESSES THAT WE ACTUALLY
AT LEAST HAVE NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION THAT I SEE- FOR THIS
BILL SO IF YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED. AS THE
START WITH DOCTOR HOFFMAN. TWO
MINUTES MAXIMUM I. WHAT
TRUMPCARE SENATORS AFTER PAN
AND AS A MEMBER OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR KATIE
HOPKINS I LIVE IN MARIN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA WHEN A PRACTICING
PEDIATRICIAN AND MOTHER OF TWO
CHILDREN. AT THE PEDIATRICIAN
I'M NO STRANGER TO CHALLENGING
DIAGNOSES AND DIFFICULT MEDICAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH PARENTS YET
EVEN MIGHT HAVE TO HIT THAT THE
NOT PREPARE ME FOR THE
DEVASTATION OF LEARNING ON MY
OWN CHILD HAD A DEGENERATIVE
AND TERMINAL DISEASE I JUST
NINETEEN MONTHS OLD MY SON
PETER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH NEW
COLLEAGUES ACCURATE OF THE TWO
OR HUNTER SYNDROME A RARE
GENETIC DISEASE IN WHICH
DEFICIENCY OF A CRITICAL AND I
NEED TO PROGRESSIVE ORGAN
DAMAGE COGNITIVE REGRESSION AND
PREMATURE DEATH. LIKE MANY
PEDIATRIC RARE DISEASES THERE
IS NO CARE PETER IS NOW THREE
AND A HALF AND THIS YEAR WE
WILL CELEBRATE THE TWO YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF HIS SUCCESSFUL
BONE MARROW TRANSPLANT BRAVELY
DONATED BY A BIG SISTER WHICH
HAS IMPROVED BUT NOT CONDITION.
HERE STATE FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
PEDIATRIC MEDICAL SPECIALISTS
REQUIRE SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
LOCAL THERAPIES WEAKLY
COORDINATING HIS. CARE AT MY
SECOND FULL TIME JOB. YET
DESPITE OUR EFFORTS APPEARS TO
BE INFORMED. PROGRESS HE'LL
GRAB LOSE ABILITY TALK. WALK
EAT AND RECOGER THEIR FAMILIES.
WITHOUT A CURATIVE. HE WON'T
LET HAS OR- FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
AND TODAY TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
OF THAT THE PEOPLE SEVEN TO
CREATE AN ART IN OMBUDSPERSON.
TO REPRESENT THE COURT AN
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA RATED
THE FAMILIES LIKE MINE. AS PART
OF MY FAMILY DURING HIS THEN WE
HAD MANY ADVANTAGES BECAUSE OF.
MY MEDICAL TRAINING AND HEALTH
CARE CONNECTION- TO THE
PATIENTS FAMILIES. ARE FRANKLY-
OVERWHELMED BY SOME MANAGER DAY
TO DAY CARE MANY OF MY PATIENTS
FAMILIES BARELY SPEAK ENGLISH
AND HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES AND
HEALTH LITERACY. AS THEIR
PEDIATRICIAN I WANT TO HELP BUT
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT RECORDED IT
RARE DISEASE RESOURCES. INTO
EQUALLY OVERWHELMING TO
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM FOR THE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. AND AR
ACAN OMBUDSPERSON CAN BRING
TANGIBLE BENEFITS AND WE'LL
HOPE EVERY CALIFORNIA RARE
DISEASE FAMILY BY ADVOCATING
FOR STREAMLINED ACCESS TO
SPECIALTY MEDICAL CARE.
COORDINATING STATE SUPPORTED
SERVICES. AND PROMOTING MUCH
NEEDED. RARE DISEASE RESEARCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THAT'S
FOR ON OUR NEXT WITNESS ENTRY
SHAPIRO ABOUT COURSE. PLEASE
BEGIN. I WANT I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO SENATOR DR PAN
CENTER DEMAND AS AND ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
I'M A TWO INCH APPAREL ON THE
FIFTH GENERATION OF MOTHERS IN
MY FAMILY TO HAVE A CHILD WITH
SICKLE CELL DISEASE. S. C. D.
AS A GROUP OF GENETIC BLOOD
DISORDERS THAT RESULT IN PAIN
ORGAN DAMAGE AND A REDUCED
LIFESPAN IT IS THE LARGEST RARE
DISEASE IN THE U. S. THERE OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND ABOUT THE
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE. EVERYTHING WAS
THE- TO NEW CREE. HEY- AND SHE
IN HER CHILD FRIENDS RECEIVED
GOOD AT BASED CARE IN THE
PEDIATRIC CENTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH NO NEW
TREATMENTS AND NO BONE MARROW
TRANSPLANT OPTION THE DISEASE
PROGRESSION AND SHE REACHED HER
MID TWENTY S. C. D. TOOK OVER
OUR LIVES. EXTENSIVE
HOSPITALIZATION MANY OF WHICH
MIRRORED THE END OF LIFE
EXPERIENCES WENT ON FOR OVER
TEN YEARS. THE MEDICAL BILLS
RAN INTO MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND OF COURSE THE EMOTIONAL.
COST WAS IMMEASURABLE. HUNDRED
YEARS AFTER THE DISCOVERY OF S.
C. D. THE FDA APPROVED THREE
NEW DISEASE MODIFYING DRUGS
SHIPPED HER COLLABORATION WITH
PHARMA COMPANIES GOVERNMENT
LEGISLATIVE POLICYMAKERS. AND
MANY MANY BRAVE PATIENTS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS. BUT REFER BEGAN
TAKING THE FIRST DRUG IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY. FACTS HAVE BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR OVER TEN
YEARS. EIGHT TO TEN EIGHT TO
NINE MONTHS IN THE HOSPITAL OR
CLINIC YEARLY WE LIVE DOWN TO
THREE SHORT HOSPITAL STAYS IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND NO
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN THE PAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. OUR TAKE AWAY
IS EVEN THOUGH WE HAD NEW
TREATMENTS AND ARE CLOSE TO
UNIVERSAL Q. WERE. ACCESS TO
BENEFITS ARE HAMPERED BY THE
LACK OF SERVICES PROVIDER
HESITANCY COST COVERAGE AND THE
ABSENCE OF THE STATE CHAMPIONS.
THE LESSONS LEARNED BY THE FCT
COMMUNITY FULLY DEMONSTRATE THE
NEED A DRAFT BY C. A. S. B. TWO
FORTY SEVEN. WE ASK. SUPPORT
FOR A CARDIAC IT IS NOT BUT- TO
ESTABLISH THE REPRESENTATION
AND ADVOCACY FOR ALL RARE
DISEASE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THIS COMMITMENT WILL ENSURE
ACCESS AND BENEFIT RESULTING IN
SAVING MONEY TIME AND MOST OF
ALL SAVING LINE THANK YOU. I'LL
DO THAT THEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- BUT THAT- LET'S MOVE ON
DOWN TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- THE TO GET NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
WILL START THE GALLERY SAYING
NO WITNESSES UP IN THE GALLERY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAY NO IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE A PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY SEVEN-
TO- TO TESTIFY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM LINE.
THREE OH TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. NINE THREE OH TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IS YOUR
PHONE ON MUTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BILL BARCELONA IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN GROUPS.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANK YOU
AND THAT COMES TO MIND THREE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE. NINE THREE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
**** ON BEHALF OF BIO CALM
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANK IN THAT COMES TO MIND TO
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TO NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
KAREN MAREE I'M A CARE GIVER TO
MY DAUGHTER WHO HAS ADDISON'S
DISEASE A VOLUNTEER FOR THE
NATIONAL AGREEMENT DISEASE
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS THE
HUNTINGTON'S DISEASE SOCIETY OF
AMERICA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SENATE BILL TWO FOUR SEVEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BUT WRITER
CAN I JUST ASK HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE ON THE LINE. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWELVE OKAY SO I'M GONNA
ASK YOU AGAIN WE HAVE A WE HAVE
TAKEN OPPOSITION TESTIMONY YET
BUT HAVE NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION SO- JUST ASK PEOPLE
TO GO AS QUICKLY AS THEY CAN-
BECAUSE WE ARE VOTE SHORTEN
TIME AND I WANT WE HAVE OTHER
BILLS ALSO WE NEED TO HEAR SO-
IF YOU BUT I DO WISH TESTIFIED
PLEASE JUST GO AHEAD AND DO
THAT QUICKLY NAME OR DISEASE
POSITION ONLY SECTOR PLEASE.
BAADER PLEASE OPEN THE NEXT
LINE. THANK YOU LINE THREE
NINETY FIVE GO AHEAD. WILL BE
THAT MUCH ON THIS COURT THANK
YOU. EXLINE LINE THREE NINETY
EIGHT. H. YOU CAN CANCEL THEM
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. EXLINE BLIND THREE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GERMAN
AND SENATOR EIGHTEEN REPEAL ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANK YOU
AND THAT'S LINE THREE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS FRED NO WHERE
REPRESENTING THE GOLDEN WEST
CHAPTER OF THE ALS LOU GEHRIG'S
DISEASE ASSOCIATION. AND THE
PHARMACEUTICAL RESEARCH AND
MANUFACTURERS OF AMERICA
FARMING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE THREE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS TINA FINEGOLD
I'M A CARETAKER OF A CHILD
BECAUSE SHE'S DISEASE AND I'M
ALSO A VOLUNTEER REPRESENTED AT
THE GROCERY COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. EXCELLENT LINE THREE
SIX SIX THREE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE LEAST L. CLINICAL BURKE I
HAVE CYSTIC FIBROSIS AND I ALSO
REPRESENT CYSTIC FIBROSIS
RESEARCH INSTITUTE- PRIME FROM
LOS GATOS CALIFORNIA NINE
SUPPORT AS SB TWO FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THANK YOU
AND THAT'S LINE THREE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE FAN
ON BEHALF OF VERTEX
PHARMACEUTICALS IN SUPPORT ALSO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CRISPR
THERAPEUTICS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE
THREE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M FRIEND HADN'T I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF MY GRANDDAUGHTER
WHO'S LIVING WITH CYSTIC
FIBROSIS I'M IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU NECKLINE.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS STACY
REVELA THEY LIVE IN NEVADA CITY
CALIFORNIA I HAVE A VERY YOUNG
CHILD WITH A RARE DISEASE I
WANTED TO TAKE A BREATH OF
STANDING VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB TWO FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
SENATOR EGGMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU. EXLINE I. LINE THREE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS DEBORAH VIC M. AS RARE
DISEASE ADVOCATE AND I AM VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE TWO FOUR
SEVEN AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
ADVOCATE WITH OF I THINK I
HAVEN'T FOUNDATION AND ALL
STRIPES AND THE VERY
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE MORE
PERSON Q. THEY ARE RECEIVING
THE LINE NUMBER AT THIS TIME.
LINE FOUR OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY
HABER FROM ALL CHICKEN EGGS
ARMITAGE ICAL AND SUPPORT SB
TWO FOUR SEVEN OKAY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. AND A
TOUGH TIME OKAY THANK YOU SO
NOW WILL TAKE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FORTY
SEVEN START WITH THE GALLERY
SINGLE AT THE GALLERY REMOVED
TO ROOM TO FORTY SINGLE ONE
ROOM TO FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
TWO FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
THOSE ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
KNOWING KEEPING UP OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT- WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS SARA GROVES THE BILL
BUT I DO HAVE A COMMENT OKAY
YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- VERY SELDOM DO
RARE DISEASES GET THE ATTENTION
THAT THEY NEED I HAVE- SOME
DEAR FRIENDS IN MY DISTRICT AND
THEY ARE BOYS SUFFER FROM
WHAT'S CALLED CAVERNOUS
HEMANGIOMA. IT SAYS LIKE
BLUEBERRY OR RASPBERRY TYPE
LEADS IN THEIR BRAIN AND THEIR
SPINAL CORD THE ONLY CURE IS
FOR SURGERY WHEN SOMETHING
RUPTURES. AND THEN THERE'S ONLY
ABOUT ONE IN TWO AND A PEOPLE
THAT HAVE THIS CAVERNOUS
HEMANGIOMA BUT THE KIDS THE
YOUNG KIDS THAT ARE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT SUFFER. FROM THIS
THAT I'VE HAD SEVEN SURGERIES.
IS A MUTATION. OF THIS AND
THERE'S ONLY A THIRTY PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES THAT HAVE
THIS SO THANK YOU FOR. BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I'M WITH THE
BILL. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MEMBERS.
SAYING NONE SORRY WENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH BRINGS BILLABLE
FORD. WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE TO
RARE DISEASES EVEN THOUGH THEY
MAY INDIVIDUALLY THE RARE
COLLECTIVELY THAT'S ACTUALLY
LARGE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO IMPORT
WE HEAR FROM THEM- WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU HAVE TO MY COLLEAGUE
FOR MAKING THAT AT THAT
STATEMENT. YEAH IF WE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A RARE DISEASE. ANY
DISEASE IS NOT LUCK BUT DID BUT
IF THERE'S A LARGER
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT YOU-
MORE RESEARCH AND MORE MORE
VOICES COUNT- I HAVE A STAFF
WHO HAS. CYSTIC FIBROSIS AND I
KNOW THE STRUGGLES THAT HE
LIVES WITH EVERY SINGLE DAY. MY
MOM HAD A RARE DISEASE STATUS
YOU LIVE WITH THAT FOR TEN
YEARS BEFORE. SHE DIED. SO I
KNOW THE STRUGGLES OF FAMILY
WHO DON'T HAVE ANYONE ELSE TO
SPEAK FOR THEM AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER GROVE TO
MOTIONS TO PASS BUT FOR ARE.
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE.
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AN HI CAN I AM A-
HI. MELENDEZ AYE A- HI EGGMAN
AYE GONZALEZ. AND SALAS I GROW.
GROWTH I HER TADO. FOR TOTO I
LEYVA. FIVE LEYVA HIGHLY MON
HI. LIMON AYE ROTH. ROTH AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO I WIENER BY WIENER
AYE OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT TO
LIVE IN ZERO THANK YOU LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN S. B. TWO EIGHTY BY
CEREMONY THANK U. S. AIR. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHTY WOULD REQUIRE LARGE
GROUP MARKET HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICIES TO COVER MEDICALLY
NECESSARY BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICES UNLIKE INDIVIDUALAND
SMALL GROUP MARKET HEALTH
INSURANCE REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. LARGE GROUP MARKET
HEALTH INSURANCE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO COVER MEDICALLY
NECESSARY BASIC HEALTH SERVICES
AS A RESULT OF LARGE GROUP
POLICIES ROUTINELY LIMIT OR
EXCLUDE COVERAGE. FOR ESSENTIAL
MEDICAL CARE SUCH AS OBESITY
CARE ORGAN TRANSPLANT OR
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES.
SB TWO EIGHTY WILL ALSO
CODIFIED OF THE FEDERAL THE
FEDERAL AFFORDABLE CARE ACT'S
PROHIBITION ON DISCRIMINATORY
LARGE GROUP HEALTH INSURANCE
BENEFITS. DESIGNS AND MARKETING
PRACTICES THIS PROTECTION
PROHIBITS HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES FROM DISCOURAGING
CONSUMERS WITH SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH NEEDS FROM ENROLLING IN
COVERAGE AND ALSO PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
CONSUMERS BASED ON PROTECTED
CHARACTERISTICS. THESE INCLUDE
RACE COLOR NATIONAL ORIGIN.
PRESENT OR PREDICT DISABILITY
AGE SEX EXPECTANTLY EXPECTED
LENGTH OF LIFE DEGREE OF
MEDICAL DEPENDENCY QUALITY OF
LIFE OR OTHER HEALTH
CONDITIONS. HEALTH INSURANCE
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
IS NOT CURRENTLY PROHIBITED BY
FEDERAL LAW SB TWO EIGHTY WILL
PROTECT THESE IN STATE LAW. THE
PANDEMIC HAS UNDERSCORED THE
NEED FOR. THE CALIFORNIA BERMAN
OF INSURANCE TO HAVE AUTHORITY
TO NIMBLY RESPOND TO UNEXPECTED
REAL WORLD CONDITIONS THAT CALL
FOR ROBUST REGULATION OF HEALTH
INSURANCE BENEFITS. ONLINE
TODAY I HAVE JOSEPH FIGUEROA
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR IN
THE POLICY AND LEGISLATION
BRANCH OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER DICK ON THE LOT AS
OFFICE AND DIANA DOUGLAS POLICY
AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
HEALTH ACCESS TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO OUR
WITNESSES. THE SPRING ON JUST A
FIGURE JOSEPHINE FIGUEROA FROM
THE- THE- FROM THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE I POINT
OUT I UNDERSTAND THEIR SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES FOR THIS BILL SO
IF YOU CAN KEEP YOUR REMARKS
BRIEF THAT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED AS WE STOP SEVERAL
ITEMS LEFT TO COVER AND- THE
REMAINING THIRTY. ONE MINUTES-
THIS JOSEPHINE FIGUEROA READY.
PLEASE BEGIN. I'M SORRY YOU GET
THEIR FURNITURE MEMBERS
ADJUSTING TO GROW TO BE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE-
UNFORTUNATELY THANKS A LOAN FOR
FOSTERING A TWO EIGHTY- IT DOES
IT WOULD REQUIRE A LARGE MARKET
INSURANCE POLICIES TO COVER
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. UNDER THE
INSURANCE CODE CURRENTLY NONE
OF THESE BENEFITS ARE REQUIRED
TO BE COVERED. AS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY BY LARGE. INSURANCE
POLICY AND THAT'S A RESULT OF
THE PUBLIC ARE ROUTINELY LIMIT
COVERAGE OPPORTUNITY HUB- THE
MEASURE ALL CALLS- THE FEDERAL
AID. PROHIBITION ON
DISCRIMINATION- BASED- BUT NOT
LIMITED TO A RACE COLOR
NATIONAL ORIGIN DISABILITY AGE
SEX- WITH RSPECT TO A LARGE
GROUP INSURANCE POLICIES- WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE
EXPANSION OF CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN SB TWO EIGHTY-
WILL HELP ENSURE CONSUMERS TO
HAVE. COVERED WHO ARE COVERED
BY A LARGE GROUP HEALTH
INSURANCE HAVE ACTED IN THE
SAME BASIC HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AS MILLIONS OF OTHER
CALIFORNIANS. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT ABOUT
US. I WOULD LIKE DESPERATE I
BOOK. THANK ARE LET'S NOW BE ON.
DEMAND FROM HEALTH ACCESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DIANA DOUGLAS WERE HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO EIGHTY. THREE TO EIGHTY ONE
BOTTLE OF THE PLAYING FIELD TO
ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH
COVERAGE REGULATED BY THE STATE
WOULD HAVE COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BASIC
HEALTH SERVICES. CURRENTLY
CONSUMERS WITH LARGE GROUP
COVERAGE RIGHT REGULATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ARE NOT
GUARANTEED FOR BASIC SERVICES
THAT COULD EVEN INCLUDE DOCTORS
AT THAT HOSPITAL SERVICE THAT
WOULD BE THAT THE LAB SERVICES.
UNLIKE CONSUMERS VERGE IS
REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE INDEED
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONSUMERS DESERVE TO BE
PROTECTED BY A SPEECH YOU
EIGHTEEN THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
DATE YOU HAVE ACCESS TO BASIC
SERVICES. THE BILL ALSO KIND OF
BY FEDERAL PROHIBITIONS ON
DISCRIMINATORY MARKETING AND
BENEFIT DESIGN PRACTICES THAT
HAVE BEEN APPLIED IN THE
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
MARKETS SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
SB TWO EIGHTY ONE SURE THAT THE
LARGE GROUP PLANS ARE ALSO
PREVENTED FROM UNSCRUPULOUS
MANIPULATION OF MARKETING OR
BENEFIT DESIGN. THAT UNFAIRLY
TARGET CONSUMERS WITH EXPENSIVE
MEDICAL CONDITIONS ARE BASED ON
THE PROTECTED CHARACTERISTIC
SUCH AS RACE AGE OR DISABILITY
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT SB.
TWO EIGHTY AND REQUEST YOUR AYE
BUT- THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR. THE BREVITY BOTH THE
WITNESSES LET'S GO AHEAD MOVED
OTHER WHAT AND SOME- SCENE- AND
GALLERY LET'S MOVE THE ROOM TO
FORTY. NO ONE AND TWO FORTY SO
LET'S THEN MOVE ON TO
TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB TWO EIGHTY- AND THAT
WOULD MAKE NOTE GAIN THE-
THERE'S THE SNOW REGISTERED
OPPOSITION- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. TECH COMMAND
AGAIN ONE. ZERO IN ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE GIVE THEM THEIR
LINE YES AND THEN AGAIN IT'S
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
AND- MODERATE BEFORE WE BEGIN
IF YOU CAN JUST TELL ME HOW
MANY PEOPLE ON THE LINE. RIGHT
NOW WE ONLY HAVE ONE PERSON
OKAY WHAT'S GOING ON. IN ORDER.
ALIGN TWO HUNDRED NINETY NINE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. SO
JENNIFER MALLEY WITH A
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
IS ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE. IT
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
PEOPLE WISHING TO COMMENT ALL
RIGHT THEN LET'S MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION FOR TESTIMONY. AS
ANY TESTIMONY OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY SCENE NINE LET'S MOVE
THE ROOM TO FORTY SEEN NONE
MODERATOR WE PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WE'VE TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO EIGHTY-
FOR THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. PAN MISTER CHAIR I SHOW
NO ONE QUEUING UP TO COMMON ALL
RIGHT EXCELLENT. PAGE THERE'S A
MOTION THE BILL FROM CENTER
GROVE I GET THAT RIGHT ALL
RIGHT ARE THERE OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ABOUT THE BILL.
OKAY SAYING NONE I THINK THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT STEP FOR A
CONTINUE REFORM CENTER LIMóN
WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO THE
MOTION AS MOVED BY CENTER GROVE
IS DUE PASSED THE FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY- SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM
LINDA'S. MELINDA'S I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE AND SALAS HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. GROWTH I HER
TADO. FOR TOTAL AYE LEYVA ALL
RIGHT LEYVA AYE LIMóN AYE.
STONE AYE ROSS. AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. OKAY YEAH WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE. OKAY THIS IS A
CENTER RUBIO COMING BACK- SHE
HERE. OKAY I'LL PUT THE WILL
THIS RIGHT NOW THE VOTE THAT
HAS A TEN VOTES SEPARATE THE
BILL ON- ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS LET'S MOVE ON TO- ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE ELEVEN IS
CENTER WE SELL HERE. TO TEST
RIGHT NOW OKAY ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT. SENATE HUESO WELCOME
ATIONS. OKAY RIGHT UP TO THE
PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN I'VE BEEN
THAT WE ARE A LITTLE SHORT ON
TIME I DO KNOW YOU HAVE SOME OF
THE STUFF REGISTERED OPPOSITION
BUT- PLEASE GO AHEAD BEGIN YES
THANK YOU AND I'LL TRY TO KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF BUT- TODAY A
PRESENTING SB THREE ELEVEN THE
COMPASSION AND ACCESS TO
MEDICAL CANNABIS ACT ALSO KNOWN
AS RAIMES LAW THIS IS A BILL
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
HOUSES LAST YEAR ACTUALLY WE
GOT IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK-
WHERE WERE. GIVEN THIS BILL
ANOTHER TRY BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL- THE
COMPASSIONATE THE BILL THAT'LL
HELP A FAMILY STRUGGLE BEEN F.
DURING THE DIFFERENT MOST
DIFFICULT TIMES OF FACING THE
END OF THEIR LIFE- HERE WE
HAVE- UP UP. THE FATHER OF RYAN
BARTEL JIM BARTEL WHO WHO WILL
TESTIFY TODAY AND ENSURE WITH
US ARRANGE STORIES AND THE
EVENTS LEADING TO THIS BILL'S
INTRODUCTION- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
HAD A VERY PROACTIVE
CONVERSATIONS SO FAR WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WILL BE MEETING SOON
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
INCLUDING UP POTENTIALLY SO
MEETINGS WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. TO EXPLORE A LANGUAGE
THAT WE THINK THAT WILL TO HELP
PERSUADE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RELATED TO THIS BEER FOR THIS
BILL WE ARE CONFIDENT WE CN
REACH AN AGREEMENT TO GET THIS
DONE BY THIS YEAR WE THINK THE
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM IS A
SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS BUT EXERCISING OVER
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE GET THE LANGUAGE
PERFECTLY- CORRECT- SO- I'LL
I'LL DEFER MY TIME. TO JIM
BARTEL WHO'S ON THE PHONE PHONE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE. HEATHER
MANAGED TO NURSES CEO CAN CAN
BUSINESS NURSES NETWORK. AND
EVERY DAY WERE GAINING NEW
SUPPORTERS TO THIS BILL WITHIN
THE MEDICAL INDUSTRY SO I THINK
WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER AWAY SO-
THE- LET'S PLEASE BRING ON- JIM
BARTEL ON TO THE PHONE LINE
FIRST. AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
I'M HERE TO BE HERE AND- YES
AND THEN I WILL MEMBERS OF THE
HEARING YES WE CAN PLEASE BEGIN.
OKAY I IMAGINE BY JOHN AND THE
FATHER RYAN MARTEL AND SPONSOR
OF SENATE BILL THREE ELEVEN.
BRANCH LOST. RYAN IS WHITE HE
BOTH WORKED IN THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION WITH MOSTLY AUTISTIC
CHILDREN. WHO THAT GOT TAKEN
NOT ONLY SPECIAL SKILLS BUT
ALSO GREAT PATIENCE AND
COMPASSION. BRIAN HAD THOSE
QUALITIES AND HE WAS VERY
EFFECTIVE WITH THE STUDENTS. I
HAVE A SON CONNOR WILL BE
TWELVE YEARS OLD. SIX AND MARCH
FIRST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
RYAN CALLED ME AND MY WIFE. THE
DALLAS THE AND DIAGNOSIS STAGE
FOR PANCREATIC CANCER. AND ONLY
A FEW WEEKS TO LIVE. I COULDN'T
REALLY BELIEVE WHAT I WAS
HEARING AND MY HEART. SANK IN
THE TEARS SWELLED. HE WAS IN
THE HOSPITAL THE BIRTHDAY MARCH
NINE. HE DIED ON APRIL TWENTY
FOR AT SEVEN WEEKS AFTER THE
DIAGNOSED. WHAT HAPPENED
BETWEEN MARCH FIRST ENABLE
TWENTY FIRST EIGHTEEN AT LYING
I'M HERE TODAY. IN THE HOSPITAL
RIGHT WAS GIVEN MORPHINE. AND
OTHER OPIOIDS FOR PAIN RELIEF.
THOSE WEREN'T STRONG ENOUGH SO
THE ADAGE RENDELL. WHICH IS ONE
HUNDRED TIMES MORE POWERFUL
THAN WORKING. THE RESULT WAS TO
THE SLEEP MOST OF THE TIME.
DURING ONE OF THOSE. RARE
WAKING MOMENT SHE SAID TO ME.
HE DIDN'T WANT SPEND AS FEW
SLEEPING. IT'S ONLY ONE TO BE
ABLE SPEND TIME WITH HE
ENCOUNTERED. PARENTS BROTHER
AND SISTER AND MANY FRIENDS. TO
GET THE MEDICAL CAMPUS IN
ALTERNATE WHICH HE TO. WE HAD A
MEDICAL CARE CHEMISTS CANNABIS
MEDICINES FOR PAIN RELIEF. ARE
WE INFORMED BY THE HOSPITAL
THAT IT'S THEIR POLICY NOT TO
ALLOW CANNABIS IN HOSPITAL. THE
IRONY THAT POLICY IS THAT THE
PENDULUM AND OTHER OPIOIDS KILL
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE A
YEAR U. S. OKAY TO HAVE MY
HOSPITAL. THAT MEDICAL. CAMPUS
WHICH IT NEVER KILLED ANYONE.
AT CORE HAVE WE RE THE TRANCE
TO ANOTHER HOSPITAL A LOT OF
THE CANNABIS. BECAUSE HE COULD
SWALLOW ANYTHING EVEN WALK. THE
CHEMISTRY A MEDICAL CANNABIS
SPRAY MINISTRY UNDER THE TIME
CONSTRAINT. THE RESULT WAS A-
WAIT AND ALERT DURING THE HE-
HAVE OUR STATION. CURRENTLY AND
I WIFE'S BROTHERS OTHER IN
FRIENDS WITHOUT PAYING THE DEBT
THING IS SLEEP BUT NOW THE
MEDICAL CANNABIS PROVIDE
LIMITED ALL YOU LIFE FOR IS
FINE TWO ONE HALF WEEKS IT'S
ABOUT TELNET. OF COMMERCE THAT
ARE TELLING THAT YOU TO WRAP UP
SORRY TO TWO MINUTES IS UP. HI
I NEED A LOT. ONE ONE MINUTE.
IN A LOT OF DAMAGE BUT THE
FAMILY AND TO REMINISCE LAUGH
WITH ME FRIENDS TO VISIT EVERY
TERMINALLY ILL SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
AND TO SPEND FINAL DAYS THE
MUCH DIGNITY POSSIBLE. THEY ARE
DONE WHY WOULDN'T THAT FOR THEM
DURING THE PAST WEEK HAVE MET
WITH CALIFORNIA HOT BECAUSE YOU
CAN GET ACCESS YOU TO WRAP UP.
HE JUSTICE PLEASE OKAY THANK
YOU OKAY IN CONCLUSION THE
HAPPIEST MOMENT. MY LIFE. BUT
WHEN I. FIRST TIME I HELP EACH
MIGHT CHILDREN WERE BORN. SHE
HAD A SMALL LIKE THE KOBE
BRYANT HAND TOOK A CLASS. I
HOPE IT THE STATUS MULLIN WILL
BE MADE LESS PAIN BY AND- THAT
RISE LAW WILL ALLOW THOUSAND
OTHER CURRENTLY PATIENTS. SO
THAT THEIR FINAL DAYS WITH
EQUALITY AND DIGNITY BUT HE WAS
ABLE EXPERIENCE PLEASE SUPPORT
RIGHT AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY- MISTER
BARTEL APOLOGIZE BUT WE- HAVING
TO CUT IT SHORT BUT WE ARE ON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO HAVE THEIR MEANNESS
WITH THE CONGRESS NURSES
NETWORK- BECAUSE THE FIRST
WITNESS STEADY OVER TIME I'M
GOING TO ASK IF YOU TRY TO KEEP
YOUR REMARKS VERY BRIEF SO WE
CAN KEEP TO OUR TOTAL TIME
LIMIT OF FOUR MINUTES PER SIDE-
SO- NURSE. HEATHER MENACE
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU I'LL DO
MY BEST. MY NAME IS HEATHER
MAIN S. NOTICED HEATHER AMONG
PATIENTS AND COLLEAGUES I LIVE
IN SAN DIEGO AND A WIFE A
MOTHER A GRANDMOTHER AND HE'S
BEEN A REGISTERED NURSE FOR
TWELVE YEARS. SPECIALIZING IN
HOME HEALTH END OF LIFE MENTAL
HEALTH IN INDIA CANNABINOID
JUSTIN CARE. IN MY ROLE AS
PRESIDENT. OF THE GLOBAL
NURSING ORGANIZATION BASED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. PRETTY SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS NURSES
NET NETWORK AND OUR MEMBERSHIP
TO STAND UNIFIED IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF SB THREE ELEVEN
RYAN BLOCK. AT THE NURSING
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT PATIENTS BY
BEING IN THEIR HOME ONE OF THE
MOST PROFOUND THINGS I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT HOME BOUND INTO
BLIGHT PATIENTS OVER THE YEARS.
HOW MANY OF THEM USE CANNABIS
MANAGE SYMPTOMS. PAIN ANXIETY
DEPRESSION. INCREASED APPETITE
SLEEP QUALITY COMFORT. AND
THEIR OVERALL QUALITY OF LIFE.
THIS EXPERIENCE WAS ESSENTIAL
IN FURTHERING MY KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF CANNABIS
SCIENCE AND HOW PATIENTS ARE
FINDING RELIEF THREE SELF
ADMINISTERED CANNABIS USE. WITH
OR WITHOUT MEDICAL OVERSIGHT.
WHEN CARING FOR TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS EVERY MOMENT COUNTS
PEACE AND COMFORT COUNT.
QUALITY OF LIFE MATTERS. ALL
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
UNDERSTAND THE HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE PATIENTS ARE
TREATED WITH THE UTMOST
COMPASSION. THEIR WISHES ARE
GRANTED WHENEVER POSSIBLE AND
WILL MOVE HEAVEN AND EARTH TO
PROVIDE COMFORT MEASURES FOR
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS. WORKING WITH AND
CARING FOR THOUSANDS OF
PATIENTS I'VE LEARNED MANY
TIMES COMFORT MEASURES INCLUDE
CANNABIS. I'VE HEARD REPEATEDLY
OVER THE YEARS I DON'T WANT TO
DIE IN A HOSPITAL I WANT TO
LIVE OUT THE REMAINDER OF MY
MINUS. HUNDRED EIGHTY GAMES
WRAP UP PLEASE- HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS HAVE MANY TOOLS
ASSIST THE AN ARTICLE OF
THROUGH AND CLINICAL NURSES
HAVE COME AND THE AND OF ENDO
CANNABINOID SYSTEM CARE AND THE
VALUE AND BENEFITS OF
CANNABINOID THERAPEUTICS- AFTER
MORE THAN A DECADE ACCORDING TO
CANADA PATIENT I CAN
CONFIDENTLY TESTIFIED THAT
PATIENTS REPORT FEELING BETTER
WHICH IS THE PURPOSE OF
PALLIATIVE CARE NOT TO CARE. TO
HELP PATIENTS BUILD BETTER
SEPARATE LAND CAN BE A PLEASANT
AND PRESENT A POSSIBLE FOR
THEIR MARK TWAIN THANK YOU YOUR
TIME PLEASE SHOW COMPASSION
FAVORING JOHNSON AT. ELEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT LET'S. MOVE ON TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE ELEVEN UP IN THE
GALLERY SINGLE AT THE GALLERY
COMPLEX ROOF TO ROOM TO FORTY
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO TEST MY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE ELEVEN. ON THE TELEPHONIC
LINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
CALM IN SUPPORT OF THAT TO BE
THREE ELEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. RECOMMEND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AGAIN A REMINDER
ITS NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
ONLY- WE ARE RUNNING A LITTLE
SHORT ON TIME SO- WE HAD SOME
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY ALREADY SO
AGAIN- PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
ARE MODERATE HOW MANY- TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TESTIFYING. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
EIGHT PEOPLE WAITING TO OKAY
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN UP THE
LINES AND- ASKED IF PEOPLE
COULD PLEASE. GET NAME POSITION
THE NAME OR IS THIS A POSITION
ONLY. LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. PICTURE
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF KHALIFA ONE THE LARGEST
CANNABIS COMPANIES IN THE IN
THE STATE YOU'RE VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE THREE HUNDRED NINETY
YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. WHY THREE
HUNDRED NINETY HERE MY COULD
OPEN. LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR
MIKE ITSELF. I AM HERE
ARMSTRONG DIRECTOR OF INDUSTRY
AFFAIRS FOR AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS. ALL SEE EACH YEAR. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION.
PRINCE FOR SAFE ACCESS TO THE
NATION'S LARGEST OLDEST
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENTS.
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
COMPASSIONATE SELL. A.
COALITION OF TROPICS CANNABIS.
THANK YOU NEXT NEXT LINE PLEASE.
THE LINE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY YOUR
MY KIDS UP.HELLO TONY BOTH
HERE BAY AREA CHAPTER OF
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS WE
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT LINE. THE
LIGHT OF FOUR HUNDRED THIRTEEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI EDDIE
FRANCO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU NECKLINE. LINE
FOUR HUNDRED SEVEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. I WISH TO CREATE ON
THE HAPPENED EVEN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXTER LINE.
LINE FOUR HUNDRED FIVE YOUR
MIKE AT THE- HI MY NAME IS ALEX
TACKLE I'M IN THE LEGISLATIVE
AND PUBLIC POLICY CLINIC AND
THE MAJORITY SCHOOL OF LAW IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONE FOUR HUNDRED TWELVE YOU'RE
MY COULD OF. THIS IS DOCTOR
LAWRIE RETURN EMERGENCY
POSITION. I SERVE ON THE MARIN
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND LAST NIGHT OUR
BORDER IN SUSIE ASKED ECCLES
VOTED FOR ZERO. TWO SUPPORTERS
SENATE BILL THREE ELEVEN. THANK
YOU EXLINE. BLIND FOUR HUNDRED
FOR YOUR MY COULD OPEN. HI THIS
IS ERIC HOFFMAN BERMAN CHOICE
OF LAW LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC
POLICY CLINIC IN SUPPORT OF IT
HELLO. Q. I'VE COUNTED EIGHT
TEST FIRES SO FAR HOW MANY MORE
PEOPLE ON THE LINE. WE HAVE ONE
MORE WAIT OKAY ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO IN HERE. LINE TWENTY THREE-
MY KIDDO. I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE THIS IS SERRA
ARMSTRONG I AM ALSO THE POLICY
CHAIR FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COALITION AND WE
JOINED AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE STUFF. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. RIGHT AS ANYONE ELSE ON
THE LINE. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER PEOPLE WAITING TO
PROVIDE COPYRIGHT THANK YOU. IT
NOW IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE THE
LEAD OPPOSITION IS ALICE
HAWTHORNE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE BRING ALICE
HAWTHORNE ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. REALLY
MISTER CHAIR L. STOP ON
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
REGRETFULLY WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL. I WOULD DRAW THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION TO THE
ANALYSIS- THERE WAS A VETO
MESSAGE FROM GOVERNOR NEWSOM ON
A NEARLY IDENTICAL BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. WHICH SAID I
QUOTE HEALTH FACILITIES CERT
RECEIVE PAYMENTS. FROM THE
FEDERAL CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES MUST
COMPLY WITH ALL FEDERAL LAWS IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE SERVICES
THEY PROVIDE. BUT STILL THAT
OVER TIME WOULD CREATE
SIGNIFICANT CONFLICTS BETWEEN
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW. I WOULD
ALSO- NO MISTER CHAIR THAT
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH
IS THE ENFORCING AGENCY FOR.
THE FEDERAL CERTIFICATION
STANDARDS ALSO NOTED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE TO CITE
DISABILITIES FOR ALLOWING THE
USE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS. BY
PATIENTS. HE J. IS NOT OPPOSING
VIEWS OF CAN. HOWEVER THE
LARGEST AS WITH. BUT HOSPITALS
AND THE TO THE- AT THE MIDDLE
ASKING. IS FOR THE BILL TO BE-
APPLE APPLICABLES ONLY IF
MEDICAL CANNABIS IS REMOVED
FROM SCHEDULE ONE OF THE
FEDERAL CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
ACT THANK YOU YEAH. YEAH I
THINK IT'S GONNA BE TWO RUSSIAN.
THANK THANK YOU- THANKS SO MUCH
FOR YOUR- TESTIMONY. LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO- TO SB THREE
ELEVEN- SEEN DONE IN THE
GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SAY NOT IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- MODERATE PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE ELEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CARE FOR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THE COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THEN. ZERO AND MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW NO ONE QUEUING UP
TO COMMENT OKAY THANK YOU- THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. R. EIGHTEEN YES OUR
GROWTH BRIEFLY THANK YOU I AM I
AND A MINISTER PORTED TODAY BUT
I WOULD ASK YOU IF YOU CONTINUE
TO WORK. THROUGH THE CHAIR
WITH- CJ. THEY DO AVE A VALID
POINT THAT IT DOES VIOLATE
FEDERAL LAW AND THEY WOULD BE-
IN JEOPARDY OF LOSING THEIR
FEDERAL THUNDERING AND SO I
JUST ASK YOU TO WORK WITH CJ TO
MAKE- BOTTOM AND IT CAME TO
PASS. PLEASE YES THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH-
CENTER MELENDEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU SO OUR SERVER BRING
THIS BILL FOR FORWARD I AM A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
AND- HI I CAN'T IMAGINE. YOU
KNOW WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO GO
THROUGH THIS AS A PARENT AND I
GREATLY APPRECIATE THOSE WHO
TESTIFIED AND SHARED THEIR
PERSONAL STORIES WITH US. ABOUT
WHAT WAS LIKE TO GO THROUGH
THIS EXPERIENCE WHICH IS JUST.
HEARTBREAKING. HERE'S A THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU. RIGHT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ARE COMMON THE BILL
AND THERE'S A MOTION FROM SAN
MELENDEZ- SORRY THANK YOU FROM
THIS BILL FOR I'VE BINDING THAT
WANTED IN THE BILL IS THAT IF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ISSUES A
NOTICE OR LETTER OR SOMETHING
TO THE HOSPITAL SAYING THAT
THEY WILL BE DENYING PAYMENT
BECAUSE OF- BECAUSE THE
HOSPITALS ALLOWING THIS TO
HAPPEN THEN THE HOSPITAL
ACTUALLY CAN- SAY THE NO LONGER
ALLOWED IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY IS GOING TO
PENALIZE THE HOSPITAL SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BILL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT- MISS
SHARON MEMBERS AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF COURSE THE
BILL IS WRITTEN TO PROVIDE A
SAFE HARBOR FOR- THESE
FACILITIES THAT DO ALLOW THIS-
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT MAKE SURE WE
STRENGTHEN THE LANGUAGE BUT-
YOU KNOW GIVEN THAT- THE
ENFORCEMENT HASN'T EVEN FUNDED
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL- TELLS US
THAT THIS. THESE ARE THESE IS
TO SHOW WHEN IT BE. IN JEOPARDY
OF THE- SO. AND IF THAT HAPPENS
WE CAN DEFINITELY TAKE ACTION
BECAUSE THE BILL ALLOWS FOR
THAT- CHECK. EXEMPTION TO BE TO
BE MADE SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS AND I
APPRECIATE. ALL ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT AND ALL YOUR ATTENTION
TO THIS. BILL WHICH WE THINK.
WE CAN. MAKE A LOT OF PROGRESS
ON THIS YEAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
HUESO THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SUMMERLAND DOES THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AM
LINDA'S AYE LINDA'S AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ VICE AND
SALAS I GROWTH. RIGHT GROVE I
pLEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE LIMON I.
LIMON AYE ROTH ALL RIGHT. ROTH
AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE WIENER ALL
RIGHT WIENER AYE OKAY THAT
AROSE OUT LEVIN ZERO THANK ALL
RIGHT. OKAY SO- WE ARE. DOWN TO
SEARCH THEIR LAST EIGHT MINUTES
SO WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS. HI I'M
GOING TO HOLD OVER ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB TWO FIFTY BECAUSE
THERE IS OPPOSITION TO THAT
BILL BUT I'M HOPING THAT-
SERMON WONDERS IF YOU DON'T
MIND TAKING UP THE GAVEL FROM
YOUR DESK. I'LL TRY TO PRESENT
SB FOURTEEN SB THREE TWENTY SIX
AN EXPEDITIOUS MANNER AND-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET TO THAT
ITEM AND THEN WE WILL TAKE A
PURCHASING CALENDAR TO GO
THROUGH- MISSING MEMBER SO-
WITH THAT. SIR MELINDA'S- MAY
BEGIN TESTIMONY. HEY- SENATE
OPINION TO YOU- WE WOULD YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND PRESENT SB
THREE TWENTY SIX OKAY THANK YOU
AGAIN THIS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
SB THREE TWENTY SIX- THIS IS A
BILL TO ALLOW THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS OF THE ACA TO STAND
IN CALIFORNIA EVEN IF THE
EASIEST- OF REPEALED- THAT'S
INCLUDING PROTECTIONS AGAINST.
DISCRIMINATION IT'S PEOPLE PRE
EXISTING CONDITION EXCLUSIONS
THE REQUIREMENT OF PLANS HAVE
TO SELL YOUR POLICY REGARDLESS
YOUR HEALTH STATUS RENEWED A
POLICY MATTER WHAT KIND OF
ILLNESS YOU MAY BE DIAGNOSED
WITH THAT ALSO BUT RESTRICTIONS
ON PLANS ME CREASING PREMIUMS
WE GET SECOND ENSURES THAT THE
CENTRAL HEALTH BENEFITS ARE
COVERED BY HEALTH PLANS SO-
THE- THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN THESE PROTECTIONS-
WITH THAT I HAVE TO WITNESSES
SUPPORT WHICH ARE ASKED TO BE
VERY BRIEF AND OCCURRED A
TESTIMONY- DIANA DOUGLAS AND
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA CHEN
FLORI FROM THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY EXPECT WE
ASK FOR AND I THOUGHT. THANK
YOU CENTER. OKAY MISTER
MODERATOR WE HAVE DIANA DOUGLAS
ON THE PHONE YES. YES GOOD
ONLINE IT OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
BY CERTAIN MEMBERS DIANA
DOUGLAS WERE HELD ACTIVE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE HEALTHCARE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY SIX
WHICH WILL REMOVE FROM CAL
CALIFORNIA STATUTE HIGH BACK
THAT MAKE YOU CONSUMER
PROTECTION CONTINGENT UPON THE
FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
REMOVING THE OUTDATED OVER
THERE DIFFICULT PRODUCTIONS
THAT CALIFORNIANS RELY ON EMILY
WILL DIMINISH THE RELIANCE. OF
CALIFORNIA LAW AND FEDERAL LAW.
THE PATH WEEK TO GET HEALTHY
COULD JUST. AND PEOPLE BRITAIN.
RENDERING THE AND ENSURE. SOME
WHO HAD COVERAGE ON THE ABOUT
YOUNG INSURANCE THAT WE'RE NOT
PAPER BY STATING CARE AND
HEALTH PLAN COULD USE
DISCRIMINATORY RATE SETTING
PRACTICES. AT PROTECTED AGAINST
ALL OF THIS AT THE TIME THIS
HAPPENED A DECADE AGO THERE IS
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
STRUCTURAL STABILITY AND HOW
THE QUALITY TO PLAY YEAH. THE
CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENTED A NEW
PROTECTIONS WE'D HAD THEM BACK
THE FEDERAL PROVISIONS AT THE
PAPER. THAT. WE CAN HELP FOR
DECISION. EIGHT OUT NOW THAT
CONGRESS IS FAILED TO THE- AND
HEALTH. HAS ENACTED OWN INTO
MAN IT'S TIME TO REMOVE THE
OUTDATED CONNECTIONS. THE
FEDERAL STATUTE FOR THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORT ACTUALLY
TWENTY SIX AND REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER DOUGLAS MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN THE LINE UP TO
CHEN FLORI PLEASE FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. GEN FLORES LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD MISREADING
ASSISTANCE LAURIE FROM. SORRY
BY- BY CHAIR THIS IS JENNIFER
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND IN AN EFFORT TO
KEEP THIS BRIEF ALL THE FOCUS
ON A FEW OF THE PROVISIONS AND
WHAT THEY MEAN FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR- THE PRE
EXISTING CONDITION EXCLUSION
PROTECTION I HAD IS SOMETHING
THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE COME TO
RELY ON PRIOR TO HAVING THAT
LOW INCOME PATIENTS. WHO FEARED
THEY MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD HEALTH CARE IN THE
FUTURE WORKRATE TO BE
FORTHCOMING WITH THEIR DOCTORS
ABOUT THEIR CURRENT HEALTH
NEEDS WHETHER THAT BE DIVULGING
A HISTORY OF SMOKING OR SORRY
MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS WE NEED
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS THAT
PROTECTION WON'T GO AWAY.
SIMILARLY WITH THE RATE
STANDARDIZATION PROTECTIONS
SINCE THE ACA PASSED
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT ALGORITHMS IN USE
INCLUDING ACTUARIAL RATES ARE
DETERMINING CREDIT WORTHINESS
AS MANY HAVE BEEN FOUND A
PERPETUATE RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION WE ABSOLUTELY DO
NOT WANT TO GO BACK TO A TIME
WHEN RATES ARE BASED ON THAT
THE LESS CHARACTERISTICS THAT
YOU EASILY EXACERBATE EXISTING
RACIAL DISPARITY. AND FINALLY
WITH THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS PRE ACA PLANS
TYPICALLY DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
WOMEN BY EXCLUDING SERVICES
THREE BLADED TO PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH AND DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES BY EXCLUDING
HABILITATED SERVICES AMONG
OTHERS THAT THEY NEED IF THE
ACA WORK ALL WE WOULD NEED A
MUCH MORE ROBUST CONVERSATION
CALIFORNIA'S HOW WE CAN PROTECT
OUR PRIVATE HEALTH COVERAGE
MARKET BUT WE MUST GUARANTEE
THAT WE DON'T RETURN TO THE PRE
ACA STATUS QUO WITH
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON HEALTH
STATUS GENDER AND RACE WITH
BUSINESS AS USUAL. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
NIGHT OF THANK YOU MISS FLOYER
WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY NAME TOLD THERE ARE
NONE TIMES WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
I SEE NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TESTIFIED VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MISTER
MODERATE. WOULD YOU PLEASE
PRACTICE INDIVIDUALS. ORBCOMM
IN SUPPORT OF SB. THREE TO SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO.
THAT CAN AGAIN ONE. SEVEN ZERO.
WE HAVE THREE PEOPLE QUEUING UP
TO PER COMMON OUR CALVET FROM
TO NINETEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS JENNIFER MALLEABLE THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE OF FOUR HUNDRED NINETEEN
YOUR MIKE IT UP. HI GOOD%
EVENING ENGAGE BE ACTED ON
BEHALF OF S. C. A. CALIFORNIA
HEARING ARGUMENTS THE COURT FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. OUR NEXT WITNESSES
LINE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTEEN YOUR
MY KIDS UP. USING KANSEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BACKUP NETWORK
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MURRAY CAN YOU CHECK ONLINE
TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING A
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
ONE MORE WITNESS FROM LINE.
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY.
KELLY THIS IS KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU- IS THAT
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT. MISTER
MODERATE THAT IT EVERYONE OKAY
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS ONE ON POLICY IN
PROCESSING HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO VISITOR
IDENTIFIED OPPOSITION I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE IS SO WE WILL GO
THEN TO MOVE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY WITH THERE ARE NONE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE ARE NONE
MISTER MODERATE WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINE UP TO THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
AND PLEASE LET ME KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE YOU HAVE ON THE LINE IF
ANY. SHARE OR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND I SHOW IT NO ONE SHOWING UP
TO PROVIDE A TESTIMONY. OKAY
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR- YOU
WANT TO CHECK ONE MORE TIME
JUST TO BE SURE SO DON'T LEAVE
ANYBODY OUT. OF COURSE FOR
COMMON IN OPPOSITION TO AT B.
THREE TWENTY THIRDS PLEASE
PRESS ONE. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE THEN. ZERO AND I FEEL SO NO
pWHEN THERE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
FROM THE MEMBERS NO SEEING NINE
BILLS TO PAY DR PAYMENTS LIKE
CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WOULD YOU PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLL CALL VOTE ACTUALLY I THINK
WE STILL NEED A MOTION HELLO
I'M SORRY THAT WE HAD ONE OKAY
SORRY APOLOGIZE- YES SENATOR
LEYVA MOVED EARLIER RIGHT YES.
OKAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS. AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PAN BY HAND HI
MELINDA'S I. LEARNED AS I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ. HI
GONZALEZ AYE GROVE. AYE GROVE
AYE HER TADO. FOR TOTAL AYE
LEYVA ALL LEYVA AYE LEóN HI
LIMON I ROTH. FIVE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE. SEVEN ZERO
ELEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL PUT THAT A BILL ON CALL
FOR ANY ABSENT MEMBERS I KNOW
WE'RE GOOD IT'S OUT. OKAY
FORGET IT'S A CONSOLATIONS.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH OF A STIR
MELENDEZ- WE ACTUALLY COMPLETED
USING THE PHONE LINE EXACTLY
WHAT WE NEED TO STOP USING IT A
FIVE THIRTY THANKS TO YOUR
SKILL. AND AND THE SPEEDY
EXECUTION NEXT ITEM IS OUR
CONSENT ORDER. FOR ITEMS ITEM
NUMBER- NINE SEP CENTER AG S.
B. THREE SIX. I AM NUMBER TEN
ROCK SB THREE FIFTY THREE I'M
NUMBER ELEVEN SEVEN AYE BATES-
SB FOUR THIRTY FOUR AND I'M
NUMBER TWELVE BY MYSELF- TAN S.
B. TWO TWENTY SIX IS OUR MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. IT'S
BEEN MOVED- SECRETARY. THANK
YOU FOR THE BREAD AND BUTTER
THE MONEY EITHER. DELETED AND-
SO RIGHT AT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IF YOU FIND HAND BY
HAND HI MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I
EGGMAN HELPS OKAY. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. HI EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I GROWAYE
GROVE AYE HER TADO FOR TOTAL
AYE LEYVA ALL LEYVA AYE LIMóN
AYE LIMóN AYE ROTH. ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER. AYE
WIENER AYE RIGHT CONSENT
CALENDARS APPROVED ELEVEN ZERO
IT'S OUT NOW LET'S GO BACK AND
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS-
WHICH IS GOING FILE ORDER ITEM.
YEAH OKAY SO FIRST OF ALL-
HELLO ACTUALLY NO I DON'T KNOW
WHICH WAS VERY PASSED OUT
REMIND ME SO FIRST WE'LL START
WITH THE ITEM NUMBER ONE HER
TADO SB FORTY SIX EIGHT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
AMOUNT. LIMON HI. ELEVEN THAT
BILLS OUT ELEVEN ZERO. OKAY
THANK YOU OUR NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER TWO BY DORADO SB FIFTY
SIX SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE
GROVE NO HER TITLE. HURTADO I
LIMON HI LIMóN HI. WHAT'S THE
ACCOUNT RIGHT. OKAY THAT BILL
IS OUT NINE TWO. EXPOSED I
NUMBER THREE SB FIFTY SEVEN BY
CENTER WIENER SIX SIX THESE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELENDEZ. NO AND NO MELENDEZ
NOW. PORTATO. NOW HER TOTAL NO
LIMON HI LIMON I RUBIO. JUST OF
DANGER LOADING SO. PROBABLY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN DOES THAT
BILLS OUT SEVEN THREE. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B.
TWO THIRTY FIVE BY CENTER ALLEN
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS- TADA. I HURTADO
I OKAY THAT BILLS L. ELEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU NEXT IS- ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB TWO FORTY TWO
AND A PHONE AND WE ARE ASKING
OF NOW WE FINISH THAT ONE OKAY
CLOSE THAT ONE OUT AND THEN WE
FINISHED AT. NUMBER. EIGHT WHEN
I HEAR. OKAY SORRY NUMBER YES
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SORRY I'M LATE SHE DISCUSSED
WITH ME ABOUT THE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. HOLD ON A SHE'S GOT ALL
TANGLED UP HERE. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR I APOLOGIZE FOR ME JUST
GET THIS STRAIGHT OKAY PHYLUM
LET'S SEE HOW COME THAT WAS
MISSING. ON THIS ISSUE OKAY
LET'S MOVE ON THE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. SB TWO EIGHTY BY
SALAMONE SECRETARIES CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS RUBIO HI
RUBIO I. WHAT'S. THE BILL IS
OUT ELEVEN ZERO. ANY OTHER
ITEMS. THAT'S IT OKAY- THAT
COMPLETES THE AGENDA OF THIS
HEARING AS THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH AGAIN AS A REMINDER
WE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN WILL.
SB TWO FIFTY BY HAND IS GOING
TO BE HELD OVER. ALL THE
MEMBERS- AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU AT WEDNESDAY SO WITH
THAT OF THE COMPLETION OF THIS
AGENDA OF THE SENATE HEARING
AND SAY CAMINO HEALTH WE ARE
JOINED. OKAY DISPATCH.